REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE WILL COME TO ORDER. AND
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
IN THE CAPITOL WITH SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. TODAY I AM HERE IN
THE ROOM AS IS ONE OF THE
MEMBER I THINK TO ARRIVE DR AT
PAN AND SENATOR MELENDEZ WILL
BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I S. IT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
RECOGNIZE THAT USER RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MEET. PLEASE SELECT A MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING WITH
OUR IT PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU WERE DONE
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS. WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS. DUE TO PUBLIC HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REMOTELY THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL.
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
DISCONNECTION OR HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN IS
CLOSED AS THE SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
WAIT TIMES WE ASK FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AND TO BE RESPECTFUL
OF ALSO THAT ALL PARTICIPATED
INTERESTED PEOPLE CAN
PARTICIPATE. I IN TODAY'S
BUDGET HEARING WILL REVIEW THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS FROM VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS FOR. THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HOSPITALS THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
COVER CALIFORNIA. RENESSE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE TO
READ THE PROPOSALS LISTED IN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S AGENDA WILL
FALL THE ILLEGAL PRESENTATION
WITH COMMENTS FROM THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THEN
PROCEED ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
OKAY SO IT'S GONNA BE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TODAY BUT WE'RE GOING
TO GET ALL THROUGH IT AND- I
HOPE FOR OUR ILLEGAL FOLKS
OTHER GOOD READING VOICES ON
TODAY BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
DOING THE READING FOR US- AND
NOW WILL. BEGIN SO MISTER HIT
OKAY THERE YOU GO ALL RIGHT.
THANKYOU SENATOR EGGMAN
ACCORDING TO SHEILA FROM THE L.
A. L. IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU
I'LL JUST GO AHEAD AND- READ
THESE PROPOSALS INTO THE RECORD
SEQUENTIALLY- FIRST SET OF
PROPOSALS ARE IN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY- CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION REQUESTS
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. TO SUPPORT THE
PROJECT ECHO HE ENTERED MENTAL
HEALTH GRANT PROGRAM A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM TO
PRINT BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALISTS AND COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS AND EDUCATORS- NEXT
THE NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP
REQUESTS GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF THE
FORTY THREE THOUSAND AND-
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
TO SUPPORT A WORK GROUP IN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCYTO ASSESS THE
FEASIBILITY. FOR CALIFORNIA'S
POTENTIAL TO STREAMLINE
MEDICARE FUNDING TO COUNTIES
FOR HOME VISITING SERVICES.
NEXTERA PROPOSALS ARE IN
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES-
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA REQUEST EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE MILLION- HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND THIRTY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION FEDERAL FIND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. AND THE THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- THREE AND TWENTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND THIRTY
MILLION FEDERAL FINE ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO SUPPORT EXPANSION
OF MEDICARE HOW TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE SENIORS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS BEGINNING
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND JUSTICE IN AGING
REQUEST EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
OF A HUNDRED AND TEN POINT ONE
MILLION FIFTY TWO POINT NINE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND FIFTY
SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND TWO HUNDRED
NINETEEN POINT SIX MILLION
HUNDRED AND FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND A
HUNDRED FOURTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS. ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO ELIMINATE THE
ASSETS TEST FOR MEDIC CAL
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS FOR
DISABILITIES EFFECTIVE JANUARY
FIRST TWO TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
TO INCORPORATE CERTAIN DATA
ELEMENTS REGARDING THE LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS INTO
ITS MANAGED CARE PLAN CONTRACTS.
THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE GROWTH
ALREADY OF THE FORTY MILLION IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND MAKE TO BRIDGE LOANS
TO THE THIRTY FOUR DISTRICT AND
MUNICIPAL HASTA HOSPITALS TO
AID IN THE TRANSITION. FROM THE
PUBLIC HOSPITAL REDESIGN AND
INCENTIVES IN MEDIC CAL CRIME
PROGRAM AT QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM UNDER THE STATE'S
EXPIRING ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVER
TO THE QUALITY AND CYNICAL Q.
I. P. PROGRAM- THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWELVE MILLION
ANNUALLY. IN 202-122-2020 TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR TO CONTINUE.
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT AND TO
BUILD AN EQUITY AND INCLUSION
CORE WITHIN THE C. R. C. SYSTEM.
THE CALIFORNIA OPIOID
MAINTENANCE PROVIDERS REQUEST
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF NINE
POINT TWO MILLION- TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY AND AT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO GRANT
AUTHORITY TO DH CS TO EVALUATE
AND IMPLEMENT CHANGES TO THE-
NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAM
ALLOWING NEW DRUG AND DISEASE
TESTING. THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK AND THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF ONE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND THIRTY THOUSAND
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO. FIELD
TEST TRANSLATIONS OF MEDI CAL
MATERIALS AND COLLECT
ADDITIONAL DEMOGRAPHIC DATA AS
PART OF THE EQUITY DASHBOARD.
TOTALLY KIDS SPECIALTY HEALTH
CARE- FROM SUN VALLEY REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF ONE MILLION TO
EXTEND THE 10% REIMBURSEMENT
RATE INCREASE IMPLEMENTED
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. OR FREESTANDING
PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE FACILITIES
THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. B.
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES NETWORK
GROUP REQUEST EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF EIGHTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION. NINE POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND NINE
POINT THREE MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS TO EXTEND FOR SIX MONTHS
THE 10% REIMBURSEMENT RATE
INCREASE IMPLEMENTED DURING THE
CALL THE NINETEEN ENDEMIC FOR
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AGAIN FROM THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES NETWORK BY THE REQUEST
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE
DCS AND DDS TO CONVENE A
WORKGROUP TO ADDRESS GOVERNANCE
PROCEDURES AND PROCESS THESE
PERTAINING TO THE TRANSITION
OF- HI CFTC'S FROM THE FEE FOR
SERVICE TO THE MEDIC CAL
MANAGED CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
UNDER THE CALTRAIN INITIATIVE-
THE END OF THE EPIDEMICS
COALITION REQUEST ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY. OF SEVEN MILLION TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASE SERVICES
COVERED BY THE FAMILY PLANNING
ACCESS CARE AND TREATMENT OF
THE FAMILY PACKED PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MENTAL HEALTH PEER RUN
ORGANIZATIONS THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE REQUEST EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION. FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS TO SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM PURSUANT
TO S. B. EIGHT OH THREE-
CARAPACE REQUEST TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE INDIVIDUALS
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE FOR A
PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY- THE PACE
PROGRAM ARE AWARE THAT CASE IS
AN OPTION AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ASSESSED AND
ROLE BEFORE BEING ENROLLED IN A
MANAGED CARE PLAN UNDER THE
MANAGED CARE TRANSITION
INCLUDED IN THE- CAL AIM
INITIATIVE. CAL PACE AGAIN
REQUEST TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO MAKE PERMANENT THE
REGULATORY FLEXIBILITIES
PROVIDED TO PACE ORGANIZATIONS
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THAT ALLOWED
PACE ORGANIZATIONS TO SAFELY
CARE FOR AND PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THE FRAIL SENIORS THAT AS
ORGANIZATIONS SIR. THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
REQUEST EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
OF EIGHTY MILLION FORTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND FORTY MILLION
FEDERAL FUND TO PROVIDE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR MEDICAL
DENTAL PROVIDERS FOR PANDEMIC
RELATED COSTS. OF NEW MANDATORY
MEDICALLY NECESSARY INFECTION
CONTROL. HE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION REQUEST EXPANDED
OUR GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF FORTY MILLION
AVAILABLE FOR ENCUMBRANCE OR
EXPENDITURE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FOUR TO CONTINUE THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PILOT PROJECT WHICH
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS. B. CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC AND PROSTHETIC
ASSOCIATION REQUESTS
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF NINE
MILLION FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS TO
INCREASE MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR PROVIDERS OF ORTHOTICS AND
PROSTHETICS. PRIVATE ESSENTIAL
ACCESS COMMUNITY HOSPITALS
REQUEST EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
FIFTY MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
SEVENTY MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS
TO IMPLEMENT A SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS ADJUSTMENT FACTOR OR
REIMBURSEMENT OF CLAIMS PAID TO
SAFETY NET HOSPITALS THAT
PROVIDE CARE FOR. MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES. A COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
THE FIRST FIVE CENTER FOR
CHILDREN'S POLICY THE MARCH OF
DIMES THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP- MATERNAL CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS AND THE FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
REQUEST EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
OF A HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
FIFTY FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS- IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. AND TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION A HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND A HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO EXTEND PREGNANCY
ONLY MEDICARE COVERAGE FROM
SIXTY DAYS POSTPARTUM TO TWELVE
MONTHS AND TO EXTEND CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE FOR ALL CHILDREN UP TO
AGE FIVE. THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY REQUEST TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO PERMIT
FEDERALLY ALLOWABLE FLEXIBILITY
IN THE ACCEPTANCE OF TELEPHONIC
OR ELECTRONIC. SELF ATTITUDE AT
THE STATION OR- OTHER.
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR.
MEDI CAL. THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
IS MEDICINE COALITION REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF NINE POINT THREE
MILLION ANNUALLY IT CONINUES
SUPPORT FOR A PILOT PROJECT
THAT PROVIDES MEDICALLY
TAILORED MEALS TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. THE CALIFORNIA
CLINICAL LABORATORY ASSOCIATION
REQUESTS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF FORTY MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
REMOVE THE CAP ON MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CLINICAL
LABORATORIES FORGIVE
RETROACTIVE RECRUIT RECRUITMENT
OF REIMBURSEMENT REDUCTIONS AND
DELAY OTHER REDUCTIONS UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE NATIONAL
COALITION FOR ASSISTED AND
REHAB TECHNOLOGY REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY
OF TWO MILLION ANNUALLY TO
ELIMINATE THE 10% MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE DEDUCTION
ENACTED BY AB NINETY SEVEN. R.
FOR COMPLEX REHABILITATION
TECHNOLOGY. C. H. E. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF
THREE MILLION ANNUALLY AND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
DUALLY ELIGIBLE FOR BOTH
MEDICARE AND MEDI CAL AND WHO
RESIDE IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. THE CALIFORNIA THE-
ALAMEDA POINT COLLABORATIVE AND
LIFELONG MEDICAL CARE REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE AT THE
READY OF THE FIFTEEN MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
TO SUPPORT CONSTRUCTION OF A
MEDICAL RESPITE AND HEALTH
CLINIC BUILDING AT THE ALAMEDA
WELLNESS CAMPUS TO SERVE ON
HOUSING BILLS AND SENIORS WITH
COMPLEX HEALTH CONDITIONS. B.
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY REQUEST
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF A
HUNDRED MILLION TWENTY FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN SEVENTY
SIX MILLION FEDERAL FUNDING
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
THIRTY SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND A HUNDRED FOURTEEN MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. AND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION AND
SIXTY MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
A HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. TO CREATE A MEDIC
CAL BENEFITS SUPPORT OUR TO
FIND HOUSING SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR BENEFICIARIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND PEOPLE WHO
WERE HOMELESS AND ARE NOW
RESIDING IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
THE CALIFORNIA CHIROPRACTIC
ASSOCIATION REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
ANNUALLY. TO RESTORE
CHIROPRACTIC BENEFITS IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM. THANKS THE
PROPOSALS ARE IN PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. A COALITION OF COUNTIES
COUNTY HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS AND
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS
REQUEST ANNUAL GENERAL GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS IN STABILIZATION
AND ADDRESSING THE NEEDS AND
ISSUES FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SEIU. SEIU CALIFORNIA REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES
ALREADY- THREE POINT TWO
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. TO CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION OF LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
STAFFING WORKFORCE NEEDS AND
RESOURCES. IN ORDER TO
ACCURATELY AND ADEQUATELY FUND
PUBLIC HEALTH. A COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
THE LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE AND ROOTS OF
CHANGE REQUESTS GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION.
AVAILABLE FOR ENCUMBRANCE AND
EXPENDITURE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FOUR TO IMPLEMENT A CALIFORNIA
HEALTH EQUITY FUND WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE INCREASED FUNDING FOR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CLINICS AND TRIBES. ARE
COMMUNITY BASED INITIATIVES AND
PROGRAMS THAT RESULT IN
DECREASED RISK FOR PREVENTABLE
ILLNESSES AND ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
EXACERBATED BY COLD NINETEEN.
THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES COALITION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER REQUESTS CAL GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURES FORTY OF
FIFTY MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AVAILABLE FOR
ENCUMBRANCE OR EXPENDITURE
UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE TO EXTEND
AND EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT.
FOR SEIU CALIFORNIA REQUESTS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO PHASE
OUT WORK FOR SHORTAGE AND
PATIENT ACUITY WAIVERS FOR
STATUTORY STAFFING REQUIREMENTS
AND SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES
REQUESTS GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TO EXPAND THE
ALL CHILDREN THRIVE PILOT
PROJECTS TWO HUNDRED NEW CITIES
OVER FIVE YEARS. THE GOLDEN
WEST CHAPTER OF THE- ALS
ASSOCIATION REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
THREE MILLION ANNUALLY TO
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THE CURRENT
ALS WRAPAROUND TREATMENT MODEL
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO AN
EVIDENCE BASED MODEL OF CARE.
AND KEEP PACE WITH THE GROWTH
IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
DIAGNOSED WITH ALS OR LOU
GEHRIG'S DISEASE. THE END THE
EPIDEMICS COALITION REQUEST
EXPENDITURE THE ALREADY FROM
THE AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM REBATE FUNDS THE
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT PRE
EXPOSURE. PROPHYLAXIS
DELEGATION IN RETENTION
SERVICES RETENTION SERVICES. B.
AND B. EPIDEMICS COALITION ALSO
REQUEST EXPENDITURE FUND
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY
OF A HUNDRED MILLION AVAILABLE
OVER FIVE YEARS TO SUPPORT THE
PURCHASE OF HEPATITIS C. VIRUS
TEST KITS ASSOCIATED MATERIALS
AND SUPPLIES TRAINING FOR TEST
COUNSELORS. AND THE STAFFING TO
SUPPORT EIGHT TEST KIT PROGRAM.
AND THE EPIDEMICS COALITION
ALSO REQUESTS GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF THREE
MILLION ANNUALLY TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASE PREVENTION
AND CONTROL ACTIVITIES. AND THE
EPIDEMICS COALITION ALSO
REQUESTS GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF THREE
MILLION ANNUALLY TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE DPH OFFICE AND
AIDS SYRINGE EXPLAINS EXCHANGE
SUPPLY CLEARING HOUSE. THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP REQUEST
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF THIRTY MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
SUPPORT KOBE NINETEEN RECOVERY
EFFORTS FOR COMMUNITIES DEEPLY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC
THROUGH GRANT PROGRAM THAT
ENCOURAGES PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS AND LEGAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SUPPORT FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
B. TRANS- LET NEXT COALITION
REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
FIFTEEN MILLION ANNUALLY TO
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING OR INTERSEX
INDIVIDUALS. THE CALIFORNIA
WAKE ASSOCIATION REQUEST
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY AS FOR THE
EIGHTY FOUR WEEK LOCAL AGENCY
CONTRACTS WITH THE PH THEY'RE
AN EXEMPTION IN THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTING CODE- HE MICHAEL J.
FOX FOUNDATION REQUEST TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO EXTEND OR
REPEAL THE SUNSET DATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PARKINS IS.
PARKINSON'S DISEASE REGISTRY.
NEXT PROPOSALS AND DEPARTMENTS
THE HOSPITALS THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
REQUEST TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO PROHIBIT THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS FROM BILLING
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES FOR
THE COST OF CARE DURING
PLACEMENT. NEXT PROPOSALS IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
OVER OERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
CHILDREN NOW REQUEST GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
EIGHTY POINT FIVE MILLION. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL GRANTS FOR
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS
AND COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO CHILDREN.
NEXT APOSTLES AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF FOUR
HUNDRED TO FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY FOR THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT EXTENSION OF THE STATE
SUBSIDY PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
HEALTH INSURANCE AFFORDABILITY.
IN THE COVERED CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFITS EXCHANGE. AND
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA ALSO
REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES ANNUAL GENERAL
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF. FIFTEEN AND
NINETEEN MILLION IN TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW STATE
LEVEL PREMIUM SUBURBS SUBSIDIES
TO COVER THE ONE DOLLAR PER
MEMBER PER MONTH PREMIUMS. ARE
STATE ONLY COVERAGE FOR ALL
COVERED CALIFORNIA MARKETPLACE
ENROLLEES. AND THAT THAT IS IT
THAT'S ALL THE PICKLES AND- FOR
THE RECORD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- KAMALA
OKAY I THINK RIGHT I THINK I'M
NOT ECHOING MORE THAT'S GOOD I
DON'T KNOW- DOCUMENT IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO BUY
ANY OF THESE YOU WANT TO GO TO
CALLS RIGHT NOW OR HOW WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PROCEED. MAYBE JUST
MAKE A FEW BRIEF REMARKS- SO
AGAIN FIRST OF ALL I WANT THANK
THE L. A. FOR- READING ALL
THESE PROPOSALS CERTAINLY- I
THINK IT WILL NEED TO BE
CONSIDERING THEM- AS THE YEAR
GOES ON AND- AND AS FOCUS ALSO
WON'T GET TO ME REVISED WE HAVE
A BETTER IDEA OF OUR REVENUES
AS WELL AS OTHER ITEMS AS WELL
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO JUST THAT
MAYBE MAKE NOTE OF- SOME OF
SOME OF THE THINGS ARE BY FIRST
OF ALL I KNOW THAT- TERMS OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURES
WERE GOING THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC WE NEED TO BE SURE
THAT WE- SUBSTANTIALLY.
STRENGTH AND IT'S- NOT JUST FOR
THE MEDIA BUT FOR THE FUTURE
SO- EIGHT IT'S GONNA
IMPORTANCIA CAPITAL FUNDS MAY
COME AROUND AS WELL- SO AND-
HOPEFULLY WE WILL HAVE A-
ESTIMATE WAS PASSED BY
CONGRESS- MAY TAKE A FEW DAYS
THEY HAD READ SIX HUNDRED
SOMETHING PAGES LAST NIGHT OR
SOMETHING SO- BUT BUT WE'LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS THERE I ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT- YOU KNOW WE IS A
STATE- ACTUALLY- SUBSIDIZED.
WITH PEYTON PROVIDE SEVERAL
FLAT AND TRIED STATE FUNDS TO
HELP MAKE- COVERED CALIFORNIA
MORE AFFORDABLE AS PART OF OUR
EFFORTS TO EXPAND COVERAGE
WHICH IS AT ACTUALLY BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN FACT THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE'VE REDUCED PREMIUM
INCREASES OCCURRED CALIFORNIA
OF INCREASED BY LESS THAN ONE
PERCENT- SO- SO CERTAINLY- I
THINK- HOPEFULLY AGAIN- THERE
MAY BE ELEMENTS IN THE FEDERAL
THAT MAY AFFECT- THE- THE-
STAKEHOLDER REQUESTS IN TERMS
OF- MODIFICATION TERMS OF WHAT
THE STATE WOULD STILL NEED TO
DO TO DO THAT BUT SOMEHOW I
KEEP AN EYE ON THAT BECAUSE
IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
DOING. THE ONE THAT DROPPED
THAT OFF- I WOULD ALSO MAKE
NOTE. THAT- THE SENATE HAS. IT
HAS. PETER LEE- PAST- AND
PROPOSE IN OUR BY- COVER FOR
AND I. SENIOR SO- YOU KNOW KNOW
THAT'S HOPEFULLY WE WILL CAN.
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. AND
THEN- FINALLY- SO MAKE NOTE
THAT- IS WE TRY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF STRUCTURAL RACISM AND
RACISTS- AND- EQUITY THAT- IF
THE BUDGET IS A- STATE OF OUR
PRIORITIES- IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
SIMPLY DECLARE RACISM PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS WE NEED TO PUT
RESOURCES BEHIND ADDRESSING.
THIS STRUCTURAL RACISM SO I
HOPE WE CAN. LOOK AT THAT
CERTAINLY THERE'S MANY OTHER
PROPOSALS AND NOT GOING TO.
COMMENT ON ALL OF THEM HERE
RIGHT NOW- BUT I DID WANT
HIGHLIGHTS ON THESE LARGER
PROPOSALS THAT I THINK THAT.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING-
HOW THEY MAY. EVOLVE ESPECIALLY
LOOKING ALSO LOOKING AT WHERE
TO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE THERE ARE
COMBINED WITH WHAT OUR STATE
CAN DO TOGETHER. THANKS VERY
MUCH. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THOSE COMMENTS. THANK YOU
VERYYES AS A AND I KNOW I KNOW
I HAVE MET WITH MANY OF THESE
GROUPS THAT. INVEST FOR
SEPARATE MEETINGS WITH ME AND
WE GOT A LOT OF MEETINGS AND- A
LOT OF REALLY GOOD IDEAS HERE
IN. THE SOCCER PANTS AT ONE OF
OUR AND I CERTAINLY HEARD THAT
FROM A GROUP YESTERDAY. AFTER
BEING ABLE TO. NOT ONLY JUST
ACTED TO HELP OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE RECOVER. BUT
REALLY PLAN FOR THE FUTURE
GOING FORWARD- BALL SCENE I
THINK THE- IMPORTANT WORK THAT
THAT HAPPENS AND WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE HAVEN'T FUNDED IT
ADEQUATELY. I'M IN AND I'M
PEOPLE KNOW I HAVE A- REALLY
HUGE INTEREST IN MENTAL HEALTH
AND ESPECIALLY AS IT. ACROSS
THE CONTINUUM SO- WILL BE
LISTENING WITH A LOT OF
INTEREST. GOING FORWARD AS OUR
DEPEND SAYS WE STILL HAVE TO
WAIT FOR THE TO SEE WHAT COMES
WITH THE FED SHOULD AND SHE WAS
LEFT IN THE BUDGET. A LOT OF
VERY GOOD WORTHY IDEAS
SUBMITTED FOR SO THAT WILL BE
GIVING. I AM CONSIDERATION TO-
AND I GUESS WE CAN THE ILLEGAL
COMPLAINT THEIR BLESSINGS TODAY
THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO READ
FIRST SIX SIX SIX HUNDRED PAGES
BUT JUST KEEP IT JUST A FEW-
ANY ANYTHING FROM THE- OFFICE
OF FINANCE. I THANK YOU SHARING
AND MEMBERS RYAN MILLER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY SAY THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY TO HEAR ABOUT THE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT OUR DEPARTMENT IS
MET WITH MANY OF THESE- GROUPS
AND THE AGENDA SO FAR THIS YEAR
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE DISCUSSIONS TO.
BOTH LEARN ABOUT THEIR IDEAS
FOR INVESTMENT BUT ALSO GATHER
THEIR FEEDBACK ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL- AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS IN THE
COMING MONTHS AND WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO GET THROUGH
THE REST OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND- WORK TOWARD A FINAL BUDGET
PLANNING CHEN. SO WHILE WE
CAN'T BE SUPPORTER BUT OF ANY
OF THESE IDEAS TODAY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T. FIT WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FRAMEWORK I
JUST WANT TO AGAIN REITERATE
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONTINUING NETWORK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS ALL
IS ALL PART THE PROCESS NOW
WE'VE HAD. IS OUR LAST.
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING BEFORE WE
COME BACK FOR THE MAY REVISED
FOR PUTTING THE WHOLE BUDGET SO
THERE'S A LOT OF TIME STILL-
BUT WE APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S.
BEING ENGAGED IN IN GETTING
THIS DONE EARLY SO. I THINK
WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- AND HEAR PEOPLE'S
COMMENTS ARE OR AT THAT THEY'D
LIKE TO MAKE IT THIS TIME AND
AGAIN WE ASK PEOPLE. IN ORDER-TO. LIMIT OUR TIME ALL TOGETHER
HERE IN THIS BUILDING AND THAT
IS MANY PEOPLE PARTICIPATE AS
POSSIBLE WE ASK THAT YOU. TRY
TO MAINTAIN YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE IN PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES BEFORE YOU- FOR YOU
BEGIN. OKAY MODERATOR WE READY
TO GO. YEAH ALL SET THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LADIES AND- ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PUT YOURSELF IN QUEUE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO. IN AT
T. OPERATORS GOING TO GIVE YOUR
LIFE NUMBER OFFLINE. IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE YOURSELF OUT OF
THE QUEUE PLEASE I JUST PRESS
THE ONE ZERO COMMAND AGAIN. OUR
FIRST- QUESTIONS IN THEIR
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL COME FROM
LINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M NOT SURE MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY COMMENT THIS IS CAT
BURKE FROM THE HEALTH OFFICERS
AT THE AGE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
IN SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUEST- THE NEW
YORK TIMES SAID THAT THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING CYCLE IN
THIS NATION IS. NEGLECT HANNEKE
REPEAT AND IT'S TIME TO STOP
THAT CYCLE FAVORITE OPPORTUNITY
AND BUILD UP OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH IN THE STATE IN
PREPARATION FOR THE NEXT
PANDEMIC THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN FIFTY
TWO YEAR YOU ARE OPEN. DID YOU
MEET YOURSELF FIFTY TWO. MOVING
ON- AND I'M SURE WE WILL LINE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HI THIS IS
STACEY HER MODEL I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF RAM COAL THE RACIAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
COALITION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS. OF THE PROPOSAL TO
SUSTAIN THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT. THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT IS PERFECTLY TIMED
AS THIS WOULD ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND MITIGATE
THE EFFECTS OF COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AS WELL. AS THE
LARGEST EFFORT IN ESTABLISHING
COMMUNITY DEFINED EVIDENCE
PRACTICES THAT WILL REDUCE
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES FOR
RACIAL ETHNIC AND LGBT
COMMUNITIES. THIS GROUND
BREAKING PROJECT MUST BE
SUSTAINED AND EXTENDED FOR THE
FULL THREE YEARS THAT WE ARE
ASKING. FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NICE TO TALK TO TODAY IN A ROW
STATING THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU. WE WILL LINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS
MACHEL GIVEN WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE THAT THE
PATIENT CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND HERE
TO REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR
REQUEST FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WORKFORCE. THE FUND WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO
REBUILD STAFFING LEVELS WHICH
IS BEEN ABOUT IT IN THE PAST
DECADE IN ADDITION OR QUESTION
YOUR SUPPORT OF THEIR BUDGET
REQUEST TO FIND A PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
ASSESSMENT. WE KNOW LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS NEED
IMMEDIATE IMPACT THAT ENTIRE
WORKFORCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NOW BUT WE KNOW THAT EVEN WITH
ITS INVESTMENT THE NEEDS ARE
GREAT THE COMING ON THE HEELS
OF THE PANDEMIC IT'S IMPORTANT
TO EVALUATE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATE BACK IN
A COUPLE WORKFORCE NEEDS AND
RESOURCES NEEDED TO ENSURE AN
ADEQUATE. LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WE CALIFORNIA CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT PUBLIC
HEALTH PRACTICES WE MUST INVEST
IN REBUILDING PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE INFRASTRUCTURE TODAY
AND WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
BECAUSE THE BUDGET REQUEST WILL
MOVE FORWARD IN THAT DIRECTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
FORTY YOU ARE OPEN. YES HI- MY
NAME IS CAN YOU HEAR ME OKAY
I'M SO SORRY. GO AHEAD PLEASE
YES. YES HI MY NAME IS TANYA
YOUNG ADAM AND I AM THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK COULDN'T
HELP PROJECT AND I SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE EXTENSION OF
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THE
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA DUE
TO THE SEVERITY PROJECT WHICH
IS AN UNPRECEDENTED HISTORICAL
POPULATION POLLUTION THAT HAS
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE IN THE
STATE THE NATION AND EVEN
PERHAPS INTERNATIONALLY. THE
LITTLE HEALTH OUTCOME
DISPARITIES BUT A STATEMENT
POSSIBLE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
POPULATIONS BUT DOESN'T TAKE.
THIS INVESTMENT IN THE
CONTINUED. FINDING OF THE- AND
SO I THINK. THE FIFTH MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THREE YEARS. OF
CONTINUE OF THE CALIFORNIA.
THIRTY FIVE TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE WERE LINE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANY
BLOOMBERG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES STAFF ONCE EXPRESSED
THEIR STRONG CONCERNS WITH SB
IDEAS PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE-BACKING LABOUR'S UTILIZED BY
NURSING FACILITIES FOR VERY
SPECIFIC INSTANCES. WHERE
FACILITIES UNABLE TO FIND AND
HIRE THE NEEDED DIRECT CARE
STAFF EVEN PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC NURSING WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES WERE SIGNIFICANT IN
LONG TERM CARE AND NOW DURING
THE PANDEMIC THESE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES HAVE BECOME EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED. WE SHOULD NOT
CONSIDER ELIMINATION OF THESE
WAIVERS AND SO WE'VE ADDRESSES
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND
RECOVERED FROM OUR CURRENT
CAN'T. CASH THE COURT ALTHOUGH
THE ITEMS BOB COMPANY AND MEDIC
HOW. FOR PBS SUB ACUTE
FACILITIES AND ITO THE BEYOND
THE PANDEMIC. BY CONTINUING THE
CAMPUS INCREASE FOR THE- AS
WELL AS THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO PAY THEIR CARE GIVERS. AND
HEALTHCARE STAFF ADEQUATE WAGES
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN THEM.
ALSO WE SUPPORT THE BUDGET
ITEMS THAT WILL ESTABLISH A
WORKER FOR A CFPB AGES AND THEN
THEIR TRANSITION TO MANAGED
CARE WITHIN. THE CALENDAR
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. THIS PLEASE. WE WILL GO
LIVE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE MEMBERS KATHY MUSTARD
REFUSING THREE CLIENTS ON THREE
DIFFERENT SHOES FIRST ON BEHALF
OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
NETWORK REPRESENTING THE
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
AROUND THE STATE WE SUPPORT
BOTH THE CONTINUED CAL THE
NINETEEN REIMBURSEMENT
SUPPLEMENTAL THROUGH FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OUR
FOLKS HAVE BEEN AT THE RATE
FROM. A WINDOW NINE AND THE
SUPPLEMENTAL ABOUT OUR HOMES TO
STAY OPEN AND SECONDLY ON
BEHALF OF THE STANDALONE
PEDIATRIC FACILITY IN
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE SUFFERED
FROM THE SAME RETREAT SO WE
DON'T NINE THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS HAVE BEEN A LIFE
FLIGHT WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE CONTINUED COOPER
NINETEEN SACRAMENTO RIGHT
THROUGH THE NEXUS YEAR WE ALSO
FOR BOTH THE I. CFPB'S
UNDERSTANDABLE. THE CALLIN
LANGUAGE THAT WILL HELP US
BETTER TRANSITION KELLY LAST
BUT FAR FROM LEAST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA- DISPENSED IN
COALITION WITH SUPPORT THE
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS I
DON'T THIS GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT WILL ALLOW THE
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE TO
DO TO PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED
NUTRITION INTERVENTIONS. TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS WE LOOK
FORWAD TO WORKING WITH BOTH
THE LEGISLATURE THE
MINISTRATION AS WE REPORTED TO
THE BUDGET NEGOTIATION AND HELP
THESE AUGMENTATION
AUGMENTATIONS WILL STAY IN THE
FINAL TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO.
THE MORNING MADAMMEMBERS OF
THE- ON WE WITH THE POINT KALAU
WITH THE PROJECT SPONSOR OF
ALAMEDA WELLNESS- CAMPUS FOR
BOTH THE MEDICAL RESPITE AND
THE SENIOR HOUSING COMPONENT-
WE ARE REQUESTING FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN A GENERAL
FUND TO BE SPECIFICALLY
EARMARKED FOR THE MEDICAL
RESPITE. HEALTH CLINIC AND
RESOURCE CAMPUS BUILDING. WHICH
WILL BE THE FIRST PURPOSE BUILT
HIGH ACUITY RECRUITMENT OF CARE
CAMPUS IN THE STATE DESIGNED
FOR HOMELESS ADULTS WITH HIGH
LEVEL MEDICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS. THE PROJECT
CREATES A NEW STANDARD OF CARE
FOR ON HOUSE PEOPLE LIVE. UP
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOR HUNDRED TWENTY ON HOW
SENIORS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY. BOB
INCLUDING CASE MANAGEMENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
HOME SUPPORT AND END OF LIFE
CARE. RECUPERATIVE CARE STAYS
IN HOSPITAL STAYS WITH HOUSING
PLACEMENT FOR ANOTHER HUNDRED
FOUR HUNDRED GIVE ME FOUR
HUNDRED ON HOW. ALAMEDA COUNTY
RESIDENTS ANNUALLY AND
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
SERVICES FOR ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED RESIDENTS ANNUALLY IN
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA. THE
PROJECT HAS ATTRACTED NATIONAL
ATTENTION INCLUDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- BANDS OF LAND AND
FACILITIES VALUED AT ALMOST TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. THE CITY
COUNTY AND PRIVATE FUNDERS AND
INVESTED HAVE ALREADY COMMITTED
OR WIND UP OVER SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE OVERALL NINETY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS WELLNESS
CAMPUS. LEAVING A GAP OF TWENTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS. ROGER HAS
NEARLY COMPLETE DESIGN ENTIRE
AND THIS PROPOSED FIFTEEN
DOLLARS WILL ENABLE APC TO
QUICKLY FINALIZE THE FUNDING
BREAK GROUND. AND DEVELOPED THE
FIRST PURPOSE BUILT MEDICAL
RESPITE CAMPUS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR THIS VITAL PROJECT IN
SUPPORT OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
COALITION FOR ASSISTIVE AND
REHAB TECHNOLOGY WHERE THE
PROVIDERS AND MANUFACTURERS OF
COMPLEX REHAB TECHNOLOGY WHICH
IS A SMALL SUBSET OF DME THAT
SERVE YOU VERY SMALL POPULATION
OF ADULTS AND CHILDREN WITH
SEVERE PHYSICAL DISABILITIES.
KILEY ACT THIS IS A QUICK
MINUTE CENTRAL TO KEEPING THE
BONNEVILLE PATIENTS IN THEIR
HOMES AND OUT OF HOSPITALS AND
I YOU BET. AT THE BEGINNING OF
TWENTY TWENTY RIGHT BEFORE THE
SHUT DOWN OUR RATES WERE TIED
TO THE UPDATED MEDICARE FEE
SCHEDULE WHICH CONTINUES TO
DECLINE YEAR OVER YEAR ON TOP
OF THAT THERE. WE ARE STILL
SUBJECT TO THE 809710% RATE CUT
THAT WAS MEANT TO BE TEMPORARY.
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION
HAVING AT THE PERCENT CUT ON
TOP OF THE DECLINING MEDICARE
FEE SCHEDULE THE PLANT DATABLE
HEY WILL FORCE OUR MEMBERS TO
CHANGE THEIR DELIVERY MODELS WE
ARE CONCERNED THESE CHANGES
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY HARM OUR
MEDICAL PATIENT POPULATION
THEREFORE WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
OUR BUDGET REQUEST TO RESTORE
THE 10% RATE CUT THE COMPLEX
REHAB TECHNOLOGY. AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY WE HAVE HAD
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND APPRECIATE THEIR
THEIR- OPEN DOOR POLICY ON THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK SURE CAN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. EIGHT EIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH HI MY NAME BROWN
WITH GENDER SPECTRUM WANNABE
IPP PROJECTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
OUR PARTICULAR WORK FOCUSES. I
AM. IT WRAPPED CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL I'M SPEAKING TODAY AT
THE PORT OF THE PROPOSAL
BECAUSE THE STATE IN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING THE CREDIT
PROJECT THE ALLOCATION OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
WILL BE SHUT DOWN FOR THE PAST
YEAR WE KNOW THAT MANY
TRANSGENDER AND OTHER DEMOCRATS
YOU ARE LITERALLY TRAPPED IN
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
NOT BURNING OF THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY THIS LACK OF
AFFIRMATION LEADS TO A SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH DISTRESS AND
NEGATIVE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
OUTCOMES. YOU'RE THE CFRB ART
PROJECT BEEN BUILDING THE
CAPACITY OF. AFTER A PERSONAL
LEARNING EXPERIENCES AS WELL AS
WITH THE IMMINENT RETURN OF
STUDENTS TO THEIR SCHOOL I HAVE
BEEN DESCRIBED THE PROJECT IS
ONE BASED ON A RIGOROUS
EVALUATION- AND IT'S UNLIKE ANY
IN THE COUNTRY BRINGING
TOGETHER POPULATION- LGBT ACTED
IN THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AND
NATIVE AMERICAN INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE BEGGING
THE CAN CREDIBLY IMPORTANT WORK
THROUGH THE ALLOCATION OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME AND YOUR HEAVY
LIFTING WITH THAT WOULD BE
PRETTY. AMAZING AND THEY HAVE
GREAT PROJECT THAT INSURANCE
CAN BE HARD TO MAKING CHOICES
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND
SIXTY SO PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH
ACTIVISM MUST ANGELES THANK YOU
FOR MANAGED CARE AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE ABILITY TO
COMMENT TODAY I'M SPEAKING IN
pCOVERAGE FOR TWELVE MONTHS
POSTPARTUM AND FOR CHILDREN
ZERO TO FIVE- 90% OF A CHILD'S
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT OCCURS BEFORE
THE CHILD TURNS FIVE. AND ONE
THIRD OF ALL PREGNANCY RELATED
PREGNANCY THROUGH ONE YEAR
OCCUR AFTER PREGNANCY WITHIN A
WEEK TO A YEAR OF THE
PREGNANCY. AND THAT RATE IS
HIGHER THREE TO FOUR TIMES
HIGHER FOR BLACK WOMEN AND
PREGNANT PEOPLE. MATERNAL AND
CHILD ACTORS WORKED WITH
THOUSANDS OF POSTPARTUM PEOPLE
TO ADDRESS THE POST PART OF
NEED TO GET THE METAL COVERAGE
OF POSSIBLE AND THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE ANNUALLY.
HOLD THE WOULD HELP IN DELAYS
IN CARE AND MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE SEE WITH
WOMEN AND CHILDREN. WHO ARE
LARGELY ALREADY ELIGIBLE
DRAMATIC HELL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
MEMBERS WILL NOT HAPPEN- FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP JOURNAL QUESTION
JUST UNDER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME TO
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY TO CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP TO MAXIMIZE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR HOME VISITING. THE
VAST MAJORITY OF FAMILIES
RECEIVING EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING ARE ENROLLED AT CAL
QUALIFYING THEM FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED UNDER DIFFERENT
MEDICAL BENEFITS INCLUDING
REIMBURSABLE SERVICES LIKE
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS SCREENINGS
FOR BLOOD PRESSURE SUBSTANCE
USE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH CASE MANAGEMENT HEALTH
EDUCATION. OUR STUDENTS WORKING
HARD TO EXPAND ITS CRITICAL
SERVICES IN TWENTY PUBLIC
HEALTH. HARD BY THE EPIDEMIC
SWEEPING OUR SYSTEM CAN WE HELP
PROGRAMS TO CO THAT RESPONSE WE
NEED EVERY TOOL AVAILABLE TO
MAXIMIZE OUR HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS TO HELP WORKING
FAMILIES RAISE HEALTHY BABIES
THEY HAVE MOMS HAD SAFE AND
HEALTHY PREGNANCIES. THE SUCH
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE SMALL ENOUGH TO
MOVE THIS WORK FORWARD WE'RE
ALSO HEARING SUPPORT FOR AND IF
HE ON THE REQUESTS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND WITH
THE WORK IF THAT'S NOT. AND
MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR POSTPARTUM
WOMEN AND CHILDREN FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I'M
CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE CLICK WITH CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. MY NAME IS DR
CATCHER RIDLEY WHILE THE AND I
AM THE LOCAL EVALUATOR FOR TO
BETTER MEET AN AMERICAN FAMILY
THERAPIST CALIFORNIA REDUCE THE
DISPARITY PROJECT WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING
FROM THE SURPLUS OF THE GENERAL
FUND OR ANY OTHER STATE BUDGET
START IF YOU'RE JUST THE SAME
THAT THE R. T. P. FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL YEARS. OUR TRAVEL
PROGRAM IS LOCATED IN THE WILL
BE TO THE HUMBOLDT. AND DEL
NORTE COUNTIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE THIRD DAY OF
AMERICAN YOU AGES EIGHTEEN. BUT
I REALLY A PART PROJECTS OUR
TEAM. ANYTHING THAT SOMETHING
THAT IS GOING TO A LONG LASTING
IMPACT. FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE PROGRAM HAS DEMONSTRATED
THAT CULTURAL PRACTICES CAN
INCREASE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
THANK YOU THE FAMILY
RELATIONSHIP. BUILDING TO BE
INSTRUCTING INTERTRIBAL
CONNECTION. WE KNOW THAT OUR
CULTURAL PRACTICES WERE
TARGETED THROUGH ATTEMPTED
GENOCIDE THAT BUILT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WE
PERSEVERED TO CONTINUE TO
RECONNECT TO OUR CULTURE THE
CEREMONY. WLL ALSO CONTINUE TO
FACE SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES
OF SUICIDE AND THANK YOU TO BE
IN OUR NATIVE COMMUNITY. ARE
YOU ARE CURRENTLY TELLING US A
BIT. IS IT. ONE CONSIDER. ON
HOW. IT IS TO THEM TO BE ABLE
TO CONNECT CULTURE THEIR OWN
THEIR TO THEIR- ARE YOU. HAVE
TO THINK THAT. ABOUT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. AND IF YOU'RE A
NEW P. OF DOING THAT. WE ARE
ALSO CONCERNED THAT THE OF HOW
COLD THE NIGHT HAVE. IF I OUR-
ESPECIALLY THROUGHOUT THE
INDIAN. AND WE- THAT PUBLIC
CALL. ARE YOU ARE GOING NEED AT.
THIRTEEN WE READ ABOUT THEIR
WITH THEIR- STOPPING A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS NOW WILL BE. DR TO
OUR COMMUNITY CAN YOU. THE
CALIFORNIA WOULD YOU BE IT'S
VERY. IN THE UNPRECEDENTED. I
WE ARE HERE BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO. THE OF OUR- AND HIGHLY ARE
YOU LOOKING TEACHING THE FINE.
WE SUPPORT PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIMES. THIS YEAR
THING I CAN DO P. THREE. YEARS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY TASK
PLEASE. I AM THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GOING. GOOD MORNING
INSURANCE SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JACQUELINE TRAN AND I THINK
SPECIAL SERVICES GROUPS THAT
YOUR GUESTS A CLOSER TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTED BY THE- DO THE
DISPARITIES PROJECT WE ARE TO
KEEP PASSPORT. COMMENTED IS OF
THE PER FIFTY MILLION AND
RUNTIME. FROM THE SERBS GENERAL
FUND DURING OTHER STATE BUDGET
THREE YEAR WE'RE JUST STAYING
AND EXPENSE TO YOUR FOR THREE
YEARS. I WORK IN SUPPORT OF
WORKING AFTER EIGHT PACIFIC
ISLANDER TO THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING OR COUNTY RIGHT
THAT. THIS THIRTY P. AND PRESS
HISTORIC ELATION SOLUTIONS
BASED IN RECORD DEVALUE FOR THE
INITIATIVE I CANNOT STRESS
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING TO AND
CULTURALLY THE GOOD CAN QUITE
PROVIDER AND PRESS. TO ADDRESS
HEALTH ARE. THIRTY P. FUNDED
PROGRAM TO LOOK FOR GAP IN
MENTAL PREVENT. THAT IS THE
CENTRAL REDUCING TO. RUNNERS
ARE CAL. ILLINOIS EVALUATED IF
I. DATA SOME OF OUR PROJECT SO
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE MICHELADA
DISCUSS FOR IMPROVED
PSYCHOLOGICAL. REPORTED EVER DO
PARKING. I. PROGRAM INCLUDING%
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
EVALUATION CREATING A MECHANISM
FOR STEALING THE PROGRAMS AT
THE LOCAL COUNTY LEVEL AND
DEVELOPING PLANS FOR PHASE
THREE THAT EXPAND SERVICES TO
ADDITIONAL SPECIAL POPULATION
AND- IMPLEMENT SPECIAL
ASSISTANCE CHANGE AT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL. I CAN'T I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THE PAST
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE RTP
FOR AN ADDITIONAL THREE YEARS
THANK YOU SENATORS FOR YOUR
TIME AT THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOST COLORFUL. WE WILL
ALIGN ONE OH THREE YOU ARE OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
BRENDA COPING WITH LIFE ON
MEDICAL CARE IN THE EAST BAY
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND BUDGET REQUEST FOR
THE ALAMEDA WILDER CAMP AT. THE
ALAMEDA WELLNESS CAMPUS WILL
PROVIDE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR SENIORS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
MEDICAL RESPITE INTEGRATED
MEDICAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE END OF LIFE CARE AND
PUBLIC PREVENTION THE STATE
CURRENTLY DOES NOT HAVE A
DESIGNATED FUNDING STREAM FOR
CREATING MEDICAL RESPITE
FACILITY BUT SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN METHOD FACT IF
COMPREHENSIVE MODEL WHICH HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO REDUCE ACUTE
CARE. AND EMERGENCY CARE COST
INFORMATIK WE IMPROVED HEALTH
AND HOUSING UP- FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS FOR
INSTANCE CIRCLE THE CITY
THROUGHOUT THE PROGRAM IN
PHOENIX BUT SHE COST SAVINGS
THE HEALTH SYSTEM OF OVER OVER
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE ALAMEDA
WELLNESS A CENTER WILL ALSO
FURTHER THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
TO HELPING TO END HOMELESSNESS
FORGET PREVENTABLE EMERGENCY
CARE AND HOSPITAL READMISSIONS
IMPLEMENT THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING AND SERVE AS A MODEL FOR
CALTRAIN IMPLEMENTATION THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIVE SEVENTY PLEASE
AHEAD. BY SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
ON MUTE. OKAY GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS DR GET JOHN
AT THE PRESENT CENTER HERE IN
FRESNO CALIFORNIA TODAY I'M
CALLING IN TO ADVOCATE FOR
SUPPORT OF FUNDING THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DESPITE A
PROJECT FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS WE ARE ONE OF THIRTY FIVE
IMPLEMENTED PILOT PROJECT UNDER
THE- AGE OF PACIFIC. ISLAND THE
HUB AND NOW A CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DESPAIR PROJECT IS
CALLED THE MOLE HELPING HANDS
IN THIS EMPLOYMENT IN FRESNO
COUNTY MYSTIC COUNTY STANISLAUS
COUNTY WHERE WE WORKED WITH
FORMER MOM REFUGEES AND THEN
TOGETHER THESE THREE COUNTIES
ACCOUNT FOR THE LARGEST
CONCENTRATION OF MALL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE FRESNO COUNTY
WE HAVE CLOSED ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND MILES THE
ORGANIZATIONS BRAVE MEN HEALTH
SERVICE YEARS ONLY 1% THE
LOWEST OF ANY UNDERSERVED ON
THROUGH GROUP IN THE COUNTY THE
WITH THE R. D. P. I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO IN THE- LAST THREE
YEARS IT'S BEEN ABLE TO HELP
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. IN THIS 1%
AND I BELIEVE THAT IS NOT ONLY
MAKING THE DIFFERENCE ANIMAL
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO THIRTY FOUR
OTHER UNDERSERVED AND UNSERVED
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I FROM ALL DIFFERENT
RACES GROUP AND ETHNICITY AND
THEN FOR THE MORE ARMONK
COMMITTEE I'M MORE HELPING
HANDS WE HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
WORK ETHNICALLY IMPROVE
PARTICIPANTS LEVEL DEPRESSION
ISOLATION SENSE OF WHAT OF WHAT
THE NEXT. STRENGTH IN THE BODY
MIND SPIRIT BEFORE AND AFTER
PARTICIPATE IN FEES
CONNECTIVITY SO THIS PROJECT
YES BUT YOU NEED. IT AND I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADRE WENT
A QUICK WE DO HAVE A MEMBER OF
THE- WOULD WISH TO COMMENT
SOMETHING. HERE IN THE BILL. SO
I WOULD YOU TO COME FORWARD.
THE INTERNET'S REALLY SLOW. IF
YOU JUST GIVE ME THIRTY SECONDS
BEFORE. WE CAN GO BACK TO THE
QUEUE WHEN YOU CAN AND YOU CAN
WAIT THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MODERATOR. THANK
YOU WE WILL LINE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING UNDER THROUGH LEON IN
EVERY CARE COORDINATOR WALKING
A KOREAN COMMUNITY SERVICE AT
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH CARE
CENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY THAT
HAS BEEN PROVIDING MULTIPLE
SERVICES LIKE CLINICAL
THERAPIES AND PUSHERS THE FOR
THE PAST THREE DECADES. AS A
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA LOSING
DISPARITY PROJECT WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
THAT THE FOR THE KOREAN
MONOLINGUAL POPULATION WHO HAVE
A LANGUAGE BERIA THEY NEED TO
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. I'M
CALLING TODAY TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE ON THE LIONIZE THE
FLORIDA REPORT FIFTEEN MILLION
IN ONE TIME FUNDING FROM THE
DIFFERENCE OF THE GENERAL FUND
OR ANY OTHER STATE BUDGET SO
EASIER TO SUSTAIN TO SEE ALL
THE FEES FOR THREE ADDITIONAL
YEARS AND EMPATHIZE WHY DO
SUPPORT WHAT I MEAN FOR TEN.
AND SHOULD TO THE EXTENT.
BECAUSE OF THE DEBTORS ON.
ISN'T IT THE TWENTY TEN ON MY
PUBLIC HEALTH ASSOCIATION SHOW-
COME FROM MANY OF THEM MIGHT TO
WHO'S THE PRO MENTAL HEALTH
EACH LIKE BE PRE ME TODAY YOU
CRIED. AND DINNER SYNDROME AND
LYFT CO GETTING AND A AND-
RECEIVE ALL CON SO FOR. AND
WORTH SIX WITH FIFTH FULLY AT
HIGH FULLY MILLER IN EVELYN- M.
A. R. LEVEL- SORRY YEAH HELLO
INTERPOLATION FOR OUR PRO DAY
CHAU EVEN IF THE TALLIED THE
KERR AS THE SITE. DISTRESS FOR
IN PRO SAY FONG AND THE PORTER
IT IS FAILING- BUT MY- AND
ISOLATION AFTER ALL CLIENTS
COMPLETE THE PROGRAM MANY
CLIENTS WHO WANT TOLEARN MORE
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
RESTORED. OR THEY'LL WHILE
BEING. THEREFORE PLAY COME
SUPPORTING APPROACH FIFTY
MILLION TIME FUNDING FROM THE
FLOOD OF THE FUND PHOTO IN
OTHER. STATE DIVERGENT WITH
THOSE TEETH. WITH THE TENDER
THE ARE THE PEOPLE THREE YEARS
THAT THEY SHOULD NOT YEAR TO ON
IMPACT I THREE COME. THAT IS
THE KOREAN. THAT ARE WALK WE
THANK YOU FOR LEASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
LINE. ONE I THANK YOU FOR- THE
FIRST OF OCTOBER I NEED TO FACE
MY NAME ETISALAT CONFIDENCE I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE GOVERNOR
MAKES IN EVERY COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING PROJECT WE ARE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION SERVING
MY DRINKING IS COMMUNITIES
COMING TRACK COUNTY. COMMUNITY
HOME TO TWENTY THOUSAND
INDIGENOUS MIGRANTS MULTI
FARMWORKERS WHO EXPERIENCE
EXTENSIVE ISOLATION BECAUSE A
LACK OF LEGAL STATUS AND
CONTINUED DISCRIMINATION IN
WITH THE BEARS WITH THE COMING
I THINK AND THEN MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN FORGOTTEN
FIRST OF ALL WITH THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO INFORMATION IN
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES A LETTER
COMMUNITIES UNIMPORTANT MICHAEL
HAS BEEN ACTIVELY ADVOCATING
FOR LANGUAGE THAT COULD BE
NEEDED FOR ANYTHING A
COMMUNITIES BY DEVELOPING
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS
AND BDO'S IN RESPECT THAT
PROTECT GOOD APPETITE AND
BINDING. FROM THE COMMUNITY
ABOUT THE HEALTH EMERGENCY WE
ARE PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING THE STATE PROJECT ALSO
NANCY OR NIKKI WE HAVE A ONE
THIRTY FIVE CAN YOU RESPOND
INNOVATIVE IMPAIR INCOMING
DECOMPILER PROJECTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE PROJECT I DID
BECAUSE I MEAN IF YOU NEED TO
DO IS ARGUMENT ENOUGH PROGRAM.
WHICH IS A MAILING LIST IN
RESPECT RECOMMENDED AND THIRTY
INTERVENTION MENTAL HEALTH AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAM WE IN
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENTED BY MY
CUP MAKE BEGINNING BEGINNING
FROM MADONNA'S COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH WORKER- I JUST BECAUSE
OF THE PROJECT AND ANY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND POLITICAL TO NOT
ENDING WITH THE CANCELLATION
FOR MEXICAN. BUCKLEY WE ARE
HERE TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
FIFTEEN IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE THIRD CLASS OF THE GENERAL
FUND OR ANY OTHER THING BY
DIVORCEES HERE AT THE END OF
THE YEAR BEFORE THREE ADDITION
YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY THE MODERATOR COULD
TAKE A QUICK BREAK WE HAVE.
SOMEBODY HERE IS GOING TO MAKE
A COMMENT. CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG BUT AROUND A YEAR AGO AT
THIS TIME THERE HAD BEEN- SOME
EFFORT I THINK HEADED UP BY
AGUIAR-CURRY. TO ADD- THE HPV
GARDASIL VACCINE- THROUGH THE
FAMILY PACKED PROGRAM I AM A
BIG BIG BELIEVER AND
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE I HAVE
PERSONALLY BEEN SERVED BY.
THREE PLANNED PARENTHOOD'S IN
IN THREE DIFFERENT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA MY BODY MY CHOICE
ALL THE WAY- BUT THAT BEING
SAID I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT.
PLAYED OUT BECAUSE I'VE LOST
TRACK OF THINGS GIVEN THAT
WE'VE BEEN LIVING IN A PANDEMIC
AND I DON'T HAVE SCHOOL FOR MY
CHILDREN- BUT I HAVE ENORMOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT- THE GARDASIL
VACCINE AND SO I WANTED TO READ
A LITTLE SOMETHING TO THAT. AND
IF YOU COULD MAYBE HUMOR ME
WITH THIRTY MORE SECONDS-
INFORMED CONSENT FROM MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IS A MUST. WHEN
PUBLIC OFFICIALS BEGIN MAKING
MEDICAL RECOMMENDATIONS IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THEY GIVE FULL
INFORMATION ON BENEFITS AND
RISKS AS WELL. IT HAS BEEN
WIDELY OBSERVED THAT IN
DEVELOPED OR DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES REGULAR USE OF PAP
SMEARS. AND BETTER OVERALL
ATTENTION TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH HAVE ALREADY BROUGHT
DOWN RATES OF CERVICAL CANCER.
A COUPLE OF THINGS ON THE
GARDASIL SHOT ITSELF WE KNOW
THAT FOR GARDASIL. THERE ISN'T
EVEN COMPLETE CREEK CLINICAL
TRIAL DATA WITH APPROPRIATE AND
POINTS. TO INDICATE WHETHER OR
NOT ANY POTENTIAL REDUCTION IN
VACCINE STRAINS OF HPV. IT
QUITE SO TRUE CANCER REDUCTION.
MERCK WAS ALLOWED BY REGULATORS
TO CUT THE TRIAL SHORT AFTER
FAST TRACK APPROVAL WAS
GRANTED. WE KNOW THAT DURING
THE CLINICAL TRIAL DATA WERE
AGGREGATED FOR THE GROUP'S
GIVEN THE PLACEBO AND THE
ALUMINUM ADJUVANT WHEN
REPORTED. SO THAT IT LOOKED
LIKE ADVERSE EVENTS FOR THE
VACCINE ARM OF THE STUDY WERE
SIMILAR. THE ADVERSE EVENTS FOR
THE BUNCH PLACEBO AND ADJUVANT
GROUPS. THIS WAS BEEN REPORTED
AS SAFE AS PLACEBO BY THE MEDIA
AND INDUSTRY FRONT GROUPS
ALIKE. WHEN FURTHER ANALYSIS
WILL SHOW SERIES OF EVENTS IN
THE ADJUVANT AND VACCINE
GROUPS. SO I COULD GO ON AND ON
ABOUT GARDASIL BUT I WON'T I
HAVE BEEN CAN BECAUSE YOU'VE
YOU'VE TAKEN TWO MINUTES OUT OF
MY BODY MY CHOICE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DAVID. HOOD YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TIME
IS EXPIRED. THANK YOU SHOULD WE
GO TO THE NEXT LINE VERY WELL
LET'S DO IT MR MODERATOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WIL
ALIGN NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AT.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES WE
CAN PLEASE PROCEED. GREAT MY
NAME IS A FIFTEEN HOUR ADAM AND
I'M THE CEO THINK PATHOGEN
BASED IN OAKLAND WE ARE ONE OF
THE THIRTY FIVE IDPS PROGRAM.
IN THE C. R. D. P. STARVING
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
FIFTY NINE DOLLAR REQUESTED TO
STAY IN THE C. R. D. P. TO
CONTINUE IMPLEMENTING
SOLUTIONS. TO THE
UNCONSCIONABLE MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER BACK TO NEXT LGBT Q.
CLASS IN NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES. DECADE THAT DATA
DEMONSTRATE THAT TRADITIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH APPROACHES DO NOT
ADDRESS ALL THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY. FIFTY
RT P. HAVE SUPPORTED THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE TO
IMPLEMENT YOU NEED TO FIND.
SOLUTIONS HOMELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE HAD BEEN
LEVERAGED EVERYTHING UP TO CODE
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC TO HELP
MITIGATE THE DISPARITIES
EXPONENTIALLY AMPLIFIED BY CO
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
COALITION IS HERE REPRESENTING
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
ASKING THAT WE MOVED BEYOND
PILOT FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT THE STATE MAKE A STRATEGIC
INVESTMENT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN BUILT WE NEED AT THE STATE
TO INVESTMENT TAKING THE
COMPLETION OF THAT WORK FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES TO SCALE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY FOR NINE
YOUR- HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN PROCEED. SENATOR AT AND
COME MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
PROPERTY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT MY NAME IS DR NINA MORE
CHANNEL AND I AM ONE OF THIRTY
FIVE LOCAL EVALUATORS.
EVALUATING THE SAFE PASSAGES
IMPLEMENTATION PROJECT WHICH IS
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT I CAN
ATTEST FIRSTHAND FROM
PRELIMINARY EVALUATION RESULTS.
BETTER SAFE PASSAGES PROJECT
HAVE CONSISTENTLY HAVE A
MULTITUDE OF POSITIVE OUTCOMES
FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES IN ALAMEDA COUNTY I AM
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL TO SUSTAIN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT THROUGH FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OR ANY OTHER
SPECIAL FUNDS. DATA
CONSISTENTLY CONFIRMS THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF
CODED ON THE POPULATIONS AT THE
VERY CENTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT INCLUDES
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN LATIN NEXT
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER NATIVE
AMERICAN LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY.
FOR THE PAST ONE YEAR. SAFE
PASSAGES ALONG WITH OUR OTHER
THIRTY FOUR SAID WHEN PROJECT
WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY PIVOTED TO
ADDRESS THE TSUNAMI OF NEGATIVE
HEALTH IMPACTS AND THREATEN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS A RESULT OF
COLLUDED WE HAVE PROVIDED.
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
RELEVANT SUPPORTS TO ADDRESS AN
ARRAY OF NEEDS RANGING FROM
FOOD ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
ACCESS TO TESTING AND
VACCINATIONS BACK THAT THE C.
R. D. P. HAS BEEN FUNDED AT THE
STATE LEVEL THROUGH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. BUT UNLESS
YOU TAKE ACTION IT WILL EASE
THE EXIT IN APRIL OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO I URGE YOU TO
INTERRUPT THE EXACERBATION. OF
HEALTH DISPARITIES ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS WELL AS
L. G. B. T. Q. PARK COMMUNITIES
AS A RESULT OF COLBERT NINETEEN
AND STRUCTURAL RACISM BY
SUPPORTING THE REQUEST FOR
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE. MY TO
SIX GO OUT. ONE FIFTY SIX UP
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS KELLY
BROKE I WILL BE COMMENTING ON
FOUR ITEMS ON BEHALF OF FEDERAL.
FIRST HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA.
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS WHICH REPRESENT THE
TWENTY ONE COUNTY IN UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL. I THINK
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO SUPPORT
OUR HOSPITAL'S CRITICAL CARE
DELIVERY NEEDS DURING AND
BEYOND THE PANDEMIC. WE HAVE
SEEN INSTIGATED BY ABOUT THAT
THERE IS A HIGHER INCIDENCE OF
CODE MAKING POSITIVITY
SERVICEMAGIC HOW BENEFICIARIES
VERSUS MEDICARE MANAGED CARE.
PUBLIC HEALTH HOSPITAL HEALTH
FINANCE NON FEDERAL SHARE
PEOPLE SERVICES PATIENT DAYS
AND HAVE BEEN DOING TO THE
FIVE. APPROXIMATELY 65% OF THE
FOR SERVICE AND PATIENT DAYS
ARE COVERED BY FEDERAL MATCH
THE REST OF THE COST THURMOND
REIMBURSE. THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WILL COVER OUR
INCREASED AND REIMBURSE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH INPATIENT THE
FOR SERVICE BASED THE PAN AM.
THE URBAN COUNTY CALIFORNIA ALL
PER THE PROPOSAL. I CAN'T THE
URBAN COUNTY THE- ALSO ON
SUPPORT THE HUNDRED DOLLAR IN-
IN YOUR LONG GOING OUT. FOR PER
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE-
RECOGNIZED THE CROWD ROLE
PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS TO GET TO
PAY IN OUR LIFE. THIRD ON THE
OF THE CENTERS FOR ELDERS
DEPENDENT HE PROGRAM- SERVING
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES WE
SUPPORT THE YOU CAL PIECE
TRAILER BILL PER. TO ENSURE
PEACE IS AN OPTION IT IN
TRANSITION AND HAPPY- KOBE
NINETEEN FLEXIBLE THERE SENATE-
FINALLY BE HAPPY LIFE ON. WE
SUPPORT THE FIFTEEN DOLLARS FOR
THAT MEDICAL RUSHED THAT
BUILDING AT THE ALAMEDA WHILE
CENTER THE PROJECT WILL PROVIDE
AN INTEGRATED MODEL OF CARE
THAT INCLUDES PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING MEDICAL
RESPITE PRIMARY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE END OF LIFE CARE
AND INTENSIVE MEDICAL
PREVENTION. AND HOUSING
PLACEMENT SERVICES FOR HOMELESS
SENIORS THIS IS AN INNOVATIVE
ONE OF A KIND PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU-
WILL BELONG FIFTY ONE FIFTEEN
ONE HUNDRED. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ON THE WAY WESTERN
AND I'M ON POVERTY WE REQUEST
CREATING AND CAL RATHER THAN
GIVING PLAN BE TO PAY HOW
SUPPORT SERVICES AND-
EXPERIENCING HIGH. IS BASED IN.
IN APPROACH THE LINE WITH THE
ADMIN GOAL COULD THEM HOW TO
COUPON PASS. THAT CLEARED
INCOMES WORK TO ENSURE
EFFECTIVE WHILE LEADING THE-
PRIOR TO GROW HELP OUT I'M HELP
SIX HOMELESSNESS WE ALSO
REQUIRE FUNDING TO BUILD NOT ON
THE- TRYING TO ENSURE THAT ALL
MEDICARE ENROLLEES ARE ABLE P.
WITH THEIR- AND THAT. ARE AS
PART OF THE MINISTRY ECHO DASH
WE ARE REQUEST MEDICAL AND
UPGRADE TO ALLOW BECAUSE- UP
GRANNY GIMMICK DATA TO ALLOW
FOR BETTER IMPROVEMENT A FAIR
PRODUCTION THE PROGRAM WE ALSO.
EIGHT HOT DOT BILLING PATIENT
CONNECT THE FOURTEENTH. FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES FOR WHILE.
TREAT IT CAN BE OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS PIER AND- WITH LITTLE
BE ACTUAL COLLECT IF THE TWENTY
ARE REALLY FROM JAIL OR PRISON
WE SHOULD SEEK TO CONNECT THESE
IN THE WITH. THAT WILL HELP AND
WE CAN THE FIVE AND NOT I DON'T
THEM WITH DEBT THAT THAT UP
FOR. BY WE SUPPORT THE TREND
PENA COALITION FUNDING OR-
START FUNDS MEDICARE TO
SPECIALIST CERTIFICATION AND TO
AIMED AT. REDUCING THEIR HI
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. LINE OF
US USING ONE OUT NINETY PLEASE
GO. GOOD MORNING ADAM AND
MEMBERS ACCORDING TO ON OF THE
TO TALK LEADERS FORM HERE- WITH
A CLEAN RECORD YOUR- OR AGREE
LOAN FROM FORTY FOUR DISTRICT.
TO COVER THE GAP BECAUSE
TRANSITION THE QUALITY PROGRAM
IN ITS PRIME THE FACT PROGRAM
KNOWN AS Q. I. P. THE CHANGES
IN THE- I MEAN REIMBURSEMENT.
WILL NOT BE IN LOW INCOME
TWENTY TWENTY. NUMBER AT TWO
THIRTY OF THE HAWK ARE THE
WORLD HALF IN LIEU COMMUNITIES
AND AT THE CRITICAL ACT THE POP
IN MAY CASES ARE THE ONLY.
HEALTHCARE IN THE- CENTER
HOSPITAL THAT AND IN QUALITY OF
PRO. HELLO HELP THEM CONTINUE
TO THE AND LYFT INCREASE
CRITICAL YOU CAN LOOK AT ALL
DAHLE SPENT ON TWENTY THREE THE
CALL PANDA. HAS REALLY AFFECT
THE HOSPITAL LIKE ALL IN MANY.
AND YOU EVERY- LAST OF THE
RETURN THE BILL THE PANDEMIC WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT
FOR THE LOAN. IN ADDITION WE
WOULD OFTEN TO. THE- BUT A
COUPLE ON BY THE OFFICIAL ACT
THE CLEAN HOSPITAL P. COMMITTEE
AT THE I JUST FACTOR FROM.
GREEN PAID TO DATE NOT HAVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT CARPOOL. BUT WE MUST
COUPLE THAT WITH REAL RESOURCES
THAT WILL HELP UNITY ENACTED BY
SYSTEMIC RACISM. AND SO I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT OF- OUR
PROPOSAL WITH QUESTIONS IN ON
LAW AND POVERTY TO INVEST ONE
MILLION IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND THIRTY THOUSAND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FEEL
STRESSED. BILLS AS MANY
CALTRAIN POLLUTION ON AND ALSO
COLLECT ADDITIONAL DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA AS PART OF THE EQUITY
DASHBOARD STRENGTHENING
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND ENSURING
PEOPLE CAN COMMUNICATE
APPROPRIATELY WITH THE
PROVIDERS HELPS IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES. CERTAINLY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS THE
ATHLETIC MANAGED CARE POLICY
UNIT TESTING PER GAME FOR SOME
TIME BUT IT IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT. HOW TO CERTAINLY
BE REPORT THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO BOTH- COMMUNITIES AND
ADVOCATES YOU. ARE INVOLVED IN
SOME OF THESE PROPERTIES NOW
UPON VOLUNTEER WE ALSO WANT TO
CREATE INEQUITY DASHBOARD WE
UPGRADED MANSELL ALLOW. ALEXION
BOARDING. ON DISABILITY STATUS
AND MORE GRANULAR. DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA LIKE AGE RACE AT.
ETHNICITY LANGUAGE SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
IDENTITY I'M A WE ALSO WANT TO
TARGET THE STANDARDS ON THE
TWENTY THIRTEEN OPERATIVE
NATIONAL COORDINATOR- HEALTH
INFORMATION. TECHNOLOGY
STANDARDS FOR ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORD THAT ALSO INCLUDES
BEHAVIORAL SINK SOCIAL WORK
RISK FACTORS THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO TAKE A SYSTEMATIC VIOLENCE
AFTER THE HOUSING. ARE ALSO
NUTRITION SPORTS WERE ALSO HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL TO
STAND CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT. THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE THREE YEAR
EXTENSION AND I LINE MY-
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES MY
SIXTEEN YEAR AND ALTHOUGH. I'M
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BY HELP NETWORK
PULLS ALL. ALONG WITH OTHERS TO
CREATE A- THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EQUITY FUND ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MANY OF THE
PROPOSALS TO EXPAND COVERAGE.
TO UNDOCUMENTED BEARD BUT ALSO
TO ENSURE THAT THE SUBSIDY THAT
LOOKS FIRING TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND COVERED CALIFORNIA OUR
CONTINUED. SO PEOPLE DO
CONTINUE TO HAVE STATE-
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE LASTLY
BUT NOT LEAST WE SUPPORT
ELIMINATING THE AFTER TAX AND
MEDICARE BECAUSE SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN. HAVING HEALTH COVERAGE
FOR HEALTHY. THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COLOR PLAY HE'S- ONE SIXTY FOUR
YOU OPEN. HELLO THIS IS KIRTI I
ON OF THE CLINICAL SAYS HE- AND
WE SUPPORTING THE- IS THAT LAB
REIMBURSEMENT METHOD ALL. ARE
YOU KNOW LOUD OF BEEN WORK
AROUND THE CLOCK TO PROVIDE
CASH FOR NINE. INTO SPAM THAT
KEPT. AND EVEN NOW THAT THE IS.
AT THE NEW BILL CHRIS TO SCHOOL
IN RUSSIA AND OTHER BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY WITH THE NEW VARIANT.
BOB NEED PEOPLE RE. FOR ALL OF
THEIR TESTING THAT IS GOING ON.
AND YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA HOW THE
PROGRAM WORKS DOUBLE TEAMS RATE
CURRENTLY WE DO NOT NEED TO TIE
OUR RATE IN THE MEDICARE RATE.
OR THE REMOVAL OF THE 80% OF
MEDICARE CAP. IN ADDITION WE
SUPPORT ONE TIME FUNDING TO
FORGIVE THE RETROACTIVE
RECRUITMENT. DURING THE PUSH
FOR BECAUSE I THINK THAT IT'S
HAPPENING NOW IT IS NOT THE
TIME TO RECOUP MONEY FROM
LABORATORIES THAT GOES BACK ALL
THE WAY TO TWENTY NINETEEN CUTS
THAT HAPPENED BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. WHY WE SUPPORT THE
FORGIVENESS OF THE RETROACTIVE
RECRUITMENT FROM CLINICAL
LABORATORY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL AT. GOOD MORNING AT THE
JANITORIAL WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND I'LL BE
HIGHLIGHTING I REQUEST RELATED
TO PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY THE
COSBY NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE IMPORTANCE OF
ACCESS TO REGULAR HEALTH CARE
AND HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST IN CALIFORNIA NOW IT'S
PRECISELY THE TIME TO FILL IN
THE GAPS IN OUR MEDICARE
PROGRAM. SPECIFICALLY WE
SUPPORT THE REQUEST EXPAND
ACCESS TO BOTH BUILD MEDICARE
OPTIONS IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE LEFT
OUT DUE TO THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
OVER AGE SIXTY FIVE WHO ARE
MOST AT RISK DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND IN THE MOST NEED
OF HEALTH CARE TO ADDRESS
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. WE ALSO
REQUESTED THE LEGISLATURE
ELIMINATE THE MEDIC HOW ASSETS
THAT IT IS WRONG THAT ONLY
THOSE OVER AGE SIXTY FIVE OR
WITH DISABILITIES HAVE THEIR
ASSETS CONSIDERED WHEN
DETERMINING WHETHER THEY ARE
FINANCIALLY ELIGIBLE NO OTHER
HEALTH PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
AFTER SUCH AN ACCOUNTING AND
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH BUREAUCRATIC
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO GET OR
KEEP COVERAGE. THE MEDICARE
ATKINS TESCO CATCHWEIGHT
POVERTY AND AS A FORM OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM THAT KEEPS
LOW INCOME COMMUNITY TURN
BUILDING WEALTH AND FORCES
PEOPLE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN HAVING
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE OR
THINKING THAT WE ARE PLEASED
THAT ONE HUNDRED OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE STATE
JOINED AND SUPPORTED THIS
REQUEST SHOULD WE ALSO SUPPORT
EXPANDING MEDICAID POSTPARTUM
COVERAGE TO TWELVE MONTHS FOR
ALL MOTHERS NOT OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE AND MAINTAINING
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY FOR
CHILDREN UP TO AGE FIVE. IT IS
ESPECIALLY TIMELY GIVEN THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO WELL CHILD
VISITS AND OTHER CARE DURING A
PANDEMIC WE ALSO REQUEST
LANGUAGE TO MAINTAIN YET BILITY
TO DO TELEPHONIC ACTIVATION
WHENEVER SELF ATTESTATION IT
PERMITTED FOR A MEDIC CAL
APPLICATION OR RENEWAL. COUNTY
WORKERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THIS DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT
THEY NEED TO MOVE AWAY FROM
BURDENSOME PAPERWORK WILL
REMAIN EVEN AFTER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND- FINALLY
WITH REGARD TO THE STATE FUNDED
COVERED CALIFORNIA SUBSIDIES
WELL WE HAVE HIGH HOPES FOR
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
WE SUPPORT MAINTAINING THE
STATE ASSISTANCE WE DO HAVE AND
CHANGING AS ONE DOLLAR MONTHLY
PREMIUMS ZERO CAN PROVE AN OMEN.
FOR THOSE WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD
IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS HARPER. WE WERE
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR BREAKS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA OR PROSTHETIC
ASSOCIATION EXISTING LAW
AUTHORIZES THE MEDICAID PROGRAM
TO REIMBURSE PROSTHETIC AND
ORTHOTIC APPLIANCES AT A RATE
THAT MAY NOT EXCEED 80% OF THE
LOWEST MAXIMUM ALLOWANCE FOR
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S STATUS
BY MEDICARE FOR THE SAME OR
SIMILAR SERVICES. THIS BUDGET
REQUEST WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE
THAT REIMBURSEMENT FOR
PROSTHETIC AND ORTHOTIC
APPLIANCE IS BEING CREATED 80%
OF THE PROGRAM'S PREVAILING
MEDICARE ALLOWABLE RATE
PROSTHETIC AND ORTHOTIC
APPLIANCE CATEGORY HAS NOT
RECEIVED AN INCREASE IN
REIMBURSEMENT AND OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS WHILE THE COST.
MATERIALS LABOR AND OVERHEAD.
DO PRODUCTS FROM SKY. MEDICARE
REIMBURSED FOR A P. SERVER.
CURRENTLY AVERAGE AVERAGES ONLY
51% OF THE PREVAILING MEDICARE
ALLOWABLE BY THE NATIONAL
MEDICAID AVERAGES 75% OF THE
MEDICARE ALLOWABLE WELL WE'RE
REASONABLE REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY RATE FOR PROSTHETIC
AND ORTHOTIC APPLIANCES IN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM. SOCIALLY
VULNERABLE PATIENTS MANY OF
WHOM ARE ENTITIES WILL CONTINUE
TO STRUGGLE WITH ACCESSING
REPUBLICAN PROSTHETIC CARE.
SUFFER FROM ONGOING MOBILITY
INDEPENDENCE CHALLENGES
THEREFORE WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU MEDICARE WILL
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. REPORT
YES CURRENTLY WILL THE PHONE.
DIMENSIONAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY-
MY NAME IS A CLINTON AND I
LOOKED ON TRACK COOKING
RESOURCES AND WE ARE HONORED TO
BE A PART OF THE CALIFORNIA.
PROJECT AT THE PUMP IMPORTANCE
PROVIDER. GRANTED OFF THE MALE.
IT I THINK QUALITY AT THE PORT
THE PROPOSAL THANKS YOU ARE THE
PEOPLE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THREE FROM GENERAL ON ANY
OTHER ON. CREDIBLE IT IS.
BECAUSE AND IN THIS COM ADDRESS
WILL TALK THE FOR THE IT IS NOT.
LIKE WE ARE THIRTY. YEAH. HOUSE
LAW REQUIRES WITH PUT TO
FRICTION I'M I'M BASED ON
SACRAMENTO AND I'M SORRY. FOR
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN- GOING TO
LOOK BETTER SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
LEFT IN AMERICAN THREE BLACK
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO THE
CALL THAT- THE CARD- WHAT WE
LEAVE WITH A SPECIAL- NEED ON
ON A VARIETY THE OTHER- INTO
CONTROL GOVERNMENT. WELL BEYOND
AND THIS IS TRUE ACROSS- ALL OF
THE TOP- THAT SIR- AND IF- AND
SO- WITH THAT ONE HUNDRED
HOKITIKA TO CONGRESS AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES YEAH IF
AVAILABLE- I LOOKED OUT ON IF
WE ARE TO CREATE IN TROPICAL
NEXT YEAR WITHOUT ANY
INDICATION OF IT OF THAT WORK
ON THE LOCAL. IF OUT IN ORDER
TO MAKE THAT BECAUSE WE COULD
NOT BE GET FOUND WE CANNOT OKAY
THE APPROACH COULD NOT LET BEEN.
TO I DON'T SEE IT BUT- THE COLD
AND THE REIMBURSEMENT I'M
HEARING A LOT ABOUT- THE
VACCINE AND PEOPLE ARE USING
THE LANGUAGE VACCINE. AND I
FEEL COMPELLED TO SAY THAT THIS
IS NOT A TRUE VACCINE IT IS
MRNA TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
ONLY. TRADITIONAL VACCINES
CONTAIN CHOPPED UP PIECES OF
THE VIRUS SO THAT THE RECIPIENT
CAN GET IMMUNITY WITHOUT
GETTING THE DISEASE. THE MRNA
CODE VACCINE CONTAINS GENETIC
SOFTWARE THAT CAUSES THE
RECIPIENT CELLS TO MANUFACTURE
THE NTIGEN ON THEIR OWN WHICH
THEY HOPE BUT THEY'RE NOT SURE
YET. WELL THEN CAUSE AN IMMUNE
RESPONSE IT'S A COOL IDEA BUT
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT WORKS OR
NOT. BOTH ARE UNPROVEN AND HAVE
NOT COMPLETED CLINICAL TRIALS.
BECAUSE WHO NEEDS CLINICAL
TRIALS WHEN YOU HAVE THE WHOLE
WORLD TO TEST THIS THEORY ON.
THE FIZER AND MADERA ARE BOTH
MRNA TREATMENTS THEY ARE NOT
TRUE VACCINES AND THESE
COMPANIES ARE TRADED ON WALL
STREET WITH HEDGE FUNDS BEING
THE MAIN SHAREHOLDERS. AND THEY
FUNCTION BY REPROGRAMMING THE
RECIPIENT CELLS AT THE
CYTOPLASM LEVEL. AND THIS
TREATMENT IS ONLY A FEW YEARS
OLD. AND SO WE'RE ASKING THE
POPULATION. TO TAKE A NEW
GENETIC. YOU KNOW I DIDN'T NEW
GENETIC TREATMENT YOUR ONE
MINUTE IS UP THAT INCLUDES
STAFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND- MY BODY MY
CHOICE. THANK YOU WE WILL ALIGN
ONE TWENTY SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. LET NINE ONE
TWENTY SIX RIGHT- GOOD MORNING.
JOHN A SENIOR RESEARCHER WITH
SPECIAL SERVICE FOR GRIFFIN
CORPORATE IN LOS ANGELES. I AM
ONE OF THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT. I
AM OFFERING COMMON IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSAL FOR FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT. DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
AT THE END OF THE THIRTY FIVE
PROGRAMS ACROSS FIVE DIVERSE
POPULATION. THE FINISH LIVE
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
CONNECTING TO AN PROVIDING
CULTURALLY RELEVANT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SOCIAL
SUPPORT FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
YOUTH ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS
IN OUR STATE. WOULD OTHERWISE
BE UNREACHED. THE PROGRAM HAVE
STRONG TRUST RELATIONSHIP. WITH
THEIR COMMUNITIES THAT MAKE
THIS PROJECT. A GOOD ABOUT
NETWORK AND SERVICE IS A PLATE.
THE SAME THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
WOULD ALLOW MORE COMMUNITIES TO
RECEIVE THE CULTURAL SERVICES
AND SUPPORT THEY NEED EVEN MORE
NOW WHILE DEALING WITH A
PANDEMIC EFFECT ON THEIR
OVERALL HEALTH. THAT IS WHY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR FUNDING
SUPPORT EXISTING THIS MUCH
NEEDED INITIATIVE FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL YEARS. THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF ONE TIME
FUNDING FROM THE GENERAL FUND
OR ANY OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE WILL GO TO ONE TWENTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO MADAM
CHAIRMEN AND SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ARGHA
CRICKET AND I'M A MASTERS
STUDENT AT LEAST CHECK
UNIVERSITY GETTING MY DEGREE IN
SOCIAL CALLS AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
CURRENTLY I'M A STUDENT INTERN
OPERATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
COALITION WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE THINK VERY
PROJECT IT'S ONE OF THE LARGEST
OF ITS KIND AND I SPEAK I THE
COURT OF THE ONE I'M FINDING A
FIFTY MILLION. BUT THE PAIN
EXPAND OUR PURPOSE WITH A SMALL
POPULATION THE AND LOCAL LEVEL
TO ENSURE PEOPLE WITH THE
UTMOST RESPECT AND CARE I TRULY
BELIEVE IT IS OUR DUTY AND VAT
PERHAPS PROTECT THE COLLECTIBLE
BEING OF ALL AND IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER DURING I'M
THE GREAT. PART ABOUT IT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CALL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LATER SEVEN
PLEASE GOING. BEFORE THIRTY
SEVEN ARE YOU MUTED. EXACTLY
ALL PUBLIC HEALTH I AM VERY ALL
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT. THANK. FOR
EXAMPLE ONE. YEAH YOUR RECORD
PERFECT. BOB HERTZBERG. BUT.
ARGUES THAT WONDERFUL ALL
EXCEPT FOR PART THE NUMBER
YOU'RE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CALLER PLEASE. MY NAME ASKING
ME NINETY EIGHT PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ALLEN AND WHITE
AFTER THE CAL CAR OF. THE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF DOCTORS THE CAR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TO
RESTORE THE THAT AND BROKER.
OKAY REALISTICALLY THAT THEY OF
MEDICARE NEARLY HAS REVISED
MULTIPLE POPULATIONS AND
CALIFORNIA DR CURRICULA TO
ENSURE MEDICAL. HAVE ACTED JUST
MANY HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AS
POSSIBLE WITH THE WITH THE
RESTORED OTHER OPTIONAL
BENEFITS LIKE OPTICAL PODIATRY
IN SPEECH THERAPY SERVICES ONLY
HALF OF THE COMMITTEE APPROVED
A ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
ANNUAL GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION TO RESTORE
CHIROPRACTIC WITH ADULT
POPULATION. WITH MONICA BEST
INVESTMENT MILLIONS OF MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES THE BALLGAME
ACTED TO CHIROPRACTORS HAVE
PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE IN
PROVIDING NOTHING MYCOLOGICAL
TREATMENT THE PAIN WE DIDN'T
NEED FOR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
SUCH AS OPIOIDS AND AVOIDING
COSTLY SURGICAL INTERVENTION.
WE ALSO ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER ADJUSTING THE CAR TAX
BENEFIT IN A MANNER THAT
MAINTAINS THE TWENTY FOUR BIT
ANNUAL LIMITS BUT- MOVE THE TO
THE TO COME UP CAPITAL THAT
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES MAY
RECEIVE CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTIONS IN A TIMELY
FASHION. A TIME WHEN MANY
PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS AND
THEIR CORRESPONDING EMPLOYER
SPONSORED CARE WHEN BERMAN
WORKERS ARE BEING ASKED TO WORK
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
SUFFERING WITH PAIN THIS IS
DURATION IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER I FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
TO THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE HUNDRED SEVEN YOU
ARE UP. GOOD MORNING MADAM MY
NAME IS MARK GRAHAM GOAND
FIRST FIVE IF SHE ACCOUNT. YOU
CAN STRONG THE PORT OF PROPOSED
TO PROVIDE CONTINUE MEDICAL FOR
CHILDREN TO AGE AND ADULTS ARE
TO MONTHS A PREGNANT THING
CONTINUES HOW CARE COVERAGE OF
MR TO PROVIDE. SO WE'RE GOING
TO THE ESPECIALLY ITS COULD
PHASE OF LIFE MEDICAL BUT ARE
STILL AND WHEN I PERCENT BRAIN
ABOUT OCCURS BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN ONLY UNDERSCORED THE
NEED TO PARKS COVERAGE ACTUALLY
AS CHILDREN CARE LIKE WELL
CHILD VISIT THE IMMUNIZATIONS
HAVE PLUMMETED BELOW ALREADY
LOWERED PREVENTIVE CARE RIGHT
AND ACCOUNT. IS REALITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT YOUNG
CHILDREN WHEN THE COLOR GIVEN
THEIR OVER REPRESENTATION AT
CAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTEGRABLE TODAY AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT WITH THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHEN I TWELVE LINE IS.
EIGHTEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING OFFICE HE
HAD A PROBLEM YOU CAN I
SPEAKING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THREE PROPOSAL THE FIRST ON THE
EXTENT THAT IT IS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
IF THE STATE INVESTMENT POOR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WORKFORCE REQUEST FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING. THE
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT
COALITION- STRONGLY RECOMMEND
FOR OF THIS PROPOSAL OF AS WE
HAVE SEEN THE- HISTORICAL
DISINVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HEALTH
IS REALLY COMING HOME TO ROOST
FOR US RIGHT NOW AND ONCE WE
MAKE IT THROUGH ALL OF IN WHICH
WE ARE DOING- WE HOPE TO HAVE A
ROBUST PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
READY. FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC
BUT ALSO READY TO TACKLE THE
CURRENT ISSUES AS WELL BUT PART
OF IT INCLUDING THE RISING
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE
RATE- AND OTHER- DISEASE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH TRANSITION
SO- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT
COLLECTIONS REQUEST FOR ON
GOING PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING.
THE OTHER TWO PROPOSALS ARE NOT
ON THE AGENDA TODAY BUT I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THE REALLY
QUICK- WE HAVE A PROPOSAL FROM
THE SECOND BILLION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION THE
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
WITH THEM SHOULD HELP THE
PUBLIC HOSPITAL WHICH ARE
SAFETY NET HOSPITALS SERBIAN
LARGELY. MEDICAL POPULATION.
THE NUMBER OF THE THING HEARD
WITH VERY MEDICAL FEE FOR.
PATIENTS OVER THE OF THAT HAND.
THIS IS- BUT HOLD WE COURSE
MAKE AND WE'RE HOPING- THE
STATE. CAN OUT THESE REALLY
CRITICAL HAPPEN LOOK IN THE- OF
UNDER COMMUNITIES- WITH THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND LASTLY- ARE
COUNTY PUBLIC GUARDIAN'S PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS THE PUBLIC
CONSERVATIVE THERE'S-
SOMETHING. I REALLY I'M NOT ON
MANY PEOPLE'S RADAR. THEY DON'T
RETHINK REALIGNMENT FUND EITHER
COUNTY ONLY OPTION AND WITH THE
RISE AND INCREASE IN OF COURSE-
CALIFORNIA ADDRESSING THE
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE WE ARE A LOT
ABOUT- INCREASING THE ABILITY
FOR COUNTIES TO- A CONSERVE THE
PULP. OR A FINE PUBLIC GUARDIAN
BOOK- IF- ASKING. RIDICULOUS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR ONE
MINUTE HAS EXPIRED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUR NEXT CALLER.
PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THE BY. WILL BE ONE THE LINE
WENT TWO GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS BECAUSE NOT PART OF
THE AMERICAN MUSLIM COMMUNITY
SOCIAL SERVICES PROFESSIONAL AS
WELL AS A MEMBER OF THE REGIME
THAT THINK MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION- I AM
SEEKING SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY
MILLION TO SUSTAIN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCE DISPARITIES
PROJECT THE C. R. D. P.
CONSIDERING THE C. R. V. P.
EFFECTIVELY SERVES A VERY
POPULATIONS THAT SUFFER
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN TWENTY
TWENTY. DUE TO THE COLD IN
NINETEEN THAT DEMI AND AS WELL
AS THE RACIAL RACIAL RECKONING
AFTER THE VERY PUBLIC KILLINGS
OF BLACK PEOPLE. THE VALUE
ENERGY ASSISTING THIS PROJECT
IS. OBVIOUS- EARLIER THIS YEAR
D. B. BY EXTENDING THE CURRENT.
INCLUDING SO AND- MACINNES FOR
SKIN THE PRO THAT THE CAN LEVEL.
AND LASTLY BY DEVELOPING FOR A
PASTRY THAT EXPAND SERVICES TO
SERVE ADDITIONAL SPECIAL
POPULATIONS AND SYSTEMS CHANGE
AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS.
AS MENTIONED IN THIS HEARING AS
OF LEGISLATURE HAS SAID
MULTIPLE TIMES RACIAL EQUITY IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND
SUSTAINING AND EXPANDING THE
CRT P. WILL MOVE US BEYOND
SYMBOLIC GESTURES TO ACTIONABLE
ITEMS ACTIONABLE THINGS ALL
WEEK SO I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATORS FROM THE TIME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND WILL DE SUPPORTERS
HERE D. B. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN THE
POLICY IMMEDIATELY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WHERE
THE SPONSOR OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST FOR AN EXEMPTION IN THE
PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE AWAY. WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
REQUEST THAT WILL KEEP YOU FTA
FUNDS IN CALIFORNIA AND
AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
PUBLIC SERVICES. TO CURRENT
CONTRACT INFLEXIBILITY THERE
ARE SEVERAL FUNDING LOSSES.
FUNDS ARE RETURNS TO U. S. B.
A. THEY ARE DECLINED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES OR THE LOCAL EIGHT
PARENT ORGANIZATIONS FILLED
WITH AGENCIES. WHICH COULD BE A
COMMUNITY OR NATIVE AMERICAN-
ACTUATES THE CITY OR COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. HOSPITAL OR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION I
ASSUMING UNEXPECTED WISCONSIN
WHICH ALSO IMPACTED
ORGANIZATIONS BUDGET AND
OVERALL. IT'S REDUCES FUNDS TO
PROVIDE. WICKS SERVICES
BENEFITS AND COMMUNITY SERVICE
THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN
COMMITTEE SPEAKING THE TRUCK.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH ABOUT MY
LIST A- BRIEF RECESS.
OKAY
LET'S CONTINUE. THE BETTER AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS CODY CASTEEL WITH A
SPECIAL ACCESS TO HELP ME FOCUS
ON SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL AND I'M
COMMENTING IN SUPPORT OF THE
AND THE EPIDEMIC COLLISION
BUDGET REQUEST. AND WE ALSO
ECHO THE COMMENTS ABOUT NEEDING
TO STRENGTHEN OUR STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ADDRESS ARTS OTHER I THINK
PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS THAT ARE.
THAT ARE WORKING AND ARE BEING
COMPOUNDED BY COBIT- THE
CHRONIC UNDERFUNDING OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM IN FACT
ILLUSTRATED BY THE RAPID RISE
OF SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
DISEASES. THAT WERE ALREADY
SKYROCKETING TO CRISIS LEVELS
BEFORE THE COLLUDED PANDEMIC
NEARLY A QUARTER OF A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WERE INFECTED WITH
SYPHILIS CHLAMYDIA OR GONORRHEA
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THE
NUMBERS ARE ESTIMATED TO BE
MUCH HIGHER. FIND THAT THE
EPIDEMIC- ARE IN CRISIS LEVEL
HAVE ALREADY- MANIFESTED IN
STRANGE WAYS- IN ALARMING WAYS-
THE CDC HAVE CONFIRMED THAT
THERE IS A NEW ANTIBIOTIC
RESISTANT STRAINS SPREADING-
FOR OF FROM GONORRHEA AND OUR
OWN PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
ISSUED AN ALERT. HI WINTER.
ABOUT THE RISING NUMBER OF
DISSEMINATED GONOCOCCAL
INFECTIONS WHICH IS A SEVERE
COMPLICATION OF UNTREATED
GONORRHEA- THE RESULT IS THAT
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T LIKELY
RESULT THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
BETWEEN STD TESTING DURING THE
PANDEMIC. SO WE URGE YOU THAT
DID NOT SATISFY THE OTHER
PRESSING ME ECAUSE NOW IT- IT
IS NOW THIS IS THE OFFICIAL
JUSTICE ISSUE BECAUSE THE
PRIMARY COMMUNITIES. BEING
AFFECTED. ARE YOUNG PEOPLE.
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND THE- COMING. SO WE
ARE YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT- ARE
OUR PAPA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR PLEASE.
R. ONE ONE THIRTY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. THE MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MY RIBS AND A GRANDPARENT HAD
AFFILIATE CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CLINICAL
LABORATORY REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY REQUEST. WE SUPPORT
REPEAL OF THE 80% OF MEDICARE
CAP ON LAB REIMBURSEMENT AND
THE ONE TIME REQUEST TO FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO DELAY RATE
CUTS AND ELIMINATE CONTACT THIS
YEAR PROMEDICA ABOUT PROVIDERS.
LIKE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
PROVIDING OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION. LAB TEST ONLY FOR AT.
90% OF OUR VISION BE AMERICAN
FAMILY BENEFIT. AND OUTSIDE THE
CURRENT REVERSED METHODOLOGY.
BUT BEFORE GETTING UP OF OUR
CENTERS. TO MOCK. ATTRACTIVE
CUT IN CALL BACK FOR THE THIRD.
WHICH YEAR WILL IN TURN HELPS
AROUND EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS NON. ESPECIALLY DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH. AND HARMFUL
TO PAY GIVEN THE GOING OUT
AFTER THAT MAKE. WILL PARTY CAN
COVERAGE WITH THE COMMITTEE
AROUND THAT I HAVE TO MAKE IN
THE REQUEST THANK YOU YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NASCO
PLEASE. GIVE ME A ONE THIRTY
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. I WILL ONE
ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SHERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS REPRESENTING
INJECTION COUNSELORS. BROWN'S
RECOVERY RESIDENCES AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE RECOVERY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'M HERE
TODAY TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
NINE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
DEFINITIVA FUNDING FOR THE PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. I DO
BOTH EVEN THE MEDIA OUR COUNTRY
CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE AN
OPIOID EPIDEMIC THAT IS EXCEPT
HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED BY CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE ARE ALSO
NOW EXPERIENCING DRAMATIC
INCREASE STIMULANT USE THE
STORES AND WE FULLY EXPECT THAT
WHEN PEOPLE RETURN TO WORK. THE
WORKPLACE AND SCHOOL SHOOTING
CREASES IN RATES OF SEVEN HUGE
DISORDERS WILL BE UNFORTUNATELY
REVEALED CALIFORNIA NEED TO
APPLY THE SAME URGENCY PLANNING
AND RESOURCE THE SAVING LIVES
TO FACE COLUSA SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AS WE HAVE TO SAVE
THOSE AT RISK OF DYING FROM
COPD AT. TWO O'CLOCK AM CENTER
PAM COMMENTS ABOUT HEALTH
DISPARITY I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE
THAT PIERCED BY DEFINITION MUST
DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY HAVE
LISTED. IN ORDER TO BE
CERTIFIED AND THEY ARE PROVING
TO BE EXCELLENT BREAKING DOWN
CULTURAL AND LANGUAGE BARRIERS
WHICH HELP PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY SUBMIT TO ENTERING
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT I TEND
AFTER CARE IS NECESSARY AND
CONSTRAIN MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT WHICH IS CRITICALLY
EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING OPIOID
USE DISORDER RELAPSE. FOR THESE
REASONS TO CAP URGES YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS ITEM AND I
THINK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. M. WE WILL
LINE ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON- TO WHITE AT THE
ARE YOU CAN. ON THE OF A TWENTY
DOWN NURSING HOME WORKERS IN
OVER HUNDRED THE STATE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT DEBATE OCTOBER FOR
SHORTAGE AND PATIENT WAIVERS
AND CONNECTING. BY JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND LIKE THE TIME
ABILITY MEASURES AS PART OF THE
WAIVER APPLICATION PROCESS. FOR
NEXT TO ME CLEARLY DEFINED
ACCORDING REQUIREMENTS IF THEY
ARE COULD PROBABLY BRING THE
MEANTIME LOOK FOR SHORTAGE
IMPATIENT YOU LABORS HAVE
CREATED A NEED FOR MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED FACILITIES. THE
STAFF AT A LEVEL LOWER THAN THE
TWO POINT FOUR AND THREE POINT
FIVE BACKING LEVEL WOULD HAVE
BEEN RECOGNIZED AT THE MINIMUM
LEVEL OF DIRECT YOUR NEEDED TO
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE TO NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS. WE CANNOT
CONTINUE ENSURING ISSUING
WAIVERS IN PERPETUITY WITHOUT
MAKING SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND
MAKING SURE THAT FACILITIES ARE
DOING ALL THEY CAN TO RECRUIT
TRAIN AND RETAIN STAFF.
PARTICULAR DNA TO PROVIDE
MAJORITY OF HANDS ON YOUR
PERSONAL RESIDENCE FURTHERMORE
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD
AUTOMATICALLY DISALLOWS YOU
FROM CONSIDERATION OF A
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE OF PATIENT
ACUITY WEBER IF THEY HAVE A
HISTORY OF THE PARK HERE OR
INCLUDING PRACTICES THAT WOULD.
RESIDENTS AND WORKERS AT EVEN
GREATER RISK IF THEY WERE TO
RECEIVE A WAIVER. FINALLY THIS
IS A MODEST AND REALISTIC
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF. THESE MONIES THAT WERE
THERE PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC BUT
HAS ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED AND
DEVASTATINGLY AFFECTED BY THE
CONTINUED PANDEMIC AND WE MUST
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE
RESIDENTS WITH THE QUALITY CARE
NEED. NOT HAVING APPROPRIATE
STAFFING ESPECIALLY DURING A
PACK PANDEMIC AFTER THE NUMBER
OF INCREASE AFFECTION AND
DANCED AND GOT NOTHING
FACILITIES WOULD REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT AND. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION. THE YOU
VERY MUCH COLOR. FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT THIS IS
NOT WORK WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
DIRECTOR OKAY AND CO SPONSORS
OF A MEASURE REQUEST. FOR WORKS
BEST CERTIFICATION WHAT I
SECURITY PROGRAM AND REQUESTED
THE STATE YOU TO START UP. OUR
COSTS WITH ON THE COST COVERED
BY EITHER AVAILABLE MASS THE
STATE ONE TIME ONLY COMES UP
FOR QUITE MILLION AND THE
AVAILABLE CREDIT MATCH WILL IN
MILLIONS OF FEDERAL FOR AVAIL
IN. BY PEERS FOR MEDICARE BILL
PROVIDE AND THAT COUGH
EFFECTIVE YOUR SUPPORT SERVICE
AS MAY BILL PROVIDE.
SPECIALISTS ARE CERTIFIED MEDIC
CAL MEDICAID WILL PROVIDE AND
FOR OTHERS. AND THAT THE OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS AND RESULT IN
OF STANDING. IN REDUCE
INVOLUNTARY HARPER. AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES WHICH ARE. FIND YOUR
SUPPORT SPECIALIST TO PROVIDE
CARE SUPPORT ERVICES MEDIC CAL
CORN THAT HAS BECAUSE OF THE
HEAVY NINETY. YOUR SUPPORT IS
WORK IN AMERITECH AND-
DIVERSITY OF COMMUNITIES THEY-
AND HAVE LIVES NEXT. AFTER
THAT'S WILLING NAVIGATE. AND WE
WILL LINE SEVENTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR ANDMEMBERS I AM
IAN MCLEOD PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
PEACH PRIVATE CENTRAL ACTIVE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL WE'RE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED COMMUNITY
SAFETY NET HOSPITAL. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR THEIR
VERY THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS OF OUR
PROPOSAL THAT INCLUDED IN THE
AGENDA PACKET. OUR PROPOSAL
WILL ENSURE HEALTHCARE ACCESS
FOR HOMELESS ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA SAFETY NET HOSPITALS
OF WHICH THEY PROVIDE A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
HEALTH CARE TO OUR STATE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
INCLUDING SERVING MORE THAN
HALF OF THE HOMELESS ADULTS
WITH NEARLY 90% OF THEM ALSO.
BATTLING MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
WHEN HE PATIENCE OUR STATE NET
HOW. THEIR CARE IS MORE SO CALL.
AND MISLI TO AN INCREASED NEED
FOR RESEARCH. FOR ESTABLISHING
KERR SO. AND RESULT IN THE LONG
LENGTH OF STAY HERE IS NEW
NATIONAL. TO MODERN MEDICAID.
TO PROP ACCOUNT FOR THIS COMPLY.
OF PEACE. AND WE'RE ASKING
LUCKY TO PUT CAL AT THE OF THIS
MOVIE. AND SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL TO HELP. WE CAN OF OUR
MOST. PATIENTS AND THE
COMMUNITIES NET. THAT CARE FOR
THEM THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
INTO APPEARED. THANK YOU VERY
NEXT PLEASE. EIGHTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. ME YES MY PLEASE PLEASE
FROM HELLO OUT. YOUR ONE MINUTE
MA'AM GRANT. HELLO MY NAME IS
CARLENE DAVIS NUMBER DIRECTOR
STRATEGY EVALUATION FOR
CALIFORNIA BACK ON TOP PROJECT
AND I SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE SAME THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT THREE C. R. D. PEACOCK
PUBLIC HEALTH PROJECT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO IDEATE DESIGN AND
PROTOTYPE. PREVENTION
INTERVENTION PROGRAM TO REDUCE
MENTAL HEALTH STIGMA ART AND
ANXIETY IN BLACK WOMEN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND STATE
ALAMEDA ACCOUNT SO OFTEN ORGAN
LIKE OUR TO ASK TO PROVIDE AND
BASED OF THE- WILL EVIDENCE
CARE ACT FOR. MY THAT PARK SO
HAVE AS A NON MEMBER BILLY
COMMUNITY REACH THEIR EGGMAN ME
NINETY NINE TO GET ACT TO YOU
ARE TO PROVIDE VALIDATED AND OF
THE LIVE NEXT THE BLACK WE
WOULD PROBABLY ALL GET INTO
DOLLAR IN A WHILE CARD TO
PROTECT IN. AND DON'T GET ANY
RESIDUAL FOR THE NOT NINE
DOLLAR BUT I HAD PAY FOR THE
DOWNLOAD BECAUSE OF THE ARE D.
P. I HONORED TODAY TO PUT. FOR
KNAPSACK FROM THE MIX MESSAGE
NOT EXTRA PHENOMENA PURPOSELY
ANSWER FISH POWER BUT WE
VALUATION FROM THIS ONE
LOCALIZES COUNTY 1100% OUR
PARTY SISTERS YEAH CULTURALLY
FOR BY WOMEN 1% THAT WE PROVIDE
STATE FOR WOMEN TO TALK OPENLY
AND IF MENTAL. 99% OF THE BASE
A BETTER AND OF THE MIDDLE NO
HEALTH ISSUES IMPACTING THEM
88% MORE A NEEDS TO
PROFESSIONAL HELP FOR A CURRENT
OR FUTURE MEDICAL HEALTH
OUTCOME THERE'S A FIFTY TWO PER
INCREASE ONE DOLLAR ABOUT
HEALTH A 30% IN WE'RE CONFIDENT
SPEAK TO ME HEALTH AND 80% OF
SISTERS. AT THIS TO CREATE AND
STATE LAST WE YOU TO SUPPORT
ONLY BUT HELP PROJECT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR FABRIC
LATER WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE ARE
REQUESTING A ONE TIME FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION TO
EXPAND THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PILOT PROJECT WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
EXPANDING ON THE EFFORTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA BRIDGE PROGRAM IT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PILOT PROGRAM
PROVIDES GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS WITH GRANT TO HIRE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
PEER NAVIGATORS FOR THEIR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. THESE
GRANTS ALLOW HOSPITALS TO
SCREEN PATIENS AND OFFER
INTERVENTION REFERRAL AND
COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS TO MENTAL
HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM. THE EXPANSION
OF THE PILOT PROJECT WILL SAVE
LIVES REDUCE POLICE ENGAGEMENT
AND REDUCE RETURN DOES THAT THE
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOMS IT
WILL ALSO BUILD CAPACITY FOR
IMPROVED TREATMENT OF SUBSTANCE
USE AND MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
IN THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT FOR
THESE PATIENTS OFTEN END UP IN
CRISIS. FORTY THREE THANKS FOR
YOUR AND YOUR SUPPORT THE
BUDGET REQUEST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
OUR- HELLO MEMBERS YOU CAN
CREDIT NOT BE OF HELP. FOR ALL
INCOME CARE FOR THE ELDERLY WE
ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE PATIENT
AWARENESS OUT PROPOSAL AS WELL
AS THE FLEXIBILITIES. AS
AWARENESS PROPOSAL PROVIDES
AWARENESS REFERRAL ASSESSMENT
ENJOYS TO INDIVIDUALS WHO COULD
BE ANSWERED BY PAYS THE FRAIL
SENIORS FIFTY FIVE YEARS AND
OLDER IT ALSO WOULD SAVE-
ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR THE
STATE. AS IT IS APPROVING COSTS
THEY WERE UP FOR- PARTICIPANTS
AND THE STATE ON THE PACE
FLEXIBILITIES WILL PROVIDE A
GREATER. ACCESS AND ABILITY TO
TREAT A PATIENT PARTICIPANTS AS
HAS BEEN SHOWN- DURING OTHER
COVERT HEALTH EMERGENCY FINALLY
WE WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE
ELIMINATION OF THAT ASSET TESTS.
SENIORS AND- PERSONS- I DID
SPD'S THAT FOR THE REASONS THAT
HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY STATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO BACK.
THANK YOU HELLO ARE YES HELLO
MY NAME IS DR JUAN CARLOS
GONZALEZ- WITH THE INTEGRAL
COMMUNITY SOLUTION INSTITUTE
AND WE SERVE HERE IN FRESNO AND
MADERA COUNTY- WE ARE CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
THROUGH THE FIFTY MILLION FROM
THE GENERAL FUND OR ANY OTHER
SPECIAL FUND AND WE SERVE
LATINO AT RISK YOUTH HERE- IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE
SUB LATINO PROVEN THERAPEUTIC
METHODS FOR COUNSELING UNIT- WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CONTINUE THE
SERVICES THROUGH CODE RED- AND
IT HAS REALLY BEEN A LIFELINE
FOR OUR STUDENTS- THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
HISTORIC AND CROSS POPULATION
SOLUTION BASED AND RIGOROUS
EVALUATION DRIVEN INITIATIVE
WHERE STOCKS HAVE BEEN
COLLECTING DATA FOR FIVE YEARS
THAT SHOW THAT ARE PROVEN
METHODS. FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
THERE ARE PYUNIK METHODS WORK
IN THE LATINO COMMUNITY THE C.
R. D. P. CURRENTLY FUNDS THIRTY
FIVE OF THESE PROJECTS WE ARE
ONE OF THE THIRTY FIVE THEIR
SPREE HERE AND FRESNO SERVING
THE FIVE POPULATION GROUPS
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATIN NEXT
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER NATIVE
AMERICANS AND LGBTQ PLUS- WE
ARE STATE- YOU FUND- CONTINUE
TO FUND- THESE PROJECTS AT
THEIR CRITICAL IMPORTANT TO
EACH AND EVERYONE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND- WE SUPPORT-
THE PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION ONE
TIME FUNDING FROM THE SURPLUS
OF THE GENERAL FUND. OR ANY
OTHER STATE SOURCE- TO BE ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH- YOU KNOW SERVING
AND SERVING OUR COMMUNITIES. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NAY COLOR PLAY. WHY
NINETY PLAY GO AHEAD. GREETINGS
MADAM CHAIRS THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MERRY CLEAR VIA I AM
SPEAKING WITH THE KOREA OF THE
FIFTY MILLION TO SUSTAIN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT C. R. D. P. HAS BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE CULTURALLY
SPECIFIC PROGRAMMING FOR
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY.
HERE IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
PROGRAMS AS EVENTS- A MINOR IF
THE PARENTS PROGRAM FOR P. I
AND OTHERS. I AM AT THE MOMENT
AMERICAN ELDER AND HE TIRED
HERE TO GET THE SHARE. I HAVE
EXTENDED FAMILY WITH NIECES AND
NEPHEWS. AND I ALSO HAVE
ATTENDED AT THE MONOCLE MORE
THAN ONE TIME. AN IMPRIMATUR TO
SUPPORT REYES MY FAMILY. AND AT
AT THE MONACO WELCOME
INTEGRATION BECAUSE THE STAFF
UNDERSTOOD MY CULTURAL VALUES
AND NORMS. BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
AT THE MONACO VIçT SPACE
BASED **** ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SUICIDE WHICH THE
LATTER IS VERY HIGH ACCORDING
TO DATA AMONG PACIFIC NINE
THREE YEARS. AFTER THE MODEL
ALSO PROVIDED RESOURCES
REGARDING HEALTH BE SAFE DURING
COLD AT NINETEEN. I APPLAUD THE
RDP FOR FUNDING AT THE MONITOR
AND OTHER. BY COSTS IN LGBT. HE
PLUS PRO. AND IT TIME I JUST
WANTED YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN YOU'RE SPEAKING ON TWO
ITEMS FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE A CLOG MY PORES ARE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
TO EXTEND MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR
ALL POSTPARTUM WOMEN TO TWELVE
MONTHS IN THE PREGNANCY AS WELL
AS CONTINUOUS COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE YEARS
OLD. AND YOU KNOW MADAM CHAIR
ONE OF EIGHT CALLS LONG TEN ANY
PRIORITY IS TO ENSURE WOMEN
RECEIVE APPROPRIATE HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE ESPECIALLY DURING THE
POSTPARTUM PERIOD. THANK YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN AUTHORSHIP OF
FIVE SEVEN SEVEN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
EXTENDING POSTPARTUM COVERAGE
FROM SIXTY DAYS TO TWELVE
MONTHS FOR POSTPARTUM WOMEN
SPECIFICALLY WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS. THE
STAR THE PANDEMIC THIS SPECIFIC
EXTENSION HAS NEVERACTUALLY
BEEN IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE OF THE
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE REQUIREMENT
ESTABLISHED EDGES ALL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AT THE
STATE LOOK BEYOND THE PANDEMIC
AND UNDERLINES THE CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE WE BELIEVE NOW IS THE
IDEAL TIME TO MAINTAIN THIS
COVERAGE FOR ALL WOMEN.
REGARDLESS OF CONDITION AND TO
SEEK A FEDERAL MATCH WHICH IS
CURRENTLY NOT ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CURRENT LIMITED EXTENSION
QUICKLY ON BEHALF OF C. G. BE
ABLE SERVICES WE ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THE FUNDING PROPOSAL
AND TRIBAL LANGUAGE THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED
CROSSOVER PAYMENT THAT ALLOWS
MEDICARE TO COVER THE UNPAID
20% COINSURANCE FOR MEDICARE
SERVICES. TO TREAT BABY BE ABLE
HEALTH CONDITIONS OF SENIOR
STAFF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RENT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE HUNDRED FOR ONE GO
AHEAD. MORE TURN MEMBERS
CLEARLY IMPEDED JUSTICE IN
AGING. MAJOR THE COSPONSOR WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW POND OF
THEIR TERMINATE THE MEDIC HOW.
LEARN SUPPORT WE THIS CHANGE
CREDIT TO OLDER. AND PEOPLE
WITH THIS. THE MOST AFFECTED BY
COLD HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
MEDICARE. THE CURRENT RULE
MEANS THAT OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES HOW TO
LIVE IN POVERTY TO QUALIFY FOR
MEDI CAL. PARTICULARLY AFFECTS
BLACK AND BROWN CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE LESS LIKELY TO OWN
EXEMPTS HOME AND MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE CASH SAVINGS. WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY PASSED OUT THAT FOR
THE MAJORITY OF MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS BECAUSE OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT I'M SHOULD
STOP THE PRACTICE FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. ALL THE HUNDRED
AND ONE ORGANIZED. SUPPORTED
THE TO. AS WELL. WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT EXPANDING
MEDICAID TO ALL SENIORS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS THERE ARE VERY NEEDY
GROUP WHO HAS- TYPICALLY BEEN
LOCKED OUT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCENT. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENT IN A MEDIC CAL DATA
TRANSPARENCY REQUEST BY THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORT
OF WHICH WE ARE A MEMBER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE FORTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DONNA THANKS FOR BEGINNING A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS COUNTY IS ONE OF
THE CROWD TELEPROMPTERS AT THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR NINE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
BEGIN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
MEDIC HELP YOUR SUPPORT
SPECIALIST CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM. PURSUANT TO SB EIGHT
OH THREE BY SENATOR BELL WHICH
WAS ENACTED LAST YEAR. HERE'S
ARE INSTRUMENTAL TO IMPROVE
TREATMENT OUTCOMES AND TO
CONSOLIDATE THE INTEGRATION. OF
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT SERVICES. BAKER
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM WOULD
ESTABLISH STANDARDIZED TRAINING
PRACTICE GUIDELINES IN CLINICAL
SUPERVISION REQUIREMENTS FOR
PEER. AND FAMILY SUPPORT
SPECIALIST THAT WOULD NEED TO
MEET STANDARDS. SET BY FEMA. WE
URGE YOUR BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
AND THE FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
TO ADOPT THIS IMPORTANT
PROPOSAL AND I THINK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AT. GOOD
MORNING- MADAM CHAIR THE JUST
HER AGAIN DAHLE EASEMENT
REPRESENTING THE SPINE BURKE
INSTITUTE AN INDEPENDENT NON
PROFIT PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE
WHICH FOCUSES TO DOWNTOWN
PUBLIC POLICY ON THE ISSUE
BRAIN HELP VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE'S ONGOING COMMITMENT
TO TRACKING ISSUE THE BRAIN
HEALTH. AND ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS PROPOSAL I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN START UP FUNDS FOR THE MEDIC
HOW PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM THE
INSTITUTE WITH A CROWD
COSPONSORED AND PETER THREE BY
SENATOR ABOUT LAST. YEAR
ESTABLISHING A PROGRAM. OR IS
IN ACTIVE IN BASED COSTA. MODEL
HERE PRUDENT REDUCE COPLEY. AND
HOMELESS. INCREASED BY BECAUSE
TREAT ON START. WITH THE ARMED
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE AND THE NEED FOR CARE
ON THE CONTINUING TO SKYROCKET
TO THE COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
HERE THEY ARE AN INVALUABLE
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE TO GETTING
PEOPLE THE CARE THEY NEED. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. ONE FORTY
YOU ARE. HELLO GOOD MORNING HI
MITCH MATTHEWS WITH HEALTH
PROJECTS TO RIPLEY DEL MAR CARE
RESOURCE CENTER I HEARD YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET INCREASE
FOR THE CARE RESOURCE CENTERS
OVER THE LIMITED TIME OF THREE
YEARS. ORCHESTRATING CARE
RESOURCE CENTERS INCREASE OUR
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION FAMILY
CAREGIVERS TO KEEP THEIR LOVED
ONES IN THE HOME AS OPPOSED TO
BEING. PLACED IN A NURSING
HOME. BY GETTING THE ERC'S
AUGMENTATION TEN MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR ADDITIONAL
TO YOUR VIEW ON THE ORIGINAL
SUNSET DATE. YOU'D EXPIRING
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND ALLOW
THE CARE RESOURCE CENTER TO
CONTINUE EXPANDING THEIR
EFFORT. A PERSONALIZED
COMPASSIONATE EVIDENCE BASED
SERVICES THAT FAMILY
CAREGIVERS. WE NEED FOR MORE
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES SUPPORTING FAMILY
CAREGIVERS PEOPLE AFFECTED WITH
ALZHEIMER'S IS ON THE RISE AND
IMAGES. INCREASING CALIFORNIA
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR
SUPPORTING AND HELPING CABLE
CARRIERS TO KEEP THEM IN IN
THEIR HOME AND PROVIDE THE
COMPANY CARE THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR GREAT WORK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHAT
WHAT SEVEN YOU ARE UP. HI MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY-
I'M FRED FISHER PRESIDENT CEO
OF THE ENLISTED ASSOCIATION
CALLED THE LAST CHAPTER WE
OPERATE CLIFORNIA'S WRAPAROUND
SYSTEM OF CARE FOR PEOPLE
LIVING WITH THEIR LAST STATE
FUNDING RESULTED IN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN SERVICE
TO EVERYONE LIVING WITH ALS OR
MY TO THE PEOPLE AVAIL APPS ARE
AMONG THE HIGHEST RISKS FOR
COLIN AND WE KEPT OUR COMMUNITY
OUT OF BIG D. R. AND ICY USE
OUR EARLY TICKET TO HELLO
HELLO. AND OUR EXPECTATION OF A
HYBRID MODEL GOING FORWARD IS
OFTEN MORE PEOPLE BEING SERVED
INCLUDING THOSE TRADITIONALLY-
AND LIVING IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ARE EVIDENCE BASED
MULTI DISCIPLINARY MODEL OF
CARE IS THE ONLY THING THAT
HELPS PEOPLE LIVE LONGER AND
BETTER WITH THE L. APPS
CONTINUED FUNDING IS ESSENTIAL
TO SUSTAINING THE SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT IS THE
BEST HOPE FOR PEOPLE LIVING
WITH A LS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS CALL PLEASE. ONE
FORTY PLEASE CALL AT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR I MEAN YOU
CAN KANSEN SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH
NETWORK WHICH IS THE STATEWIDE
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WORKING
TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING A BLACK CALIFORNIANS.
REGION IS STRONGLY SUPPORTING
THE BUDGET REQUESTS REGARDING
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A HEALTH
EQUITY FUNDING CALIFORNIA
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER TWO YEARS DO YOU THINK
CHAMPION BY FAMILY MEMBER MIKE
GIPSON AND ROB BONTA. AS WE ALL
KNOW BY NOW THE CORONAVIRUS AND
DID MAKE AN EXACERBATED AND
AMPLIFIED INEQUITIES AND
VULNERABILITIES THAT HAVE LONG
LIKE THIS IN OUR COMMUNITY
ESTABLISHMENT OF A HEALTH
EQUITY FUND WOULD WORK TO
ADDRESS THE OPTION FACTORS AND
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY CONTRIBUTE TO THE
PANDEMICS BUT THE QUESTION%
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S BLACK
LATINO INDIGENOUS TEENAGER
COLOR. NEED FOR DEFINING IT
URGENT DEPENDING ON HOW TO
ANYTHING DEVELOPMENT YOUR TYPE
OF HEALTH AND PREVENTION MORE
LEAVE IT TO THE RIGHT THING TO
DO STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES AND
SOCIAL STRUCTURES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER TO HELP IS
VERY CANNOT STATE BLACK
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC LIFE
EXPECTANCY IN THE STATE AND
BLACK INDIGENOUS IN CANADA
COLOR STEM FROM MANY HEALTH
INEQUITIES THAT ARE LARGELY
PREVENTABLE I ACTUALLY THIS IS
ALSO THE RIGHT THING TO DO. BUT
IT DOES SOUND IF WE INVEST IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PREVENTION
WOULD SPEND LESS ON HEALTHCARE
ON THE BACKING AND IN ADDITION
TO HELP EQUITY FUND YOU CAN
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
PROPOSAL TO OBTAIN CONTINUES
MEDICAL COVERAGE FROM BIRTH TO
AGE FIVE OR TWELVE MUCH BOTH
PART IN THAT ACCOUNT YASOTHON
SUPPORT THEY CAME BACK AGAIN
THE COALITION COMPLETE BY THE
BUDGET PACKAGE. WILL SUPPORT
LIMITING THE MEDICAL ACT THAT
AT THE SAME SPONSORED BY THE
WEST IN GENERAL LONG POVERTY
AND FINALLY BE SUPPORT FUNDING
REQUEST TO DETAIN THE
CALIFORNIA'S REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT THANKS FOR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR PLEASE. ONE FORTY
FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIRMAN TWENTY REYNOLDS
CALIFORNIA'S VISORS BEHALF OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES. THE
REQUESTED WHEN HE FIRED MILLION
TO ALSO THRIVE PROJECT. THE
EIGHTEEN THE LARGEST FUNDED
AFFECT THE THREE YEAR KILEY OF
ALL CHILDREN TO FUND THROUGH A
TENDERING DOLLAR. BUDGET OUT IN
THE TWO EIGHT MENTAL HEALTH ACT
ALL CHILDREN DRIVERS IN THE
STATEWIDE INITIATIVE THAT
SUPPORTS TRUCK CALIFORNIAN
MITIGATING THE DESPERATE
EFFECTS OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ON CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
CHILDREN AND CHILDREN OF COLOR.
ALL CHILDREN THRIVE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY ENGAGED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
THAT GOAL THE DINER ROAD MAP TO
SUCCESS AND ADOPT ACTION PLANS
THE INITIATIVE WAS IMPLEMENTED
THROUGH A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE CALIFORNIA DPH OFFICIALS
WERE CHILDHOOD INITIATIVE.
COMMUNITY PARTNERS PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES AND THE UCLA
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITY. THE
REQUESTED A LOCATION AT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION WE'LL TAKE THIS
PROGRAM FROM PILOT TO BROAD
BASED IMPLEMENTATION BRINGING
ONE HUNDRED NEW CALIFORNIA
CITIES ON BOARD OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS. HE SAID HE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
BUDGET REQUESTS FROM OUR
PARTNERS AT COUNTY HELP
EXECUTIVES AND HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION FOR TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
AND THREE POINT FOUR FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR A
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WORKFORCE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK PLEASE. WHY
ONE FIFTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS- MICROBES AND ON BEHALF
QUEST DIAGNOSTICS- CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE CLINICAL LAB
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY ITEM
PUT FORWARD BY THE CALIFORNIA
CLINICAL ABBASI'S STATION-
JUST- WILL QUICKLY IT WON'T LET
YOU KNOW THAT- THE EXISTING
MULTIPLE RETROACTIVE IN A
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS CURRENTLY
PUT FORWARD BY CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY BY THE DEPARTMENT-
MAKE IT- VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE LABS IN CALIFORNIA TO
PLAN. BUDGET ND STAFF THERE AT
THEIR OPERATIONS IN CALIFORNIAN
TO CERTAIN MEDICAL POPULATION
IN THE BUDGET APPROPRIATION
BEING SOUGHT WILL HELP- WILL
HELP ALLEVIATE THAT THAT DURING
THE PANDEMIC CORDONED FOR THE
AT THIS POINT IN TIME. IN THE
CLOSE TRAILER BILL SENT TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S ADDRESS ONCE
BEFORE BUT- IT IS NEEDING TO BE
DONE IN THE BUDGET NOW AND- HIM
WINNING. THE 80% CAP ON
MEDICARE. COLLEGES THAT-
MEDICARE RATES ALREADY BEEN.
SEEING REDUCED. ON TO THEIR OWN
MARK RATE- THAT'S ABOUT. YOU
HAVE THAT ANYTHING ON TOP OF
THAT BY MEDIKAL DUPLICATIVE AND
UNNECESSARY. AND IT FORCES LAPS
TO HAVE EITHER A- SERVICES
REDUCE THEIR WORKFORCE OR
REDUCE INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA
SO- WE SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JUSTIN RANDALL THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE COMMENTS FOR
TWO ISSUES- THE DA IF REQUESTED
A ONE TIME ALLOCATION ON A
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND TO REIMBURSE THANK YOU FOR
NEW MEDICALLY NECESSARY EP
WHICH WITHOUT THE CANNOT BE
PROVIDE DENTAL CARE. THANK YOU
CAN GET THE TEAM MEMBERS HAD
SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF
WORKPLACE EXPOSURES TO AIRBORNE
PATHOGENS LIKE KOBE NINETEEN
THE INVESTMENT IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM OVER RECENT YEARS
INCLUDING THE RESTORATION OF
ADULT BENEFIT THE DTI AND
PROPERTY SIX RATING WE CAN'T
HAVE MADE IT MORE. SUSTAINABLE
PROGRAM PRESENTED. WHAT KIND
AND INVESTMENT BY THE BY HAD
GET ALL THE TEN.AND IN CHURCH
EMPLEADOS. AND IT'S 1% IN THE
NUMBER OF DENTAL SAID THAT MANY
OUT. DESPITE COMPLETED MEANT OF
THE NINETEENTH IS PUTTING YOU
PREVENT AT RISK. FACTORS YOU
CANNOT AFFORD TO THE ADDITIONAL
OVERHEAD COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASED PP AT THE VERY TO
PROVIDE. CARE DURING PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES. THAT'S NOT
WHAT HELP ENSURE THAT MEDICARE
DOES THE- CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
OUR HEALTH THE BENEFICIARIES OF
NOT PASSING THE REST DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND SECONDLY WOULD
LIKE WE ALSO LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT OF WHAT YOU CENTER
LAMPARD VIS A DEFICIT AGING I
REQUEST ELIMINATE THE MEDICAL
AFTER THAT. AT THE END OF THE
IS ADVERTISED FOR APPLICANTS.
BY EDITH UP OVER AGE SIXTY FIVE
WILL IMPROVE AFTER THE ORAL
HEALTH BY INJURY MEDIC HAL. AND
MEDICARE DO A LEGIBILITY FOR
LOW INCOME SENIORS. TWENTY
AROUND TWENTY YEARS RELY SOLELY
ON MEDICARE FOR HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE AND LACK COVERAGE FOR
DENTAL CARE THEY OFTEN HAVE TO
MAKE DIFFICULT DECISIONS ON HOW
TO SPEND LIMITED FINANCIAL
REPORT. SUCH AS GOING. FOR
GOING TO. TEACHERS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LIKE COLOR
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND THEY TOOK THEM
OUT OF Q. WE WILL GO TO ONE
FORTY SIX THANK YOU. RIGHT GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MANY MISSILES
ON FRANCE THAT THE BUT OF YOUR
NOW. SO NOW I'M THRILLED WE ASK
TO BE GREAT. FIVE MILLION
COMPACT ENOUGH. AFTER WHILE YOU
WORRY VERY SHOULD BE TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS ONE COULD
BE. PURCHASED OF IT I THANK.
YOU ALL RIGHT. INCREASE BUT AS
FAR. THE END NOW NEEDED BUT
WEEK. FIVE OKAY PARTNERSHIP OUR
NET THE FOR THAT YEAH IN.
PEOPLE AND WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT THEY COLLECTED FOR
SOME AS EARLY. IN A- WHAT ARE
PARTNERS FOLLOWING ITEMS. YOUR
SUPPORT SPECIALISTS EDUCATION
AS NINE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLAR MEDIC HOUSE FOR YOU
CHILDREN THE THREE FIVE BIRD
DAHLE OFF MY FOOT. IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE LATEST. OF THE
THAT KEEP COVERAGE HOW MARKET
THEY TO TELL. WE APPRECIATE
THAT THEY ARE GOING THAT IT
MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR THOSE
BUT BUT ALSO. I PLEDGE FOR ANY
CHILD THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK CARPOOL. ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOU ARE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS LATE ON
BEHALF OF THE TOLD SPECIALTY
CARE BECAUSE REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY FIVE PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALISTS BROUGHT
CALIFORNIA IF I TOOK PROPER
SUPPORT FOR A COUPLE OF THE
PROPOSAL BEING HURT TODAY FIRST
WE SUPPORT COVERING HOLDEN
CONTINUOUSLY TO AGE FIVE AND
ADULTS FOR TWELVE MONTHS
FOLLOWING A PREGNANCY IN MY
ACCOUNT. CONTINUE WITH
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE IS
ESSENTIAL TO AVOIDING
DISRUPTIONS IN CARE ESPECIALLY
DURING THE CRITICAL PHASES IN
LIFE WHEN MEDICAL PERFECT FOR
FREQUENT MEDIC HOW THAT
BENEFICIARIES HAVE HAD
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC AND CONTINUING
THE- COVERAGE FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN THAT POSTPARTUM WOMEN.
WILL REMOVE THE BARRIER CARE
RESULTING IN MANY BENEFITS
INCLUDING THE CHANCE FOR
CHILDREN BUT IN THE PREVENTIVE
CARE ON THE BALLOT I DON'T
THINK. I FOLLOWED MANAGING A
COMPLEX OR CHRONIC CONDITIONS
THEY MAY BE DEALING WITH WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE 10% RATE
REDUCTION FOR COMPLEX
REHABILITATION TECHNOLOGY WHICH
IS IMPEDING ACCESS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY EQUIPMENT FOR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS THAT THEY
CAN DISABILITIES AND MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. WE URGE YOU TO
ADDRESS THIS BREAK HAD GIVEN
THE LIMITED NUMBER OF SUPPLIERS
WHO ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING FOR
FIFTY MEDICARE BENEFICIARY WITH
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES THANKS
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. WHY AND WHY
SEVENTY NECK. HI GOOD MORNING
HAPPY- A LITTLE HELPS MY NAME
IS NOT IN IN AND I WITH ASIAN
AND RECOVERY WHICH IS A PROGRAM
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY I AM HERE
REPRESENTING THE ESSENCE OF
MONACO GRAND WHICH IS ONE OF
THIRTY FIVE OF THE IDPS FOR
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT ALSO KNOWN AS THE C. R.
D. P. THE PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY HERE
IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND SAN
MATTEO COUNTY I AM SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY MILLION TO
SUSTAINED CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT THREE D.
RPG HAS BEEN SO VALUABLE TO OUR
COMMUNITY BY SUPPORTING OUR
UNDERGROUND EFFORTS WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH OUR COMPUTERS TO
HELP US IN UNDERSTANDING AND
LEARNING HOW TO COLLECT DATA.
ON A COMPUTER IS A LITTLE TO NO
DATA BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITY DOES
NOT TRUST UTILITY CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES SUPPORT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HONOR OUR
CULTURAL PRACTICES WHILE
LEARNING HOW TO BRIDGE OUR
COMMUNITIES BECOME. A BEGIN TO
COLLECT THE DATA SO IN
ACCRETIONARY WE ASK FOLKS HOW
COMFORTABLE THEY FELT ABOUT A
MENTAL HEALTH AND ABOUT HALF OF
THEM SAID SOMEWHAT COMFORTABLE
BUT AFTER A TWELVE WEEK COURSE
IN DURING OUR POST SURVEYS WERE
ABLE TO FIND AT THEM IT WAS
INCREASE 80% WHICH IS ALSO
WHICH THIS WAS BECAUSE WE WERE
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT TABOO TOPICS
IN THE STATE'S FAMILY SETTING.
WITH COLBERT NINETEEN HAD DONE
MAKE ALSO WOULD KNOW THAT AND
CITING DEPRESSION IS ON THE
RISE WE NEED TO KEEP CONTINUING
TO PROVIDE SAFE SPACES LIKE
THIS ARE COMMITTED TO PROCESS I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU TWO
QUICK QUOTES FROM TWO
PARTICIPANTS THIS IS FROM A
GREAT GRANDMOTHER- I SOMEONE
GREAT GRANDMOTHER AND SHE SAYS
THE QUESTION IS A NEW APPROACH
IN CHILD REARING LEARNING HOW
TO SHOW LOVE. AND HOW TO SPEAK
WITHOUT THE COMMITTEE I REALLY
CULTURALLY WE DO WHAT WE KNOW
NOW I KNOW DIFFERENT AND FROM
ACCOUNTING CURRENT SHE SAID THE
CULTURAL PART OF ESSENCE OF
MONUMENT MANY THINGS TO ME I
REMEMBER WALKING EACH IN THE
FIRST DAY AND I FELT SAFE
COMFORTABLE AND WELCOME
INSTANCE I FELT THAT WAY I
BEGAN TO. SO EASILY. ABLE TO
SHARE MY EXPERIENCES MY LIFE
START. POPPING UP WITH PACIFIC
ON THE COMMITTEE I LIKE TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT. AND FUND
EXTENSION FOR THE- READ. JUST
ACROSS. LET'S CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER BECOME A OF AND
STABILIZE WELL INCREASING MY-
CAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WERE
YOUR CALL. AND THE AFTER. TO
PROVIDE A PUBLIC. I WANTED YOU
IN OUR NATIVE TONGUE- IN
SOMEONE I WANT TO SAY PARKS
QUITE A LOT. AND KANYON MODEL
OF PEOPLE AND INCLUSION MODEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALL
PLEASE THE MODERATOR COULD YOU.
A PROMPT THAT THE TO THE- AGAIN.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU ARE. MADAM
CHAIR AND GET IF YOU'D LIKE TO
ASK. ERROR PUT YOURSELF IN
QUEUE FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
THE QUEUE YOU CAN HIT ONE ZERO
AGAIN AN OPERATOR IS GOING TO.
GET YOUR LINE NUMBER OFF LINE
IN PLACE YOU BACK IN Q. ONE
ZERO AGAIN FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THINK AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MADAME CHIANG MAI NUMBER MY
NAME IS SALLY CHANG AND I'M TO
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER WITH
THE SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE
ACTION CENTER. HE WRAPPED. AND
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
FIFTY MILLION HISPANIC
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL DISPARITIES
PROJECT. ON THE- HE- ACTUALLY
TOOK A BREAK CARE CRITICAL THE
SOUTHEAST ASIAN AMERICANS TO
EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATES MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES INCLUDING
MAJOR DEPRESSION PTSD AND
OTHER. DISORDERS COMPARED. TO
THE GENERAL POPULATION. INTO
THE BARGELLO AND- BRANCH 62% OF
OLDER CAN AND EXPERIENCE AND OF
PTSD COMPARED 23% THE GENERAL
POPULATION. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
HE RECOLLECTED NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY COMMENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND CONDUCTED
COMMUNITY SURVEYS FOCUS GROUPS
AND INTERVIEWS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA A PART OF REPORT ON%
THE MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
FACED BY THE SOUTHEAST ASIAN
COMMUNITY. WE FOUND THAT 75% OF
DIRECTLY IMPACTED RESPONDENTS
INDICATED THAT THEY WERE NEVER
ABLE TO RECEIVE APPROPRIATE
MENTAL HEALTH. SERVICES ONLY
SEVENTEEN ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
EVERY ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EIGHT YEAH I IN THE US. BUT THE
LOWEST RATIO THE NATIVE
LANGUAGE SPEAKING HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS FOR LAOTIAN
CAMBODIAN AND LONGER AGAIN. BUT
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE CONTINUE
TO FIND SUPPORT CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES. SUCH AS
THOSE PROVIDED BY PURITY
CHIROPRACTIC LONG CULTURAL
CENTER THE BUTTE COUNTY THE
FRESNO CENTER AND THE CAMBODIAN
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE THIRTY
EIGHTH BAKER BANK THEREFORE IF
THE RECORD IS THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED. LAND IN
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THE
SURPLUS OF THE GENERAL FUND OR
ANY OTHER STATE BUDGET FIRST
APPEAR TO THE SAME. HE. FOR
THREE ADDITIONAL YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NICE COLOR PLEASE.
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY YOUR UP. YEAH
GOOD MORNING MADAM AND MEMBERS
THE COLD WAR DOMAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE CHOI PARTNERSHIP FIRST
WE AGREE DR PAN BUDGET CAN
INCLUDE SYSTEMS CHANGE THAT
ADDRESS RACISM AND EQUITY
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE CO
SPONSORING THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE CONTINUOUS MEDICARE
COVERAGE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN AND
TWELVE MONTH COVERAGE POST
PARTUM. IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
WE ASSOCIATE WITH THE OTHER
COMMENTS PROVIDED IN SUPPORT
THREE ADDITIONAL POINTS.
CONTINUE COVERAGE IS AN
IMPORTANT PROTECTION FOR
CHILDREN AT THE STATE ZACKS AND
UNPRECEDENTED MASTERY
DETERMINATION FOR MEDIC CAL
BENEFICIARIES AFTER THE
PANDEMIC IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE IS ALSO
ESSENTIAL TO INCREASE THE
DISMALLY LOW MEDI CAL PEDIATRIC
PREVENTATIVE CARE. AND THIS
PROPOSAL WILL HELP ADDRESS OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM BY REMOVING
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS TO
CONTINUED COVERAGE THIS
PROPOSAL WILL NOT HAVE COSTS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND I'M GOING
COSTS WILL BE OFFSET BY SAVINGS
FROM REDUCED RINGLET MINISTRY
HA. SECONDARILY ON THE MEDICAL
LEGAL PARTNERSHIPS PROPOSAL AND
ALL PLEASE HAVE ADDRESSED A
MYRIAD OF LEGAL ISSUES THAT
HAVE ARISEN DURING THE PANDEMIC
THREATENING THE WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WHO HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN.
THEIR WORKERS REMOVED BARRIERS
TO FOOD HOUSING EDUCATION
HEALTHCARE PUBLIC BENEFITS AND
EMPLOYMENT WITH WHOLE FAMILY A
WHOLE CHILD APPROACH IS NEEDED
NOW MORE THAN EVER AS FAMILIES
BEGIN TO RECOVR FROM THE
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
WILL OPEN UP LINE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT. HELLO I MEAN I GUESS WE
CAN'T.HELLO HI EVERYONE MY
NAME IS MICHELLE EVAN LOW QUITE
ABOUT WHAT THE TERM BUT THE NOT
COALITION ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS FOR THE TRANSGENDER
WANTED TO EQUITY FUND BUT YOUR
QUESTION. ON THE PART OF A
LARGER COALITION MEANS THAT
CALIFORNIA JACK POLICY
ALLIANCE. WE ARE SO EXCITED TO
HAVE AYE BUT YOU'RE QUITE BE ON
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY AND MONEY
NOW AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN OF
THE BILL THAT PASSED LAST YEAR
WHICH ESTABLISHED THE
TRANSGENDER WANTED AN EQUITY
FUND WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE OF THE COLD AND-
PANDEMIC THE DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT
WAS ALLOCATED TO THAT- DEFINED
WHICH STRIP OUT OF ART BELL.
AND SO WE ARE WE APPROACHING IT
THIS YEAR ASK THE LEGISLATURE
TO FIND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO FUND HOLISTIC HELP THERE BUT
THAT. TRANSCANADA COMBINING AN
INTERSEX PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
REALLY HOPING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE CAN
INVEST IN GIGI I LIVE SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- AND HAVE A GREAT
DAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY CALL
A- GOOD MORNING ILEEN JAPAN
THE WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE INTEND
TO FOLLOW UP WITH SUBCOMMITTEE
VIA A WRITTEN MEMO ADDRESSING
SPECIFIC STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL
AS WELL AS ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSALS THAT WE'VE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO COMMENT ON DURING THE
HEARINGS. ONE GLOBAL COMMENT WE
HAVE AT THIS TIME IS THAT MANY
OF THE PROPOSALS ARE GOING TO
BE CONSIDERING HAVE AUTOMATION
IMPACTS ARE YOU KNOW WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF THE FEDERALLY
MANDATED CONSOLIDATION OF OUR
AUTOMATED WELFARE SYSTEMS WITH
MIGRATION BEGINNING THIS
SEPTEMBER THE FADING IN OVER A
COUPLE OF YEAR. THAT WOULD
LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF PROGRAMMING
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH DURING THAT
TIME FRAME WE WILL COMMENT MORE
SPECIFICALLY IN OUR MEMO BUT
TIMELINE FOR AUTOMATION WILL
DEPEND ON WHAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE FINAL BUDGET PACKAGE WE ARE
HAPPY TO ENGAGE ON THIS ISSUE
AND ASK THAT WE BE INCLUDED IN
DISCUSSION FOR AUTOMATION OF
THE CONSIDERATION WE CAN HELP
YOU COMPARE OPTIONS THAT MAY BE
SIMPLE OR MORE COMPLEX
AUTOMATE. AS WELL AS TRADE OFF
FOR LEGISLATORS TO CONSIDER
AMONG OTHER THINGS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ALEX BEEN FELLED
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
TRANSGENDER GENDER VARIANT
INTERSECTS JUSTICE PROJECT OR
T. G. I. G. P. FOR SHORT AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF ALLOCATING
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
TRANS GENDER BONUS AND EQUITY
FUND. WE AT THE G. I. G. P.
APPLICANTS ARE CLIENT STRUGGLES
ACT OF HEALTH CARE YOU TO
SCARCITY OF CULTURALLY
COMPETENT HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
U. S. TRANSPORTATION 33% OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHO HAD BEEN
A PROVIDER IN THE PAST YEAR OR
BOARD OF HAVING AT LEAST ONE
NEGATIVE EXPERIENCE WITH A
DOCTOR. OR OTHER HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER RELATED TO BEING
TRANSGENDER RANGING FROM EXUAL
OR PHYSICAL ASSAULT TO DENIAL
OF BASIC CARE NOT RELATED TO
GENDER AFFIRMATION OF THE
RESULT 23% OF RESPONDENTS
REPORTED THAT THEY AVOIDED
SPEAKING HEALTH CARE THEY
NEEDED IN THE PAST YEAR DUE TO
FEAR OF BEING MISTREATED ON THE
TRANSGENDER PERSON. HE AYE
PEOPLE ALSO EXPERIENCE HEALTH
WORKING AT A HIGHER RATE THAN
THE GENERAL POPULATION YOU TO
DISCRIMINATION IN HOUSING.
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT. THE
FUNDING BECOMES. CULTURALLY
COMPETENT. ACROSS THE UP. WILL
BE BETTER ABLE TO SERVE- I
DIDN'T CREATE ANYTHING CREEK
NEED AFFORDABLE AND UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE AT A TIME IN WHICH SUCH
FUNDING. IT'S CRITICAL FOR THE
WELL BEING AND SURVIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU DIANA DOUGLAS ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACT OF
CALIFORNIA BEGINNER SPONSORED
COVERED CALIFORNIA
AFFORDABILITY PROPOSAL THE
GROUNDBREAKING COMPANIES THAT
WE WORK TOGETHER TO SECURE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND ALMOST HALF
A MILLION CALIFORNIANS RELY
UPON ARE SET TO EXPIRE AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.%
RECENTLY WE MUST RENEW THE
SUBSIDIES THIS YEAR FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO PLAN
FOR TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WE
ALSO WELCOME THE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL PORTABILITY ASSISTANCE
NOW PENDING IN THE U. S.
SENATE. YOU TO CALIFORNIA'S
HIGH COST OF LIVING WE URGE OUR
LEGISLATURE TO REPURPOSE
ORGANISING INVESTMENT IN
AFFORDABILITY AND STATE
SUBSIDIES ECHO PARTNERING
KEEPING COSTS DOWN. ESPECIALLY
TO ADDRESS SOARING DEDUCTIBLES.
FINALLY A PROPOSAL TO USE
EXISTING THING INVESTMENT TO
PAY FOR THE ONE DOLLAR PER
MEMBER PER MONTH PREMIUMS FOR
STATE ONLY COVERAGE WOULD
FURTHER REDUCE FINANCIAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS. THANK
YOU TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS FROM ENROLLING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING NO EQUITABLE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ON
BEHALF OF OUR FARM WORKER
IMMIGRANT MIGRANT COMMUNITIES
WE SUPPORT FUNDING PROPOSALS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA MEDIC CAL FOR ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE SENIORS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS WE SUPPORT WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
ELIMINATING THE MEDICAL ASSETS
TASK AND WE ALSO LOOK TO
SUPPORT OCTOBER CALIFORNIA
PROPOSALS THAT THE HEALTH
PRACTICES BOB PROMOTING THAT
WOULD- PROVIDE. STAY SUBSIDY
EXPANSION AND ALSO ZERO
PREMIUMS FOR COVER CALIFORNIA
PLAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAMEIS GAYNOR
AND GIANCANA- OF PACIFIC
ISLANDERS THANK I COME TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO SPAIN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT THANK CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE ESSENCE OF MINUS
ONE OF THE THIRTY FIVE PILOT
PROJECTS UNDER THE R. D. P.
THAT HUNTER THE PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY. NOTHING ID
PEACOCK. AS THE ABLE TO CREATE
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC PROGRAMMING
RPI COMMUNITY R. P. I COMMUNITY
HAS THE HIGHEST SEVEN THIRTY
AND HAS BEEN UNDERSERVED
POPULATION FOR DECADES. AT THE
PRODUCT OF THE MINOR I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO FIND HEALING AND
PEACE AND LYFT GROW. WITH A
HEALING AND GROWTH I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO UTILIZE MY TALENTS AND
PAINT I'M A LEADER AND ADVOCATE
FOR ALL COMMUNITIES. I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO TRANSFER MY PAIN
OF BEING A VICTIM TO BEING A
STRONG SURVIVOR. S. IS A MINOR
HER CUSTOMIZE THE MANY
ISLANDERS AT THE SOUTH END AS
WELL AS OUR OTHER BROTHERS AND
SISTERS OF CULTURE. IT IS ONE
THING FOR PARKING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL BUT IT MEANS MORE
FOR PROJECT TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
ACTIONS OF. MINOR HAS BEEN
BEYOND EFFECTIVE. LAST THING I
WANT TO THINK YOU. ALL THE CAR
BE TO THE WORK. EVERY DAY TO MY
HEALING TO THE ATHLETES MINE
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO EXTEND
THE T. R. D. P. FOR THIRTY FIVE
PROJECT AND CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE HARD WORK AND
CONNECTING MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES AND SERVICES FOR A
COMPLETELY UNDER COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. A
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CANYON MARTIN
ON BEHALF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
RECALLING TODAY TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR ALL OF THE REQUEST
IN THE END THE EPIDEMIC
COALITION BUDGET PACKAGE WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
PROJECT INVESTMENT TO ATTRACT
EACH I NEED ACTUAL MY WILL HAVE
A KIND OF AN OVERDOSE EPIDEMIC
AS WE CONFRONT THE COMING
NINETEEN CRISIS. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR THE
TRANSGENDER WILDLIFE AND EQUITY
FUND WHICH WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE SERVING
TRANSGENDER GENDER
NONCONFORMING AND AFFECT
CALIFORNIANS THANK FOR MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU
ARE OLD. A ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE I'LL GO AHEAD AND RE
PROMPT. IN THE MEANTIME WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
FIFTY TWO PLEASE CALL AT. FIFTY
TWO CAN YOU HEAR ME. SEEMS LIKE
EVERYONE'S LEFTIST OPERATOR
YEAH. THANK GOD I WAS JUST
WANTING TO WILL TRY ANOTHER ONE
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT. MY NAME IS MARY
SHERIDAN AND I'M DIRECTOR OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS.
I'M A FORMER FAMILY CAREGIVER
AND PROFESSIONAL. OUR FAMILY
CARE GIVERS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
DECADES I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT THE ONE TIME
FUNDING EXTENSION NEEDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS. THE RAVAGES A COUPLE
BUT NINETEEN HAVE AMPLIFIED THE
NEED TO FAMILY CAREGIVERS
ACROSS THE STATE PARTICULARLY
IN BLACK AND LATINO COMMUNITIES
THE ADDED STRESSORS OF CARE
GIVING DURING THE PANDEMIC.
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED INCREASED
BURDENS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE NEED YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS TO BUILD
AN EQUITY AND INCLUSION CORE TO
INCREASE SERVICE LEVELS IN
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. AND TO
ADEQUATELY DEVELOP A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT STAFF
AND RESOURCES TO SERVE ALL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
TO SUPPORT THE HEALTH OF FAMILY
CAREGIVERS. ARGUABLY THE LEAST
VISIBLE POPULATION IN THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE.
ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AGAIN BREAKING WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL FACED
BY THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM FOR FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. OR AT LUNCH
HOSTED TO DISTRACT THE FUNDING
GAP THE DATE AND BLINKER BUT
THE TRANSITION FROM THE PRIME-PROGRAM TO SECURE I. T. PROGRAM
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION PROPOSAL
FOR FORTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
THE HE HAD THAT PROGRAM PROJECT
OPERATE HERE HOLD COUNSELORS
BUT THEN HOSPITAL. AND MERGING
P. DEPARTMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COURT. ONE FIFTY
ONE YOU ARE. ONE FIFTY ONE ARE
YOU MUTED. WILL BE ALONG WITH A
LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY MY
NAME IS LAUREN WITH YOU NOT AND
I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF. THE
MONARCH ONE OF THIRTY FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION CURRENT PROJECTS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT. OR SHARE
TP. TWENTY THIRD OF THE
CALENDAR COMMUNITY AVAILABLE
COUNTY. I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSED FIFTEEN MILLION
FIFTEEN AND EXTEND THE FEAROF
THE PROJECT. IS IMPERATIVE
OPPORTUNITY PEACE BE OFFENDED
FOR AN ADDITIONAL THREE YEARS.
PRIOR TO KOBE NINETEEN OUR
PROGRAMS ARE NEEDED BUT EVEN
MORE SO NOW WITH AN INCREASE
AND THEN GRADY AND OPPRESSION I
SOLUTION FOR FAMILY. AND
FRIENDS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THE FINAL LOOK OKAY BUT YOU ARE.
AND IPP HOW- GROUND THREE WORK
AND LOOK. THE BRIDGE THE GAP
BETWEEN HOW AND ONE AMONG OUR-
OUR CULTURALLY. PROGRAM I GREW
TO BE. AND THEN THE WILL COULD
BRING ACROSS WE HAVE WORKED SO
HARD TO MAKE THE MARK. WE
CANNOT LET HER BEAT BOB THE AND-
FISCAL. THIS AND INCLUDES WITH
CALIFORNIA REDUCING THE
SPREADING. BUT EVEN SO AND
INVESTMENT INTO OUR PEOPLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IF I COULD SAY.
BY ANYBODY ELSE IN THE QUEUE
CALLING ON THE REDUCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES- MAYBE JUST YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION I HAVE.
MET WITH THE ORGANIZATION WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT IT- SO
PERHAPS AS PER THE SAKE OF THE
OF THE MANY MANY CALLS WE HAVE
IN THE QUEUE. JUST GIVE YOUR
NAME AND THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THAT FUNDING OF
THAT VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM OF
WHICH I'M VERY FAMILIAR OF I
HAVE ONE IN MY OWN COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. MISTER MODERATOR.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY I WAS MUTED
MY FAULT AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE NINETY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE JENNIFER
MALLEY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION OF THE LABOR
MOVEMENT HAS NOT FOR YEARS FOR
HIGH QUALITY HEALTH COVERAGE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS. IS WHY
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
EXPANDING HEALTH COVERAGE TO
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS. THE
PROVIDE ACT THE FOR THOSE
AFFECTED BY BECAUSE IT NINETEEN
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE UNABLE
TO OBTAIN NEEDED HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AN INABILITY TO PAN THE
PRIVATE MARKET. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THEIR EXPANDING MEDICARE ACCENT
BY ELIMINATING THE MEDICAL
AFFECT MEDIC CAL ACT THAT HAVE.
BEEN YEARS IN PERSONS WITH
DISABILITY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN HAVING HEALTH
COVERAGE. FOR HAVING THINKING.
OF A WONDERFUL DAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HOW OFTEN THE PROPOSAL-
SEVENTEEN IF YOU THOUGHT THAT
THIS OFFENSE- GOOD THING ABOUT
THIS BAND- AND WE COME AND
VISIT WITH THE TELLER REPAIRMAN
AND BACK ON THE STOCK- BUT WE
ALSO- DISTRIBUTED SB THIRTY
FIVE OFF. THE CARD. THANK YOU
THE COLOR PLAY. NOW THOUGH-
TURN IT OVER TO WOULD YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO PLEASE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU ARE OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS PHYLLIS GATHERING
A LOOSE AND I CURRENTLY SERVE
AS A VISUAL ARTS COORDINATOR
FOR REGIONALLY AN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO ENDING HIV
EPIDEMIC PROVIDING SUSTAINABLE
RESOURCES FOR LGBTQ I PREFER
PEOPLE OF COLOR MY GRANDMOTHER
SHE HER HERS I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS AND EQUITY
FUND I HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
INVEST IN THE HEALTH AND MY WE
HEARD. OF TRANSGENDER GENDER
NON CONFORMING AND INTERSEX
PEOPLE THANK YOU SO MUCH I HOPE
EVERYONE HAS A GREAT DAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. HI THERE GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS BIANCA BLOOM QUEST I'M
MISSING YOUR POLICY MANAGER FOR
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY FOR
FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE RESEARCH
EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
A NETWORK OF APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS I AM HERE NOW MALL
BUSINESS OWNERS PROVIDE ROUGHLY
HALF OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR JOBS
AND ANY CONVERSATIONS REGARDING
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY IN MONTHS AND
COULD MONTCLAIR'S LIKE OURS- WE
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO KEEPING THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA MARKETPLACE
AFFORDABLE ESPECIALLY FROM MALL
BUSINESS OWNERS RELY ON THE
CURRENT PREMIUM SUBSIDIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY SET TO EXPIRE AT
THE END OF NEXT YEAR. WE HAVE
TO EXPAND- WE HAVE TO EXTEND
THE SUBSIDIES TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE ABLE TO AFFORD
HEALTH CARE FOR BOTH THEMSELVES
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
WORKERS. ARE WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO I ENSURING THAT
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE AND
FINALIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WE URGE THE
STATE TO REPURPOSE THOSE FUN TO
CONTINUE TO WORK FOR- MORE
AFFORDABLE HEALTH INSURANCE FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FINALLY SIXTY YOU OPEN.
I THANK YOU MORNING- MY NAME IS
AND ON LAND WHAT THE
TEMPERATURES AIDS FOUNDATION
AND THE AND THE EPIDEMIC
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THE COACH
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THE CARD IS
A LINE. WE'RE HEARING STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE AND THE EPIDEMIC
BUDGET PACKAGE REQUEST. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE BUDGET EQUEST
CONSTRUCTING PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. EIGHTY REQUEST
IS TO TEACH YOU CAN TARGETED
INVESTMENT THAT SUPPORTS THE
MINIMUM EFFORT NECESSARY TO
CONTINUE TO THE DRAFT DEMOCRATS
HIV VIRAL HEPATITIS. C. I. OVER
DOES IT ONLY WORSENS DURING
COVENANT. I WANT TO SPEAK
QUICKLY TO THE ONE MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND INVESTMENTS
THE FUND OVER FIVE YEARS.
QUICKLY CHECK OUT. HUH OKAY
COSTS. FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THE REQUESTED BY
ALL A FEW AGE TO BE A GROWING
AND ALARMING RIGHT YOUNG PEOPLE
HOW JURY BY THE- OPIOID OTHER
DRUG HI. WHAT YOU MADE WELL
ACROSS OF THE- MY AGE GROUP ON
OVER FIFTY. CALIFORNIA'S
WEDDING WITH HEP ARE EVEN. THAT.
THE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
WHICH PROVIDE.ON WE BRINGING
LINKAGE CARE OPTIONS BROWN. AND
HCV. THE THIRTY ACROSS QUICKLY
DIFFICULT TO FIND. THE SAME
CDOS ALSO CLEAR COATS WERE ON
HEALTH MARGINALLY HOUSE INSURED
PEOPLE USING DRUGS YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND OTHERS WHO HAVE
LIMITED ACCESS TO TRADITIONAL
HEALTH CARE COULD. BE TO
SIGMUND EXPLANATION. THE
FUNDING. WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THE MOST VULNERABLE. ANOTHER H.
H. HE ADDED AND ALSO MIGHT CARE
ABLE TO CURE H. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VERY MUCH YOUR TIME.
CALLER MISTER MOTOR. WE WILL GO
LINE TOOL FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MA'AM SHARON MEMBERS MY
NAME TO BE THOROUGHLY EXPLAIN
WHAT THE NONPROFIT HEALTH
EDUCATION COUNCIL MEANT THE
SENATE LEADER ON A PROJECT THAT
SERVES MEDINA IMMIGRANT AS PART
OF THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT IN
SACRAMENTO YOU'RE LOOKING OF
LOOKING. STANISLAUS PLASTER AND
OTHER COUNTIES ALONG WITH A
PARTNER AT THE CONSULATE
GENERAL MAKING GOING TECH
pMENTAL AND SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSAL TO SUSTAIN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECTS TO FIFTEEN MILLION TO
THE GENERAL FUND OR ANY OTHER
SPECIAL FUNDS. THANK YOU
SENATORS FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
CARP. ONE NINETY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
GENERALLY PROMOTE FROM INLAND
CARE GIVER RESEARCH CENTER THE
RAVAGES OF THE NINETEEN HAVE
AMPLIFIED THE NEEDS OF FAMILY
CAREGIVERS ACROSS THE STATE
PARTICULARLY IN BLACK AND
LATINO COMMUNITIES. WE NEED
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS TO
BUILD AN EQUITY AND INCLUSION
COURT TO END TO INCREASE
SERVICE LEVELS AND DIVERSE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PLEASE. WHO WHO-
ONE YOU ARE OPEN. WELL MOVING
ALONG A LITTLE NINE TO TEN.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE MY NAME IS JOHN MALOOF
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
PROJECTS ENTERED THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DELMARK CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTER. ALL RAVAGES
THE COLD WOULD HAVE REALLY
CAUSED PROBLEMS AND CHALLENGES
FOR A LONG TERM CARE SYSTEM
WHAT I NEED A LONG TERM CARE
SYSTEM IS FAMILY CAREGIVERS
FAMILIES ARE THE BACKBONE OF
LUCK WITH OUR LONG TERM CARE
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE OVER EIGHTY
PERCENT. OF ALL SERVICES. WE
NEED. TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND
SUPPORT FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
IN ORDER TO ALLOW THEM. TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT TO THEIR FAMILIES I
HEARD YOU TO SUPPORT THE-
REQUEST FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CAN FAMILY CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS. TO
BUILD IN EQUITY INCLUDING CORPS
TO INCREASE OUR SERVICE LEVELS
TO FAMILY CAREGIVERS WROTE THE
STATE. THANK YOU ADEQUATELY
DEVELOP A STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
CULTURED HUMAN MYSTICALLY
COMPETENT STAFF. AND RESOURCES
TO SERVE ALL. YOU CAN. I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN AGAIN I'M STRONGLY
SUPPORT YOU TO THE STATE THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER.
THANK YOU FOR PLEASE. TO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
COMMENTING ON TO PUBLIC HEALTH
PROPOSAL ARE HERE HE PROPOSED
SUPPORT AND IS A CO SPONSOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT
PROPOSAL THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES A DECADE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY TO SHORE UP
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO STUDY THE CURRENT
pPUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT. THE
FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO REPAIRS
IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND NOT LEAVE
THE INVESTMENTS MADE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND ESURE WE HAVE OUR
RESOURCES AND WE ARE PREPARED
FOR THE NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AS WELL TO ADEQUATELY
SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES THE
PROGRAM BUT YOU NEED TO CALL
THESE IMMUNIZATIONS ENVIRONMENT
HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
HEALTH AND SO MANY MORE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME MANAGER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COURT
PLEASE. MY TO TWO YOU ARE A
GOOD THIS IS LYDIA BORN. THE M.
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION. WHAT DO
YOU THINK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE CONTINUOUS MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR WOMEN WHO ARE TWELVE MONTHS
POSTPARTUM AS WELL AS CHILDREN
ZERO TO FIVE YEARS. WE KNOW
THAT THE ORDER FIVE UNIT IS A
CRITICAL TIME IN A CHILD'S
DEVELOPMENT AND ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES IS
PARAMOUNT TO ADDRESSING ANY
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS. R. FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR BLACK WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES OF
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY. AND
ACCESS TO CONTINUOUS HERE
AFTER. A TWELVE MONTHS AFTER A
DELIVERY WE BELIEVE CAN ASSIST
AND REDUCE REDUCING ANY
UNTOWARD EVENT. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE CONTINUE WITH MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR POSTPARTUM WOMEN
TWELVE MONTHS POSTPARTUM AND
FOR CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE'LL GO
LIVE TO TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. TWO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE ON
MUTE. MOVING ALONG A LITTLE.
TWO TWENTY FOUR. HELLO YES MY
NAME IS DR LYNN SILVER I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN AND SENIOR ADVISER
AT THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
AND THAT ALMOST A PROFESSOR YES
YES I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY
PROPOSAL. WHEN BLACKHAWK
NETWORK OFFICE THE TO THE
LEGACY OF EMIGRATE SYSTEM AND
OUR CELL HERE TO INVEST IN
UPSTREAM HEALTHEQUITY IN
PREVENTION TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE. HAS
GOTTEN US TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY
IN THE PANDEMIC PANDEMIC ITSELF
IN TURN HAS LED TO MASSIVE
INCREASES IN MESSAGE FROM
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
PEOPLE CHILDREN ADULTS NOTABLY
IN OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
PROPOSAL WILL SUPPORT TRANSFORM
COMMUNITY LED INVESTMENT THE
COMPANY BY ACCOUNTABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES HARDEST
HIT BY KOPET. IMPORTANTLY IT
WILL ALSO REQUIRE REPORT BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS ON LONGER TERM
APPROACHES. THE FUNDING
BUILDING HEALTHEQUITY IN
ADDRESSING SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH WHICH CAN ALSO ACT TO
PREVENT ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. THE CONSEQUENCES
OF OUR PAST DECISIONS HAVE
NEVER BEEN SO OBVIOUS IF WE
DON'T CHANGE THE WAY WE FUND
HEALTH. WE WILL NOT CHANGE OR
HEALTH OUTCOMES. IS REQUESTED
PONDERED BY PH DIS THE
CALIFORNIA BLACKHAWK NETWORK
LET YOU KNOW COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA APPEALED AND
SPORTED BY HA ELLIE CHILDREN'S
TRUST. OUR CLINICS AND OTHERS.
MY BIG WILL FUN ISN'T THE ACUTE
NEEDS AND COMMERCIAL TERM SO
MEDIA. PROPOSED IN. WILL PLAY A
CRITICAL AND COMPLEMENTARY ROLE
IN HELPING OUR HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES COME TOGETHER TO
BUILD INNOVATIVE AND MORE TRUST
LOCAL SOLUTIONS ON ISSUES LIKE
TOXIC HOPE THE FOOD COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTS- AND OTHER
DETERMINES THAT LEAVE OUR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS WILL NOT
FALL. IN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO TWENTY
FIVE. YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
GERMAN BIRD MY NAME IS DR AS
AND- TO STAY UP TO TRANSFORM
ALSO THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
A GENDER JEFF TO PARLAY WHICH
IS A GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION
BUILDING THE POWER OF
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING COMMUNITIES IN
LOS ANGELES AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. OF CALIFORNIA- HE ENDED
UP THAT WAY IT LED BY AND FOR
GENERAL CONFORMING NINE BINARY
IN EXTENDED THEIR BLACKNESS
TRAIN PEOPLE HOW- NEED CLEANING
ORGANIZING LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT RELATIONAL
ORGANIZING AND POLICY ADVOCATE
IN JUNE MAKING CONCRETE CHANGES
IN THE LIVES OF ALL TRANSGENDER
NONCONFORMING PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
LOW INCOME. BY POCKET WE ARE
ALSO INTERESTED IN BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES COLLECTED POWER
TO FIGHT FOR RACIAL GENDER AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND PART OF
BUILDING ECONOMIC JUSTICE IT'S
MAKING SURE THAT VULNERABLE AND
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITY WHICH IS
THE TRANS AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING AN INTERSECTION
UNITY IS ABLE TO ACCESS MY
SINGING FUNDS AND SO I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE TRANSGENDER WELLNESS IN
EQUITY FUND. I HOPE THAT-
CALIFORNIA CAME BACK IN THE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS AND OVERALL
MY WE HAD OF THE TRANSGENDER
NONCONFORMING AND INTERSECT-
PEOPLE AND THAT WE ARE ALSO.
LOOKING FOR A MISSING BUT ALSO
A CO SPONSOR- THE TIME THAT
TRANSIT GENERAL EXPERIENCE THAT
pPEOPLE ARE PRIORITIZE THEIR
LIVES ARE LITERALLY DEPENDING
ON I THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO TWENTY SO YOU ARE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS RESUME I
WOULD MEDICAID THREE FOR SOME
OUR FAMILY GIVING WHICH- OF
ONLY DURING THE PANDA AND
EXISTING CARE GIVER ARE. EVEN
GREATER BURDEN BEFORE WE NEED
YOUR SUPPORT PUBLIC CARE GIVER
WE CENTER TO INCREASE SERVICE
LEVELS FAMILY CAREGIVERS BROWN
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY ONE
SEVENTY TWO YOU ARE UP. I
REPRESENT AND CAREGIVERS
CHILDREN HAVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTHCARE NEEDS. OUT WE ARE AT
THE CORNER OF THE BECAUSE FOR
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR EXAMPLE.
REPORT THAT'S WHAT
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MEDICARE.
NOT ONLY THE FRAUD THEM KNOWING
THE BATTLE BUT IT WORK THANK
HOPE THAT. THAT WE CAN THRIVE
DESPITE A FAMILY HEALTH AND THE
THANK YOU FOR THE AND STOPPING.
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
COLOR PLAY. THANK TO TWENTY
NINETY ARE OPEN. MORNING MY
NAME REALLY BUT FIVE NORTH
KOREAN MY AT THE OKAY HERE ECOG
STATUS DE. AND ONE IS ONE OF
THE THREE FIVE YOU CAN BE SURE
LOOK FOR ON P. OR. NINE HUNDRED
AND CONNECTED TO THE START WITH
THE- WITH THE- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND HAVE A GOOD DAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE WILL OPEN UP ONE ONE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS OSCAR SANDOVAL
ON THE SENIOR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH THE LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING
BECAUSE OUR ORGANIZATION IS A
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY FUND-
JUST PERSONALLY SPEAKING BEFORE
THIS I WAS HELPING OUT WITH
THAT FRESNO COUNTY'S. CODE
EQUITY PROJECT AND A LOT OF
THAT PROJECT WAS IT FELT LIKE
WRITING BE INSTRUCTION MANUAL
AND HAVING ALL AT THE SAME
TIME. AND THANKS TO THAT
PROJECT WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
INROADS OF WHAT THESE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT ARE
UNDERSERVED. AND THE LAST THING
WE WANT IS FOR ALL THAT EFFORT
TO BE THROWN AWAY. BECAUSE ALL
THESE NONPROFIT AND VIDEOS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS NO
LONGER HAVE THE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO CONTINUE THAT
OUTREACH. SO WERE STRONGLY
PAPER THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
HELP EQUITY FUND BECAUSE- WE
NEED TO. ADDRESS ALL THE GAPS
IN HEALTH CARE THAT TOO MANY OF
OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO FACE. THANK YOU AND
HAVE A GREAT DAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE WOULD I TWO THIRTY YOU ARE
OPEN. YES HI. HELLO- AFTERNOON
THIS IS- MY NAME IS GO SHINY TO
LEARN ON THINGS THAT- DIRECTOR
OF MY WITH WHAT IS A LOT
AMERICA. POSTAL SERVICE FOUNDED.
I'M HERE SUPPORT OF THE FOR.
BANK ACCOUNTS REDUCE DESPAIR
BONTA THIS MILLION FROM THE JET
FUND OR ANY OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS
TO AND PROGRAM BECAUSE MORE
YEARS THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY COLOR. TWO THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE SECOND MANY IS
NOT A VALID WHEN I LIKE THEM
COALITION FOR CAL. AND WE ARE
PROUD TO ON YOU ABOUT EQUITY
FINE IT ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE
HEALTH AND WOULD BE FINE TO
ADDRESS THE DOUBLE HOW PUSH IN
AN EFFORT THAT HAVE BROUGHT BY
CARBON. WE KNOW THAT TODAY
THANKS WILL BREAK INCREASE BUT
BASS HARD ILLNESS AND PREMATURE
DEATH YOUR TO COME UNLESS WE
**** OUT WHAT THE BIKE. THE
HELP AND FINAL FINISHED LOCAL
PARTNER MOUNT QUITE AND HARBOR
OREGON. TO ADDRESS THE MEDIA
THE COMPANY OF AUGUST DEDICATE
FUNDING TO DEVELOP COMMUNITY
LED SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE LONG
TERM HEALTH OF WHAT NEXT A
POSITIVE LONG TERM HEALTH OF
LIGHT NEXT BLACK AND INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES. I JUST HEALTH
OUTCOMES REFLECT THE LONG TERM
IMPACT OF STRUCTURAL RACISM IN
COMMUNITIES AND WITHIN PUBLIC
HEALTH BUT THE HEALTH EQUITY
FUND PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RIGHT THESE WRONGS. WE SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA EQUITY FUNDS
WITH THE VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
I'M HERE BECAUSE I'M COMING
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND SECURE
THE FUTURE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE MEDICARE FOR ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE SENIORS
REGARDING IMMIGRATION STATUS
REQUEST THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TWO THREE THREE
YOUR OPEN. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THE MY IS A LOT
THERE LESS THAN A WITH THE
NATIONAL HOPE ONE. I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR CHILDREN DIRECTOR AND
MONTHS PART OF PARCEL WE SHOULD
WILL TAKE OF CAN CHEW AGE BY.
AND ADULTS FOR TWELVE MONTHS
FOLLOWING PREGNANCY CONTINUED
CARE COVERAGE IN THE TO
ACCORDING TO THING CARE
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PHASE IN
THE LIFE WHEN MEDICAL BUILDING
ARE SO FREQUENT AND WHEN CARE
COULD IMPORTANT COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR JUST. EXPERIENCING OF THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE MEDICARE
COVERS THE GREATER SHARE
FAMILIES OF COLOR BUT I CAN'T
HAVE THE UNIQUE ROLE IN THE
DRAFTING THE STRUCTURE RACISM
THAT CLOTHING. WILL BE FELT BY
REMOVING BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
CARE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE WILL HUNDRED. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI IS A DOCTOR TREATS OR
INDEPENDENT ACTING DR THANK YOU
THE PAST THIRTY YEARS. I'VE
BEEN CHRISTIAN CALIFORNIA. I
WOULD LIKE IT'S MY STRONG FOR
CAL- BECAUSE VISION. RESTORING
MEDICARE OPTIONAL BENEFIT FOR
CHIROPRACTIC. NO BENEFIT
SHARING MODIFYING OR THE TO PAY
THAT AMOUNT CHALAMET TO A
TWENTY FOUR ANNUAL VISIT HEN
THAT ENERGY TO PROVE THIS
PROPOSAL. JUST A BRIEF MENTION
I'VE BEEN A LEADER CAL AND NOW
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN
PROVIDER FOR NEARLY THOSE.
THIRTY YEARS I THINK THE
RAVAGES OF OPIOID ABUSE IN A
FAR DOWN. OR COUNTY. AREA THE
REPORT MAYBE HEALTH. HEALTH
CARE. THANK OUT TREATMENT OF
YOUR I JUST PERFECT CARE OF THE
THANK YOU. IMPORTANT THAT THE
LIVER OF. NON DRUG THERAPIES
ABOUT YOU SPEAKERS. IF THAT
MEANS UP THERE AND PLAN
PARTNERSHIP HELPS. NOW RIGHT
NOW YOU WOULD TREATMENT THANK
YOU MUCH FOR YOUR CALL YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE. WE WILL
TO LINE TWO FORTY PLEASE GO. I
TO FORTY PLEASE ON MUTE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ELENA
ALLIANCE AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ACCESS SUPPORT
NETWORK WE ARE A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SERVING SANTA
BARBARA FAMILY THIS BILL
MONTEREY AND SAN BENITO COUNTY
CALLING INTO COURT IN THE END
THE EPIDEMIC BUDGET ASK AND AS
WE KNOW HOW CALIFORNIA'S- AT.
TWO FORTY STILL WITH US. SIR
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN NOW
MY APOLOGIES- AS WE KNOW IT
SMALL AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS ARE
BEING IMPACTED AND START YOUR
LIMITS DURING THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC- YOU KNOW THE STATE
HAS SEEN AN INCREASE IN
OVERDOSE DEATHS RELATED O
HEROIN INSIDE NOW I THINK WE
FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVEN AND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND 6
RESPECTIVELY BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. ON A PERSONAL NOTE
I'D LIKE TO MENTION THAT MY
FAMILY WAS PERSONALLY IMPACTED
BY THIS AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE AT THE
COURT AND CONFIRM THOSE FUNDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO OH SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. WILL BE ONE WILL GO TO
FORTY TWO. MADAM CHAIR DANNY
OFFER WITH THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NANI CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT FOR THE NINE POINT ONE
MILLION PER PEER SUPPORT START
UP. I DON'T THINK I CAN TELL
YOU ANYTHING ABOUT THIS YOU
DON'T ALREADY KNOW SO I JUST
THINK THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. VERY NICE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHEN NINETY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS ON MELMASON
I AM THE- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AND CLINICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
VILLAGE PROJECT THE CORPORATION
WHICH IS BAY COMMUNITY BASED
ON. YOUR HEALTH- BECAUSE WE
FOCUS MORE ON HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IN SEASIDE
CALIFORNIA- R. I. P. P. AS
COLIN YANTRA WHICH IS- BY
MAASAI WORD MEANING WARRIORS
CAMP- WE STARTED OUR PROGRAM-
FOUR YEARS AGO LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE I WOULD PART OF THE I. P.
P. A PART OF THE- CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT.
AND WE'RE PART OF- THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN- WE STARTED OUT WITH A
CHILDREN'S OUR GRADES K.
THROUGH FOR BECAUSE IT WAS OUR
PROMISE THAT- WHEN AFRICAN
AMERICANS OUR CHILDREN OUR
CHILDREN OF AFRICAN HERITAGE A
LEARNER CHIU IDENTITY THAT THE
STRENGTH THAT THEY GET FROM
THAT WILL GO FAR IN TERMS OF
ARE PREVENTING. ANY KIND OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT WOULD
BECOME A SEVERE AND DISABLING-
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY I THINK REDUCE
STIGMA AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE
TO GET OUR PROVIDE EARLY
INTERVENTION FOR A LOT OF OUR
YOUNGSTERS WHO WERE BEGINNING
TO SHOW BURGEONING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES SO WE WERE ABLE
TO. DO THAT AT AN EARLY AGE
WITH THEM- THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT HAVE GOTTEN THEM THROUGH
TO PANDEMICS ARTICLE BID AND
THE POLICE MURDERS OF BLACK
PEOPLE. SO- WE ARE. YES OUR
DATA. THE SENATE REALLY ARE
GRANTED BUT- OKAY MILLION IN
TIME. BUT WE'RE GOING TO THE
PRO. AND SO WE CAN CAN TO CARRY
OUT WHAT IS THE MISSION. THAT
WAS GIVEN TO ALL OF US AS A
RESULT OF THE PASSAGE OF THE
NUMBER OF SERVICES ACT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I'M SORRY I WAS NEEDED
TO FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO FORTY FOUR PLEASE RE QUEUE
AGAIN AND I WILL GO TO LINE TWO
ELEVEN. TWO ELEVEN. HELLO
AFTERNOON MY NAME A PLETHORA
FIREFOX ALLEN AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT HUMBOLDT
AREA CENTER FOR HARM REDUCTION
OF FULL SPECTRUM HARM REDUCTION
ORGANISATION IN EUREKA AND I'M
ALSO A CORE MEMBER OF HUMBLE
HARM REDUCTION COALITION AND
ENGAGE WITH MANY OTHER GROUPS
WORKING ON THE FRONTLINES
COMBAT HIV AND HCV INFECTION%
RATE. I'M CALLING TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE ANTI EPIDEMIC
COALITION BUDGET REQUEST
PACKAGE AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY
WE'VE SEEN A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN SUPPORT THEM TRACTION OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS AND OUR
COMMUNITY HAS FOUR TIMES THE
INFECTION RATE OF HEPATITIS C.
AS STATE AVERAGE WE HOPE THAT
THE STATE LEGISLATURE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT ANY
ACADEMIC FUNDING AND THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO ATTEMPT TOP
TALKER EDUCATION TESTING
SERVICES AND SUPPLIES THAT WILL
HELP REDUCE INFECTION RATES IN
OUR COUNTY AND OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA WITH ALREADY FACE IN
THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS H. N.
HIV STI HEPATITIS AN OVERDOSE
CASES BEFORE THE PANDEMIC COBIT
NINETEEN IT'S MAKING IT SOUND
AS EVEN WORSE THAN FURTHER
EXPOSING DECADES OF HEALTH
INEQUITIES DRIVEN BY CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING OF OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEM
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND OTHER SOCIO
ECONOMIC FACTORSWELL EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS BECAUSE IT NINETEEN
OR PERMANENT TO THE LIVES OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS THE STATE MUST
REMAIN A STRONG COOK IN
COMMISSION STRONG COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING THE ONGOING CRISIS
OF HIV HCV AND ATV ANNA
TRANSACTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. TWO FORTY FOR PLEASE
AHEAD. TWO FORTY FIVE YOU ARE
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE
CAN'T YES. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DOCTOR CESAR CASTANEDA I AM THE
MENTAL HEALTH ADMINISTRATOR FOR
LA FAMILIA COUNSELING CENTER
WHICH IS A PART OF THEY LET YOU
KNOW HOW CERVANTES DAY
COMMUNITY IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THEIR PROPOSED FIFTY MILLION IN
A ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THIS
SURPLUS OF THE GENERAL FUND OR
ANY OTHER BUDGET STORES THIS
YEAR TO SUSTAIN THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WILL OPEN UP ONE TWO FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE MEDICARE
SENATORS ERR GAS ON THE AFTER
MARKET ON ITS OWN FOR THE
MEDIGAP COVERAGE FOR TWELVE
MONTHS POSTPARTUM AND CHILDREN
AGES ZERO TO FIVE BELOW EVEN
BEFORE THE CURRENT HEALTH
PUBLIC PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION
ALREADY FACES SEVERE MATERNAL
MORTALITY OR PRETTY CRISIS.
WERE STILL BLACK AND AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE WEBER
ALREADY MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
PREGNANCY RELATED CAUSES THAN
NON HISPANIC WHITE WOMEN LOOK
AT LEAST ONE THIRD MATERNAL
HEALTH. MATERNAL DEATHS
OCCURRING IN THE POSTPARTUM
PERIOD NOW THE PANDEMIC IS
HIGHLIGHTING THE EVEN GREATER
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH OUTCOMES
AMONG YOU NEED A COLOR I DO
FIND CAUSE OF MATERNAL
MORTALITY OR BABIES COMPLAINT
AND COVERAGES ONE FACTOR A
RESEARCH PROBABLY INDICATE THAT
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE GROW ONE
GROUP THAT YEARS THE CENTRAL
GROUP- TO. AND TREATMENT AT
SOME OF THE CONDITIONS THAT
PLACE WHEN THEY'RE HARVESTED
FOR PREGNANCY RELATED
COMPLICATIONS INCLUDING
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE DIABETES
AND CHRONIC HYPERTENSION
STRUGGLE JUST GETTING ON THE
WAY TO SAY THAT ADMINISTRATION
BACKING SURPRISING TO POINT B.
POPULATION SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED RENDON'S BIRTHDAY
COVERAGE OF THE STATE SOURCE TO
THE PROCESS OF DETERMINING
WHICH GENERALLY IS WILL MAKE
ROLE MAINTAIN COVERAGE. THE ON
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HOW. WILL WE WILL ALIGN. TO
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORE MADAM AND MEMBERS
THIS IS. SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF TRIAL
AND FAMILY. WE ARE SUPPORTING
TO. THIS MORE. THE FIRST OF THE
COUPLE FOR A FOR SEVEN NINE
GENERAL FUND AND- TO STAND UP
ATTIC CAL YOUR- SPECIALIST
CERTIFICATION. AND THE SECOND
AND JUST THE CORE CHILDREN TO
PUT. EIGHTY TWO FIVE MILLION
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL. FOR BETWEEN
SCHOOLS AND- HEALTH. TAKEN
TOGETHER WE BELIEVE THESE
PROPOSALS WILL GO A LONG WAY.
TOWARD SUPPORTING THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM IN OUR
STATE. BY BOTH INVESTING IN A
VALUABLE WORKFORCE AND ALSO
INVEST THE FUNDS TO DO MORE.
FOR KIDS IN SCHOOLS WHERE OUR
MEMBERS ARE SEEN AT TREMENDOUS
SPEED THANK YOU SO. MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO THIRTY FOUR YOU
AREN'T. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TRACY RETREAT FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE AND I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY FUND
THE PROPOSAL REQUEST A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF A HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
OVER THREE YEARS TO CREATE A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY FUND
THAT WILL ADDRESS THE
DEVASTATING HEALTH AND SOCIAL
INEQUITIES. THAT HAVE BEEN
ROBBED BY COPE WITH NINETEEN
FUNDING WOULD FLOW TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS CLINICS TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
LARGE AND SMALL KNOW WHAT
ISSUES ARE MOST DEEPLY
IMPACTING THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THEY KNOW WHAT STRATEGIES ARE
MOST EFFECTIVE THEY MUST HAVE
DIRECT FUNDING AND BE EMPOWERED
TO WORK HAND IN HAND WITH LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO CRAFT
SOLUTIONS. THAT MEET LOCAL
NEEDS WITHOUT DEDICATED FUNDING
TO LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
OFTEN LED BY PERSONS OF COLOR
WE CANNOT BEGIN TO DISMANTLE
THE STRUCTURAL RACISM THAT HAS
LED TO HEART BREAKING HEALTH
INEQUITIES IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TWO FIFTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND I'M
CALLING YOU AFTER SUSTAIN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES PROJECT WE ARE A CO
SPONSORING THIS REQUEST AND
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
INNOVATIVE AND SUCCESSFUL
PROJECT THAT THIRDS UNDERSERVED
RACIAL ETHNIC LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY I AM ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEDICARE FOR ALL SENIORS
THAT THE ICC PROPOSAL ALSO
ELIMINATES THE MEDIC HOW AFTER
PASSED. I'D START UP FUNDS FOR
PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST AND
HELD BACK WITH THIS PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND STATE I THOUGHT THAT
THESE AND THERE ARE PREMIUMS
UNDER COVER CALIFORNIA BLACK
ONE AND CONTINUE WITH MEDICARE
COVERAGE FROM BIRTH TO AGE FIVE
AND FOR TWELVE MONTHS
POSTPARTUM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN
INSPECTION AFTER A BOMB AND I
WORK WITH THE CHANCE THAT YOU
KNOW COALITION AN ORGANIZATION
THAT SERVES REFUGEE HELPLESS
AND FORMERLY INCARCERATED
TRANSGENDER GENDERNON
CONFORMING AND INTERSEX FOLKS I
AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE TRANSGENDER WELLNESS IN
EQUITY FUNDS AT THE FOURTH
BAGGAGE AND HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
PEOPLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWO FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS ON DR ROLAND MORE
FROM THE PACIFIC INSTITUTE FOR
RESEARCH EVALUATION AND
BERKELEY AND WE'RE HONORED TO
SERVE AS A NATIVE AMERICAN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
TEAM. FOR THIRTY P. I WANTED TO
UNDERSCORE THE TREMENDOUS
SCIENTIFIC AND PRACTICAL VALUE
OF. THESE MULTI METHOD
EVALUATIONS BUT BOTH THE LOCAL
AND THE OVERALL- LEVEL OF FOR
ALL THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS THE
TRUTH CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE
AMERICANS AND MANY OTHER
INTERESTED GROUPS AND
ENCOURAGE. ME TO VALUATIONS
WILL HELP TO SOLIDIFY THE
EVIDENCE BASE FOR STRUCTURED
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
PRACTICES THAT SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSERVED.
POPULATIONS ABOUT IN
PARTICULAR. DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND AFTERWARDS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX
COURT PLEASE. WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. EXCELLENT
SENATE THE EGGMAN I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU DO THAT I JUST WANT TO
GIVE YOU AND YOUR STAFF BECAUSE
THE ALLEGATIONS MY NAME GIVEN
THE NEW YORK. I WORK WITH THE
WORK PROGRAM IN LA AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH
A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND THE
DISCIPLINES EVERY MOM. IN LA
FIRING AND SAN BERNARDINO. I'M
CALLING FOR SOMETHING THAT NOT
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN FOR
BECAUSE THE EXEMPTION PER WEEK
LOCAL AGENCY CONTRACT. YOU KNOW
WITHOUT THE FLEXIBILITY YOUR
UPON YEAR I READ TONS FUNDS
THAT HAVE GONE FROM USDA FOR
RICK SERVICES AND IT'S ALL
BECAUSE OF THESE CRAZY LINE
ITEM IF YOU CAN'T HOLD IT FROM
HERE TO THE OTHER ONE. THIS IS
NOT A REQUEST FOR MONEY IT'S
JUST A REQUESTED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND TO KEEP FEDERAL
MONEY IN CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. AND I DO
WANT TO VOICE MY VERY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE MEDICAID
COVERAGE OF POST BOTTOM THEM TO
TWELVE MONTHS AND CHILDREN ZERO
TO FIVE THIS IS MY POPULATION I
WORK WITH THEM I HAD THAT BOTH
CLANDESTINE STORIES RENDON
INCLUDE MEDICAL COVERAGE AT SIX
WEEKS POSTPARTUM BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT YET BEEN PAID FOR
IT- GOD. BECAUSE THE I MEAN
HORRIBLE FOR THE PANDEMIC THAT
BUT WHAT I MEANT BUT BECAUSE OF
THE EXEMPTIONS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
COVERAGE TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO
PLEASE MAKE A TEMPORARY
PERMANENT EFFECTIVE FALL
INVESTMENT HUGE ARE ALIVE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING AND MY GOD I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT YOU EAT THE OPERATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE WILL GO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO THIRTEEN
YEAR ARE OPEN. WE WILL JUST
MOVE ON TO LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHT. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
CLEARLY I CERTAINLY CAN PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU HELLO MY
NAME IS DEXTER AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS EQUITY
FUND- IT IS CRUCIAL THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN THAT IN THE
HEALTH AND LIVELIHOOD OF
TRANSGENDER INTERSEX AND GENDER
NON CONFORMING PEOPLE. BECAUSE
INVESTING IN THE HEALTH AND
LIVELIHOOD AND HE AYE PEOPLE
WILL HELP STABILIZE YEAH I
PEOPLE ARE OFTEN DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST IN MEDICAL PRACTICES
ESPECIALLY WITH IDENTIFICATION
IN RELATION TO THE CARE THEY
RECEIVE. ARMITAGE I LIVE BUT
THE PRIORITIZE ADMIN YOU'RE
TURNED AWAY OR TREATED INFERIOR
TO SEND YOUR FOLKS ESPECIALLY
IN A GLOBAL PANDEMIC- I WANT TO
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
HOPE EVERYBODY HAD A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MCH COLOR. THE
BUDGET LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY HAMMOND YES WE CAN. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DENNIS IN ACCOUNTING AND
COUNTLESS CHIP REFER PATIENTS
ARE YOU I WAS READING QUESTIONS
IN THE CALIFORNIA. I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY STRONG. WHEN SHE
ISN'T. I DON'T EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA QUITE PENSION
SOLUTION PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THE
COLLABORATIVE MEDICARE OPTION
ON BASIS OF THE ADULT
POPULATION AND I WAS ABLE TO
THE THAT I'M NINETEEN MEDICARE
TO RETURN FOR AN RIVER BUT AND
I AM A NEW GOING TO CAME FROM A
DOCTOR OKAY PENSION AND
PERSONALIZED. THE TO THE
BENEFITS OF THAT ACCESS TO A BY
I DON'T UNDER TERRORISM ACT HAS
COUPLE YEARS DOWN THE ROAD FOR
BENEFIT TO HAVE HIT THE. AND MY
LIFE THE WAY I DO IT WITHOUT
HIM I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO
THAT DURING THE DIDN'T. I WILL
CHOOSE YOU ARE SO. IN PRESS.
DONALD TRUMP AND- HAS THE
CHANGES WE. WE SHOULD HAVE TO
CARE OKAY YOU VERY MUCH I'M
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR BUT-
THANK TO HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
THIS BILL. THANK TO SIX TO
REALIGN ITSELF. YES MY NAME IS
SERGEANT GILMER AND I'D LIKE TO
FIRST WELL THANK THE MADAM
CHAIRMAN HONORABLE SENATORS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I AM THE
FORMER CHAIR OF MIDDLE AMERICA
CALIFORNIA HOST OF OTHER AFFECT
STATE AFTER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS. I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
OF THE C. R. D. P. IT'S
IMPORTANCE IN ADDRESSING THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF RACISM AND
BEHAVIOR HEALTH WHICH WE ALL
KNOW HAS INCREASED PROJECT
REPORT. COMMITTEES OF CALLERS
LGBTQ COMMUNITY. WHILE THE
COMMENT THAT I APOLOGIZE FOR
MAKING BUT IS THIS SERIOUS FOR
US ESPECIALLY FOR ME WE LOST. A
LEGACY ADVOCATE LAST MONTH
JANET KING NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY BUT WAS DEDICATED TO
MANY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LGBTQ
DEDICATED HER LIFE TO REDUCING
GRAYSON I THINK DISPARITIES IN
MENTAL HEALTH. IT IS THAT
SERIOUS THAT MANY OF US HAVE
DEDICATED OUR LIVES TO THE TO
SEE RDP IS ONLY 1% OF ALL
IMAGES ICONS IN LIGHT OF THE
FACT ALL OF THE NEEDS. IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LGBTQ IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA PLEASE.
DO THE RIGHT THING NOW'S THE
TIME TO CONTINUE. AND EVEN
INCREASE RESOURCES FOR THIS
YEAR RT P. THANK YOU PROBLEMS.
THIS CALL PLEASE. THANK TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO PLEASE CONTINUE.
OKAY ARAMBULA MY LEVELS THE
COMPONENTS LIKE THAT FOLLOW LA
I AM PART OF THE THIRTY ONLY ON
THAT IS DATE FOR THE PRODUCT ON
I DO SEE HEALTHCARE DESPAIR
ACTING YOU VERY NEXT COLOR
ALWAYS AND I'M. THANK SEVENTY
FIVE THIS BILL. THANK SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
WHEN ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
THANK YOU CAN ADAM SURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS TO
BUILD UP TALK ABOUT PRACTICING.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
THE LAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS I
CURRENTLY WORK AT THE VETERANS
AFFAIRS DEPARTMENT SANTA ROSA.
I'M HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHIROPRACTIC ASSOCIATION'S
EFFORTS TO RESTORE ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT A
COW OPTIONAL BENEFIT FOR
CHIROPRACTIC. YEAH UP FOR
ADULTS AND- MODIFY THE TO A
MEDIC CAL LIMITS FOR MONTHS TO
AN ANNUAL VISIT A LIMIT OF
TWENTY FOUR. VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION HAVE BEEN
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF
CHARACTERS IN THEIR SYSTEM
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FOUND THE CAR
PARK IS A VERY HELPFUL FOR
PEOPLE COULD CONDITIONS. AS
WELL AS TO DECREASED NEED FOR
OPIOIDS. OF ADDITIONAL
IMPORTANCE AS OF MARCH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY NOT PAPER IN
THE JOURNAL OF THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION SOME OF
THEM FOUND THE MOST EXPENSIVE
CONDITION TO TREAT UNITED
STATES OF SPYING CONDITIONS.
AFFECTED MOST OF OR ALL OF THE
MUSCULOSKELETAL CONDITIONS
DIABETES OF CERTAIN
CARDIOVASCULAR CONDITIONS ARE
POOR. I THINK. OUR STREETS
MEDICAL POPULATION- UP TO
CORRECT SOME EFFECT IN OTHERS
BASED. ARE HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU IN YOU VERY
MUCH NICK CALLER PLEASE. TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KERRY
JOHNSON AYE WAHPETON DAKOTA A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST AND I'M A
DIRECTOR AT UNITED AMERICAN
INDIAN INVOLVEMENT IN LOS
ANGELES SERVING THE LARGEST
URBAN AMERICAN INDIAN
POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY. AND
I'M JUST CALLING TO SAY THAT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY
MILLION TO FIFTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITY
PROJECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
A LINE IS NOW OPEN. HEY GOOD
MORNING SHARE MEMBERS LITTLE
HOLDING TOWARDS WITHOUT
ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
OUR REQUEST TO EXPAND MEDICAID
UNDOCUMENTED DINNER IS AN
ACTIVE B. OR R. THE REQUEST. WE
ARE ARMS UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE EXCLUDED
FROM FROM PREVENTIVE AND
PRIMARY CARE COVERAGE UNDER ON.
WE ARE PREVENTED- SORRY THEY
ARE EXCLUDED FROM PREVENTIVE
AND PRIMARY CARE COVERED UNDER
FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL HAVING
ACCESS TO POSTAL MEDICARE WOULD
HELP UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS
ADDRESSED THE VARIOUS CHRONIC
CONDITIONS THAT THEY ARE THEY
STATE. POLICE ARE CONDITIONS
HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED WITH-
WITH THE CURRENT CODE NINETEEN
ENDEMIC WE ARE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY THAN JUST AS AN
AGENCY PROPOSAL TO REMOVE THE
ACT THAT TAX THE AERATION FOR
SENIORS AND MEDIKAL AND
CURRICULA DISABILITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COURT
PLEASE. THANK TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FISCAL AHEAD. THE
MORNING MY NAME IS CHEER FONG
PRESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND THE MANAGING DIRECTOR OF
EAC SACRAMENTO WE WORK WITH
UNDERSERVED API USE SUCH A
SOUTHEAST ASIA THE I'M CALLING
TO EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT
AND FUNDING THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT A
FIFTY MILLION EACH FOR A THREE
YEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHEN ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO BASEBALL AT. THANK
YOU TO YOUR LINE. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. BUT OKAY MY
NAME IS CHLOE REAL QUIET ND
NINE FIFTY EIGHT- ABOUT THE
AFRICAN OF LUCK THE NEXT THE
FIRST AND ONLY TRANSGENDER LED
ORGANIZATION IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE TRANSGENDER WELLNESS
INEQUITY FUND BUDGET REQUEST A
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS I NEVER
GOT LINE NEXT TO PUT THE BUDGET
REQUEST BECAUSE THEY WILL
PROVIDE US WITH THE RESOURCES
WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY TO IMPROVE OUR
QUALITY OF LIFE AND ENSURE
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING PEOPLE ARE NOT
LEFT BEHIND WE KNOW THAT.
MENTAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE WITH FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN RIGHTS THAT IT CURRENTLY
INACCESSIBLE TO MANY
TRANSGENDER GENDER
NONCONFORMING AND INTERSEX
INDIVIDUALS DIGITAL TO ECONOMIC
DISPARITY THAT PLOT OUR SOCIETY
THE BUDGET REQUESTED THE STEP
IN THE DIRECTION OF ALLEVIATING
THE BARRIERS THANK. YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK TO UNDER AND
THREE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I MEAN AND GET THE S.
NINE. OR SHOULD I AM CALLING
TRUMP SUPPORTERS THE TRENCHES
WONDERFUL FOR LUNCH. I HOPE I
HOPE. THAT HELPED LIKELY TO OF
TENS. AMERICANS IN YOUR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE PLAN THAT
WILL BE A- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAX COURT. LIKE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN SIX BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT INSURANCE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS WESLEY IN I'MPOLICY MATTER
PROGRESS ON BEHALF THE ORGANS
COLIN STRAW SUPPORT OF THE ANY
OF DEMOCRATS COALITION BUDGET
REQUEST BACK. TO THE CROWD
DURING SERVICES PROGRAM
OPERATOR IN COMMUNITY HEALTH
HUB IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
TENDERLOIN NEIGHBORHOOD WHY
DOESN'T MATTER HARM REDUCTION
STRATEGY SINCE THE BEGINNING
THE AIDS EPIDEMIC TO CURTAIL
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE AND
REDUCE STIGMA OUR DEDICATED
HARM REDUCTION TEAM PROVIDES A
VARIETY OF NEW LOW BARRIER
SERVICES. MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SAFER AND HEALTHIER ASSOCIATE
SERVICES ARE ALSO AN ENTRY
POINT FOR MANY OF OTHER
PROGRAMS TO THE PRIOR TO THE
START OF THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA SORRY FACED
WITH PERSISTENT CHALLENGES
POSED BY DRUG OVERDOSE HIV STI
AND HEPATITIS C. TRAGICALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
SITUATION'S WORSENED AND THE
NEED FOR ASSOCIATED SERVICES.
AB FIVE ALMOST BARBEL NEIGHBORS
AND LOVED ONES PARTICULARLY
THOSE RIGHT THE INTERSECTION OF
HOMELESSNESS AND DRUG USE
RICK'S PAINTING A BUNCH OF
THESE CONSEQUENCES THE FIGHT
BEHIND OUR COLLECTION
INTERVENTION TO DEMOCRATIC
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ROBERT ABOVE AND UP ON THE
PRESS AND CEO OF SOUTHERN
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER WHERE
ONE OF ELEVEN BROTHERS- CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS INSTEAD
CALIFORNIA SERVING FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION INFORMAL FAMILY
CARE GIVERS. YOU KNOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS REALLY TAKEN A
TOLL ON THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING PARKED UP THE CHARACTERS
GREATER LEVELS THAT WE'VE EVER
EXPERIENCED IN OUR HISTORY. AND
AND B. PANDEMIC OF ALSO EXPOSED
THE INEQUITY OF OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM HAS THAT HAVE REALLY
IMPACTED I BELIEVE THE LATIN
AMERICAN AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY IS ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO HELP US CONTINUE OUR
OB FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HELP THE FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION FAMILY CAREGIVERS
AND TO EXPAND AND BUILD OUR
CAPACITY TO BETTER SERVE THE
WHAT THE NORTH AFRICAN AMERICAN
NATION. I'LL GBG I'M DOCTOR
UNDER SECRETARY POPULATION
THANK YOU VERY. VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN SEVEN GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
STAGE DOWNTOWN A CLINICAL
SUPERVISOR WITH AND ONE
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER
FAMILY CAREGIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES HAVE ONLY
INCREASED DURING THE PANDEMIC
AN EXISTING CHARACTER BIRDS ARE
EXPERIENCING AN EVEN GREATER
BURDEN THAN BEFORE WE NEED YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS TO
INCREASE SERVICE LEVELS TO OUR
FAMILY CAREGIVERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. TO DRESS THEIR
CAREGIVING NEEDS THAT THEIR-
AND RECOGNIZE OUR POPULATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
CAN'T HELLO MY NAME IS TO TELL
YOU TO ADJOURNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS THEY HAVE TO JUST
PART OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
HUB OF THE CALIFORNIA REDUCE.
JACK I'M CALLING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT QUESTION FROM ONE
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS ERIN MCCANN
I'M A FAMILY CONSULTANT WITH
REDWOOD CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTER I'M CALLING FROM
HUMBOLDT COUNTY ON BEHALF OF
FAMILY CAREGIVERS IN THE RURAL
AND FRONTIER COMMUNITIES UP
HERE IN HUMBLE AND DELMAR
COUNTY. ADDED STRESSORS OF CARE
GIVING DURING CALL THE NINETEEN
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED INCREASED
BURDENS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE NEED YOUR
SUPPORT AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHARACTER REAPER CENTERS
ADEQUATE ADEQUATELY DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE NETWORK OF CULTURAL
CULTURALLY COMPETENT STAFF AND
RESOURCES TO SERVE ALL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. THANK HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON SO WHAT CLARK HEALTHY
HERE TO THE EAST. THE RDP THANK
YOU. THANK YOU PLEASE. TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR
MAKES WRITER I'M A CHIROPRACTOR
POCKETING FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND SAN MATTEO CALIFORNIA
I CURRENTLY HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
PRACTICE I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHIROPRACTIC
ASSOCIATION'S PROPOSAL TO
RESTORE THE MEDI CAL OPTION FOR
BENEFIT FOR CHIROPRACTIC ADULT
BENEFICIARY. AND MODIFYING A
TWO MONTH MEDI CAL LIMIT YOUR
TWENTY FOUR ANNUAL A VISIT I
ARGUED WITH PREDICTABLE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TAX COURT
PLEASE. THANK TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JOSEPH BEAR AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
TRANSGENDER OF THE TRANSGENDER
WELLNESS IN EQUITY FUND I HOPE
YOU CALIFORNIA WILL INVEST IN
THE HEALTH AND LIVELIHOOD THE
TRANSGENDER GENDER VARIANT AND
INTERSEX PEOPLE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND AGAIN IF YOU'RE
CALLING HEALTH DISPARITIES. DID
NAME AND AN ORGANIZATION AND
THAT YOU SUPPORTED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MASON AND I AM
CALLING FROM OUR THE VILLAGE
PROJECT IN OUR- IMPLEMENTATION
PILOT PROJECT IS THE AMULSAR
PROJECT AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITY- PROJECT EXTENSION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THREE YEARS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. AND IF
YOU'RE CALLING ABOUT GENERAL
DISPARITIES JUST A YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE. OH NO
I'M I'M CALLING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY FUND
AND BE MEDICARE COVERAGE OKAY.
HI MY NAME IS SOMEONE OKAY MY
NAME IS BONNIE ON THE DOWN ON
THE TV- CALIFORNIA BLESSED WITH
HEALTH PROJECT WITH THE ONLY
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING HEALTH AND WELLNESS
BENEFITS ONE POINT TWO MILLION
BLACK GIRL. HOW WE CAN POLICY
ADVOCATES IN EDUCATION AND I
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER MY SUPPORT
FOR FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT- HOW
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY FUND
SPONSORED BY OUR FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES THAT CALIFORNIA
BLACKHAWK NETWORK. WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE FOR YOU DIRECT NOBODY
WILL BUY JUST WANTED TO ADD
THAT AND I THOUGHT THEY WERE
COMING TO SUPPORT THE MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR TWELVE MONTHS BOTH
PARENTS. AND CHILDREN ZERO FIVE
AND A QUARTER BY OPPORTUNITY
COLLEAGUES AT THIRTY FIVE MIKE
TO FIND THE CHILDREN PARTNERS
THAT THE MARKET. THANK YOU FROM
THANK YOU. NICE COLOR PLEASE.
FIND TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT GO
AHEAD. THANK TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY AIRLINE ABOUT. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU ROBIN ROBIN
THE SAN FRANCISCO HEPATITIS THE
FORCE AND ENACTED THE
ORGANIZATION OF PEOPLE OF
HEPATITIS C. AND WE'RE A MEMBER
OF THE AND THE EPIDEMIC
COALITION AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. THE IDEA
THAT THE COALITION COST
EFFECTIVE AND STRATEGIC REQUEST
FOR INVESTMENT TO ADDRESS HIV
STDS. VIRAL HEPATITIS AND THE
OVERDOSE EPIDEMIC I'M ALL A
REALLY CRUCIAL INVESTMENTS BUT
I THINK PARTICULARLY FOR THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR HEPATITIS C. TEST.
IF APPROPRIATED CAUGHT. I'M
THINKING IF I HADN'T THOUGHT TO
FOR HEPATITIS B. R. WOULDN'T BE
HERE T BE ABLE ALREADY THREE
THIS I GOT. BEING TESTED AND
TREATED GAVE ME BACK MY LIFE M.
WE REALLY NEED THESE TIPS TO
HELP SAVE OTHERS- WE NEED THESE
RESOURCES TEST FOR HEPATITIS C.
UP SPECIALLY FOR AT RISK
POPULATIONS OF IF YOU CURRENTLY
HOUSE PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO INJECT
DRUGS AS WELL AS BLACK NATIVE.
PEOPLE OF COLOR POPULATION. AND
REALLY EVERYONE WHO WAS AT
RISK. THANK YOU THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BY TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JESSICA SMITH- I'M WITH
NATIONAL HARM REDUCTION
COALITION AN ADVOCACY AND
CAPACITY BUILDING ORGANIZATION
THAT PROMOTES WELL BEING AND
DIGNITY OF PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED BY DRUG
USE. AND I'M JUST ALSO CALLING
INTO PART OF THE AND THE
EPIDEMIC COALITION BUDGET
REQUEST PACKAGE AND I WANTED
TO- QUICKLY SPEAK TO THE
ADDITIONAL THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CURRENT
EXCHANGE SUPPLY CLEARING HOUSE-
IN MY WORK WITH NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION WE DO
SUPPORT TRYING TO CHANGE
PROGRAM THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE HAVE HEARD TIME AND TIME
AGAIN ABOUT PROGRAM HAVING TO
RATION SUPPLIES ARE COMPLETELY
RUNNING OUT. I'M ALSO THE
FORMER DIRECTOR. OF AN ACTIVE
P. UP HERE AND RURAL HUMBOLDT
COUNTY AND I DO HAVE DIRECTLY
EXPERIENCED- RUNNING OUT OF
SUPPLIES ARE NEEDING TO RATION
WHICH DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
BOTH YOUR- LOW INCOME HOMELESS-
AND EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE USE.
SO AGAIN I JUST ENCOURAGE YU
ALL TO THE PART THAT YOU T.
BUDGET PACKAGE. REALLY TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE
DREAMLAND FOR THE CLEARING
HOUSE FUNDS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS CALLER PLEASE. TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
LOOK THAT LAMB ALAMEDA HELPED
THEM A LEADING HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER MEDICAL TRAINING
INSTITUTION IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM HAVE
PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
THE FUNDING TYPICALLY
NINETEENTH AND THEN IT. THE
HEALTH SYSTEM WITH BEING
SIGNIFICANTLY. OUT ONE I
REMEMBER. MEDI CAL COP. WE
SUPPORT. ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITAL. BILLS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS WITH PRACTICAL. AND
DOLLARS IN THE STATE GENERAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT FULLER. THANK TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT THIS CALL AT.
THANK TWO HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GROWING
THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO LET ME GET THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CABIN CARE AND
PREVENTION NETWORK IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY AND I'M SPEAKING AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF IN THE
EPIDEMIC BUT ALSO REPRESENTING
A CALIFORNIA COUNTY WITH AN
EXTRAORDINARY RATE OF HEPATITIS
C. AN OPIOID OVERDOSE MY CALLS
IN SUPPORT OF ALL P. T. BUDGET
PRIOR. BUT I WILL SPEAK
DIRECTLY. THE CHAO HEARING
SHARE SUPPLY HOUSE. THE
MAJORITY OF HARM REDUCTION
PROGRAMS IN OUR STATE WHY
HONEST HEARING HELP IN
EXPANDING MAC OUT AT THE TIME
AND DEMAND. FOR SUPPLIES. YOU
CAN DO TO ENSURE EIGHTEEN
PROGRAM AND. TWO THOUSAND SIX.
HOW OFTEN SHOULD HEALTH
RESEARCH CONSTRUED. NEXT YOU
FOR THE CARE. THE RANGERS
ANOTHER BY REMAIN THE MOST COPY
HM AIDS PREVENTS TOUR THEY ARE.
AND A VITAL CAN OF TO MEDICAL
AND BEHAVIORAL WELL IF. THANK
YOU THIS ORDER THREE THANK YOU
THANK VERY MUCH MEXICO PLEASE.
ONE THREE HUNDRED ONE LINE IS
NOW- OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
DANIELLE- I'M CALLING FROM
SAMPLES. OF THE PERSON WHO USES
DRUGS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
MADAM CHAIR AND LET THE
COMMITTEE. FOR BEING CONCERNED
THAT OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY IN THE
PAST YEAR HAVE DIED OF OVERDOSE
ALONE NOT TO MENTION ALL OF THE
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY
ASSOCIATED WITH- DISEASES
ASSOCIATED WITH- SYRINGE ACCESS
OR LACK THERE ALL. THANK YOU-
FOR SUPPORTING AND TO ADD THE
ACADEMICS PARTICULARLY- THE
SYRINGE CLEARINGHOUSE. I
CLEVELAND IS THAT THEY MY LIFE
A NUMBER OF TIMES AS WELL AS
OPEN OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO
HAVE A MENU OPTION TO IMPROVE
MY LIFE IN OTHER WAYS. THANKS
FOR CARING ABOUT US DON'T
FORGET ABOUT US WHAT WERE YOUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN ROUTE
pEFFECTIVE DECISION TO GET ON
THE RIGHT BY THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
WITH THE POLICE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NICE COLOR.
THANKS THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
LATEST OPEN. THANKS THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY LINE IS NOW
OPEN LET ME. YES HI MY NAME IS
BRIANNA BY I HAVE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN A SIMPLE MODEL
PROGRAMS SUCH AS JOURNEY TO
EMPOWERMENT I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCE DISPARITY
PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I DIDN'T GET.
HELLO HELLO YOUR TURNING HERE
TO MAKE THIS GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELLO. HELLO PLEASE CONTINUE.
YEAH BUT I'M NOT BEING THERE
MOST LOOK AT THE APPLE YOUNG
BOTH. I'M NOT I DON'T. AND THEY
DON'T HE IF I REFUSED BE YOUR.
ARE YOU MUCH OF A YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T COMFORTABLE WE GOT FROM
CANADA. YEAH YEAH. YES YES NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK THREE
UNDER AND NINETY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORE THE IS JIM LIMBER FOR THE
COMMITTEE ON LET- CAL. I WANT
TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR
MEDICAL FOR INCOME ELIGIBLE
SENIORS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE SUPPORT
ELIMINATING THE MEDICAL AFTER
TEST SENIOR SOME PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE TRANSGENDER
WELLNESS AND EQUITY FUND
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
HELLO CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNA HEY
WHAT I WORK WITH THE NATIONAL
HARM REDUCTION COALITION AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE AND THE
EPIDEMIC COALITION AND THE
CALIFORNIA SYRINGE EXCHANGE
PROGRAM COALITION. I'M
INTERROGATORIES DEMOCRATIC
PACKAGE AND I WANT TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THE PEOPLE THE
PROPOSAL THAT REQUIRES AN
INCREASE IN THE STATE DURING
JULY CLEARING OUT. IN MY JOB I
WORK WITH ALL OF THE STATE
SIXTY THREE IN JACK THE
PROGRAMS AND WHILE MOST OF THEM
CANNOT ATTEND TODAY I CAN
TESTIFY TO THE CRISIS PROGRAM
FACED BECAUSE OF SUPPLY
SHORTAGE THE RATIONING SUPPLIES
WHICH GOES AGAINST THE DC AND
CDPH THAT PRACTICES. GRATEFUL
FOR THE HISTORIC IMPACT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION MADE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO SUPPORT STAFFING IN
THESE PROGRAMS HOWEVER THESE
FUN CANNOT BE USED FOR SUPPLIED
NOR CAN ANY FEDERAL FUNDING IS
REQUESTED BUDGET INCREASE WILL
ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO EXPERIENCE
THE FULL BENEFITS OF THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ALREADY
INVESTED IN THESE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS FOR HUNDRED AND TEN
PLEASE GO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND RUBIO ON OF POWER.
BIRTHPLACE OF TO MILLION
DOLLARS I'M GENERAL BUDGET
REQUEST THAT WE ARE
COSPONSORING WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION TO
HELP OFFICERS ASSOCIATION THE
STOCK AND OTHER COUNTIES TO
ADDRESS THE LONGSTANDING
EROSION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
SECOND WE SUPPORT THAT THREE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME AND ONGOING GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES TO FIND A
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION SECOND
ACTUALLY FORGET THAT WATER
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
TRULY NEED AT FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. THIRD WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND BUDGET REQUEST THAT WE ARE
ALSO COSPONSORING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HOSPITAL AND
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO HELP
SUPPORT A PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEM THAT HAVE BEEN
FINANCIALLY HIT HARD BY THE
PANDEMIC. AND NOTHING TO
SUPPORT HELP FOR ALL BREAK THE
ENGINE OF BOTH COSMETIC COUNTER
THE REMAINING LOW INCOME
UNINSURED AND UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY TO THE
SENIOR POPULATION THANK. YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK THREE HUNDRED AND SIX
DAYS AGO. HELLO MY NAME IS
BALDWIN AND I AND IN SUPPORT OF
THE TRANSGENDER WELLNESS IN
EQUITY FUND I HOPE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN INVEST IN THE
HEALTH AND LIVELIHOOD OF HE G.
I. PEOPLE. THANK YOU FOR THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR YOUR WATER
LINE IS NOW OPEN. TO MOVE ON
THE COUNTY. MY NAME AFTER
COUNTY FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY FROM NINETEEN AYE IN
THE COURT YOU BRING YOU INTO A
BOOK PROGRAM IMPLEMENTED BY
CREE AND COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
SOFTWARE AND INTEGRATED
SERVICES UNDER CALIFORNIA
REDUCING A DISPARITY PROJECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR PUT
IN FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
COLONIES. RIGHT I. DON'T BLAME
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN. LAST
WORD. OKAY FORTY LARA HELLO THE
NUMBER IF I BASTANTE YES YES
FOR YOUNGER BUT OUR YOU SAYING
YOU WANT TO PRESS MONEY AND
IT'LL HEAT BUT I CALL BARRA
ORANGE. HOW DO YOU ORANGE AN
IDEA BUT I'M THE NAY FOUR FOUR
WON'T ARE REMEMBER OKAY YOU YOU
ARE NOT A PROBLEM WHEN YOU THAT
IRAQ YEAH CANNOT IN ARE THE YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MODERATOR
FOR FINE WORK TODAY I TO THANK
HERE IN THE WHO ASSISTED. ON A
DELEO FOR ALL THE OF ALL OF
THESE AND THANK EVERYBODY WHO
CALLED IN TO EXPRESS YOUR YOUR
CONCERN- YOUR POSITIONS ON
PLEASE IF YOU IF YOU DIDN'T GET
A CHANCE TO SAY EVERYTHING YOU
WANT TO SAY THAT COMMITTEE IS
ALWAYS WILLING TO HEAR MORE
PLEASE CONTACT US THROUGH
EMAIL- M. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING ON BEHALF OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
THAT CONCLUDES. THIS BUDGET SUB
THREE MEETING.